Hallo Wolfgang! Hallo Stefan!
Warum hast du so einen blauen Haken?
Ja, du hast ja auch einen. Stimmt. Okay, warum haben wir so blaue Haken?
Wir haben so blaue Haken, weil sie uns anbietet und sie uns schmücken.
Nein, das ist natürlich nicht die richtige Antwort. Es war so.
Ich sah irgendwann bei dir, der nie einen blauen Haken hatte bislang,
dass du einen blauen Haken hast.
Darauf fragte ich, was ist da los? Und du sagtest ja, dann musst du,
Elon, Geld bezahlen und zwar etwa acht Euro je nach Abo, was man da abschließt im Monat.
Warum habe ich jetzt einen blauen Haken und hatte vorher keinen?
Ich wollte nie als Bittstelle auftreten und Twitter schreiben,
hallo, ich heiße Wolfgang M. Schmidt und guckt mal, hier ist mein Wikipedia
und hier war ich mal im Fernsehen. Ich glaube, ich bin berühmt,
ich brauche einen blauen Haken. Das war mir immer zu doof.
Nun kann man für diesen blauen Haken Geld bezahlen.
Das war aber jetzt für mich nicht ausschlaggebend, dass ich diesen blauen Haken
haben wollte als Erkennungszeichen oder um irgendwas deutlich hervorzubringen,
denn der blaue Haken hatte ja vorher immer eigentlich nur die Funktion zu sagen,
ich bin besonders wichtig, meine Tweets sind Premium.
Mir ging es um eine einzige Sache, nämlich um diese Authentifizierung,
die man jetzt vornehmen kann, wenn man dafür bezahlt.
Das heißt, dieser Account ist besser geschützt. Und da ich eine Reichweite von
über 50.000 Followern habe, ist mir der Schutz dieses Accounts, dieses Geld wert.
Denn ich würde und deswegen muss ich das natürlich über diese Plattform tun
oder auch über andere wie Instagram und Co. Und ich sehe.
Das Problem darin natürlich, dass Elon Musk kein toller Typ ist und ich sehe
auch das Problem darin, wenn Privatleute so viel Macht über eine so große Plattform
haben, aber das ist ein generelles Phänomen und Problem.
Das ist ja auch etwas, was man bei Instagram, Facebook kritisieren kann.
Dass Elon Musk jetzt dafür acht Euro nimmt für etwas, was man eigentlich auch gratis anbieten kann.
Ja, das ist so, das ist ärgerlich, das ist aber unternehmerische Freiheit und
ich kann diese moralistische Hyperventilierung überhaupt nicht nachvollziehen,
die jetzt mit dieser Debatte um den blauen Haken einhergeht.
Für mich läuft das auch unter Komfort, denn es macht ja doch ein bisschen Ärger,
wenn einem wirklich der Account gehackt wird. Und das kann ja über Session Cookies
und so weiter relativ zügig passieren. Also man ist da gar nicht so gefeit vor.
Und wir haben ja letztens Mick verloren im Twitter-Versum.
Micks Account wurde gehackt. Wir haben alle bei Twitter Bescheid gesagt,
das ist wirklich der Account von Mick gewesen.
Bitte gebt ihn zurück. Aber die Antwort war entweder gar keine,
Twitter antwortet ja nicht mehr.
Oder eben, ja, wir können das nicht überprüfen. Das ist ein ernstes Problem.
Also, wir können jetzt nicht einfach jemanden im Account wegnehmen.
Egal, wie fischig der aussieht, das ist dann irgend so ein Bitcoin-Irgendwas
gewesen und so. Und ich erlebe das auch als eine sehr merkwürdige Diskussion.
Also, ich find's eigentlich 200 Prozent amüsant.
Äh, der blaue Haken wird ja nun wirklich unter ... Ah ja, da steht hinter deinem
Namen wie ein Doktortitel ansonsten davor.
Das ist total übertrieben, was der blaue Haken bedeutet.
Das ist ein Distinktionsmerkmal.
Dabei geht es nur um den Funktionsumfang. Mir geht es weniger darum,
dass ich Probleme hätte, dass andere Leute sich als Stefan Schulz anmelden und als ich ausgeben.
Sondern ich möchte gerne meine Tweets editieren können.
Und ich nutze nicht allzu oft, Videos über zwei Minuten Länge zu posten.
Aber das hat ja alles mit so was zu tun.
Das ist aber jetzt möglich, wenn man Twitter Blue hat. Ich habe diese ganzen
Fiktionen natürlich noch überhaupt nicht ausgetestet, sondern wollte nur diese
Authentifizierung haben und damit ist das egal.
Also mir würde die Authentifizierung auch reichen, ich brauche den Haken nicht
dazu, dass der Haken jetzt signalisiert schaut her hier bezahlt jemand acht
Euro an Elon Musk, ist doch eine Scheindebatte.
Also worüber reden wir, worüber reden wir denn jetzt hier eigentlich?
Ich meine, also was mich, ich muss das jetzt auch mal hier namentlich erwähnen,
was mich wirklich empört ist, dass jemand wie Jan Böhmermann sagt,
nun könne man alle Arschlöcher sofort erkennen, also alle Leute,
die jetzt noch einen blauen Haken
haben, die zahlen ja Elon acht Euro und deswegen sind sie Arschlöcher.
Jan Böhmermann hat eine Millionen Reichweite auf Twitter, er ist der wichtigste
deutsche Twitter-User, er generiert mit jedem Tweet, den er abgibt.
Hunderte tausende euros für das unternehmen von elon musk
diese plattform ist so wertvoll auch
für den deutschen medialen diskurs weil solche
premium accounts wie die von jan böhmermann tagtäglich
dort die debatte anheizen das heißt wenn jan böhmermann dieser plattform schaden
will dann muss er da runter dann darf er nicht mehr wert generieren diese acht
euro die er da zahlen würde sind nichts gegen das was er eigentlich elon musk
einbringen Eigentlich müsste es ja bei Twitter wie auch bei anderen Social Media
Plattformen so sein wie bei YouTube.
Bei YouTube laden wir ein Video hoch, dann wird eine Werbung davor geschaltet
und man bekommt glaube ich etwa 60 Prozent Anteil. Irgendwie sowas ist das.
Das heißt jeder profitiert davon.
Man kann natürlich immer noch sagen, das ist nicht genug und was weiß ich und
ja man wird damit in der Regel nicht reich, wenn man nicht jetzt irgendwie so
ein Unsinns YouTuber ist.
Aber da gibt es einen fairen Anteil.
Das gibt es natürlich bei Twitter nicht, da schafft man die ganze Zeit Geld
für diese Plattform, Betreiber, bei Instagram ja genauso und wird nicht daran beteiligt.
Das ist aber eine grundsätzliche Debatte, die zu führen ist und dann ist die
Frage, wer übernimmt dann stattdessen Twitter.
Ich bin mittlerweile auch sehr skeptisch, in welche Hände sollte man es legen.
Also es gibt sicherlich Unternehmer, die da besser wären als Elon Musk,
der natürlich eine ganz, ganz verquere Free-Speech-Idee hat,
wenn er sagt, ich spreche mit der BBC und danach mit Tucker Carlson und tut
so, als sei das einfach nur die andere seriöse Seite der Presse,
nämlich eine konservativere.
Das ist natürlich Irrsinn, aber wenn ich jetzt darüber nachdenke,
dass irgendwie so Leute von Volksverpetzer, ja,
dieser Homepage, die geschrieben hat, wer nutzt jetzt Twitter-Blue,
irgendwie sowas haben sie geschrieben, dann in der Überschrift,
Mörder, Kriegsverbrecher und sonst was, und dann frage ich mich,
was bin ich jetzt darunter?
Ja, also ich meine, wenn diese Leute, die diese politisch korrekten Kindergartentexte
schreiben, wenn die jetzt kontrollieren müssten, wer bei Twitter was machen
darf, geht's mir auch schlecht damit.
Also bis zum nächsten Mal.
Twitter ist halt ein Kulturkampfplatz und jetzt ist halt Twitter selbst über
seinen Eigentümer auch Teilnehmer daran.
Ich finde das alles immer noch wahnsinnig amüsant. Es ist aber so,
dass Twitter für mich eigentlich die Quelle fast, also von vielem ist,
sagen wir es mal so, entweder durch direkte oder indirekte Kommunikation,
die mich erreicht, für alles Mögliche.
Also ich habe zum Beispiel das alten Republiksbuch, da habe ich ja auch hinten
im Literaturverzeichnis Tweets aufgenommen wie wissenschaftliche Studien.
Denn wenn Marcel Fratscher irgendwas twittert, dann macht er das ja nicht aus
heiterem Himmel, sondern möchte das mit einer Botschaft verkünden.
Und das nehme ich dann genauso ernst, wie man es an Universitäten nicht darf.
Aber ich bin ja ein Sachbuchautor und kein wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter und
deswegen erlaube ich mir da einfach Tweets ernst zu nehmen.
Wir werden heute über Chat-GPT noch mal reden. Da ist auch viel durch Threads
zustande gekommen, dass man sagt, das ist eine interessante Studie,
die lese ich. Oder ich rezipiere einfach den Thread und weiß da schon Bescheid,
warum wir es vielleicht doch mit einem Papageien zu tun haben.
Twitter Blue hat dann eine sehr superinteressante Funktion.
Nämlich, dass ich einzelne Tweets nehmen kann und sie wegspeichere.
Man kennt ja dieses, mein Like, schreibt man dann so in die Bio,
mein Like ist nicht immer ein Like, Ich kann mir auch nur Sachen für später
merken. Das ist ja gar nicht nötig, denn man kann sich Tweets seit einer Weile
mit Lesezeichen vermerken.
Plus, als Twitter-Blue-Kunde kann ich das auch in verschiedenen Ordnern tun.
Was für mich wahnsinnig hilfreich ist, denn ich hatte über die fünf Jahre,
in der ich Material gesammelt habe für die Alten Republik, immer das Problem,
wie speichert man eigentlich Tweets? Und zwar so, dass man sie übersichtlich einfach wieder hat.
Ich habe dann solche Sachen wie Pocket benutzt oder Pinboard usw.
Und dann kann man sich zwar entweder, also da wird dann als Titel,
wenn ich es automatisiert wegspeichere, einfach geschrieben, das ist ein Tweet.
Also wenn ich bei Pocket meine Tweets, die ich mir wegspeichere,
aufliste, sehe ich einfach nur eine Spalte lang Tweet, Tweet,
Tweet, Tweet, Tweet. Ich muss jeden einzelnen anklicken, um zu sehen, worum es da geht.
Wenn ich das bei Twitter intern mache, kriege ich einfach wie eine fertige Tweet-Liste,
wie eine Timeline die Tweets, die ich mir gespeichert habe, zu einem Thema.
Ich habe also eine unglaubliche Materialsammlung, die mit null Aufwand entsteht
und die ich dann, wenn ich sie auswerten möchte, wenn ich nämlich mein Arbeitstag,
Buch, jetzt übertrage ich alles in mein Citavi, habe ich einfach eine 1A-Liste
mit den Inhalten und kann die so schnell durcharbeiten wie sonst nichts.
Und na klar ist mir das 8 Euro wert. Und ehrlicherweise wäre mir auch 80 Euro im Monat wert.
Aber du bist jetzt wieder ein sehr spezieller User.
Ja, aber mein Familienbuch wird, wie bei der alten Republik,
natürlich zur Hälfte aus Material stehen, das mir durch Twitter zugespielt wurde.
Diese Bedeutung hat Twitter immer.
Genau, deswegen sage ich, du bist da ein sehr spezieller User.
Also mehr als 8 Euro muss es jetzt für mich nicht sein. Ich finde eigentlich
8 Euro auch schon zu viel.
Jedenfalls löst ja nicht, jetzt ist das Problem nicht dadurch gelöst,
indem man sagt, ich bleibe bei Twitter, Verzichte aber jetzt auf den blauen
Haken, wie das jetzt einige dieser reichweitenstarken Accounts machen wollen.
Und auch, ich meine, Böhmermann hat seine Tweets, die er über die Jahre verfasst
hat, als Buch veröffentlicht, als gebundenes Buch und da nochmal Reibach mitgemacht.
Also dann muss mir doch niemand irgendetwas noch erzählen,
ja das sind Leute die haben Millionenverträge bei Spotify, ja Spotify ist eine
Plattform die versucht das Podcastgeschäft auf ihre Seite zu holen und es nur
noch als kommerzielle Sache zu machen und zwar nur noch eine die voll und ganz
aufgeht im Plattformkapitalismus.
Spotify ärgert sich im Prinzip, dass es sowas wie die 29er gibt,
wo es noch außerhalb Möglichkeiten gibt, wie Steady oder so,
dass es also nicht alles über Spotify läuft.
Und das sind Leute, die extrem von diesem Plattformkapitalismus profitieren, Böhmermann und Co.
Und versuchen jetzt mit so einer Virtual Signaling Idee von,
ich habe aber keinen blauen Haken, sich als bessere Menschen darzustellen.
Ja, das ist so, als würde ich mir ein SUV kaufen mit 500 PS und würde aber dann
nochmal draußen dran schreiben, aber ich habe keine Sitzheizung.
Also das muss natürlich sein. Man muss jetzt nichts übertreiben.
SUV ja, aber ohne Sitzheizung.
Also bei Böhmermann müsste man sich auch nochmal sehr genau anschauen,
ob seine Fernsehquoten wirklich reichen für die Karriere, die er da hinlegt oder ob nicht. das CDF.
Auch mit viel internem Widerwillen, weil er ja auch dafür vor Ohre sorgt,
ihn, sich ihn nicht einfach als Aushängeschild leistet, so wie man ja auch Funk.
Und ich habe heute angesichts unserer großen Macron, Lagarde,
Baerbock und so weiter. Die Welt ist in Aufruhr.
Keine YouTube Clip Show zum Thema Funk funktioniert jetzt gerade gar nicht mehr.
Und alle rennen irgendwie weg und diskutieren nur noch, warum Funk nicht mehr
funktioniert bei YouTube.
Also das scheitert ja alles rechts und links.
Es gibt eine sehr große Welle.
Ja, Mensch Stefan, das sind ja mal Nachrichten hier. Du wolltest doch mal Positives mitbringen.
Genau, ja, also wir werden es ja auf jeden Fall noch behandeln,
aber Leeroy, der Interviewer, der immer so...
Dieser Schreckliche, ja, ja.
Der hat jetzt Funk verlassen.
Ja, der hat sich ja jetzt einfach eine Reichweite so aufgebaut,
dass er die nicht mehr braucht.
Genau, der hat das begründet mit, bei Funk kann man keinen Gewinn machen,
was bedeutet, er konnte nicht für die Gäste, die er hatte und die wirklich Hilfe
brauchen, noch einen Hilfeaufruf machen.
Und zwei Minuten später geht es dann darum, dass ja sein Unternehmen,
also seine Interviews, 20 Leute arbeiten für diese kleinen Filmchen.
Und er möchte jetzt, das hat er dann nicht mehr ausgesprochen,
aber das ist natürlich wahrscheinlich der Haupttenor seiner kleinen Ansage,
dass man natürlich, wenn man aus dem öffentlich-rechtlichen Kosmos ausbricht,
also seine Videos monetarisieren darf, dass man dann ein bisschen mehr als das
Festgehalt, das Funk regelt, bekommt. Mitbekommen.
Vermute auch, ja. 20 Leute, aber was machen diese 20 Leute? Man würde sie gerne
mal kennenlernen, denn es kann nicht journalistische Arbeit sein.
Das wäre eine lustige Clipshow geworden.
Wir können sie ja noch mal zusammenstellen für die nächsten Male.
Vielleicht für die Live-Show, dass wir dann nochmal Funk abarbeiten.
Ja, zum Beispiel, wie sehr viele andere YouTuber sich fragen,
20 Leute, also deine Frage, und dann so ein bisschen rumrätseln,
was man mit 20 Leuten macht, obwohl nur zwei Leute zu sehen sind,
die man halt abfilmen muss.
Naja, es geht jedenfalls drunter drüber bei diesem öffentlich-rechtlichen und
Böhmermann wird als blauer Haken des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks noch gebraucht.
Genau. Böhmermann ist der blaue Haken des öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunks.
Ja, und deswegen werde ich den blauen Haken jetzt auch vorerst behalten,
denn wir haben es im Influencer-Buch schon geschrieben, die Lage auf den Plattformen ist immer eine prekäre.
Ja, auch wenn man eine große Reichweite hat, kann man sie ganz schnell verlieren,
weil irgendwas sich ändert oder irgendein Unternehmer durchdreht und ja,
das ist so. Das finde ich auch schade.
Im Sozialismus wäre es anders, kann ich hinzufügen, aber ich kann jetzt auch
nicht versuchen, in dieser Medienwelt eine moralische Instanz zu sein dadurch,
dass ich irgendetwas nicht mache.
Also dass ich jetzt sage, ich mache alles mit, nur noch dieser blaue Haken,
also da kriegt er mich jetzt nicht, diese acht Euro, die bekommt er nicht,
das ist schon maximal albern.
Nun springen wir...
Erst einmal dazu, dass wir darauf hinweisen, dass wir wieder einen Salon aufnehmen
werden in einer Woche und dann geht es um ein Buch, das heiß,
heiß, heiß diskutiert wird. Wird es diskutiert?
Wird das Buch diskutiert?
Haben wir es? Genau, du hast natürlich für dich recht. Also es wird diskutiert,
dass es das Buch gibt, aber über den Inhalt dieses Buches werden wir dann mal sprechen.
Da sind wir dann auch tatsächlich in der Minderheit. Es soll nämlich gehen um
noch wach, den neuen Roman.
Ja, es ist auch als Roman ganz dick unterschrieben von Benjamin von Stuckrad-Barre.
Und da wird ja gemunkelt, es gibt einige Parallelen zu einem großen deutschen
Medienkonzern mit einer berühmten Zeitung, die vor allem aus Bildern besteht.
Wir werden dem nachgehen. aber es soll jetzt nicht so sehr ein Roman für uns
sein, wo wir noch mal schauen, haben wir hier es mit einem Schlüsselroman zu
tun, sondern wir müssen natürlich das Phänomen als Ganzes erläutern.
Wir müssen auch mal über literarische Kriterien reden, denn ich sage das ganz
offen, ich habe irgendwann mal angefangen Solo-Album zu lesen von Stuckhardt-Parr
und hab's dann wieder in die Ecke gedonnert, weil es mich nicht interessiert hat.
Für mich war immer die Frage, warum soll Woll ich.
Einen Golf fahren, wenn der Rolls-Royce dasselbe kostet. Nämlich so ist es ja
auf dem Buchmarkt. Deswegen habe ich immer Brad Easton Ellis gelesen.
Ich brauchte nicht die deutsche Gartenzwerg-Version davon.
Aber ich werde mich trotzdem diesem Buch in alle Offenheit stellen.
Und möchte aber auch schon mal ankündigen, dass es müssen die Ärmel hochgekrempelt
werden bei Stuckrad Barre, bei diesem Buch.
Und auch bei dieser ganzen Debatte darum. Und auch was diverse andere Medienproduktionen
gerade anbelangt. Denn ich habe zum Beispiel auch diesen Podcast mir angehört,
Boys Club, der mit dem Springer Verlag abrechnet.
Und ich finde da einiges sehr, sehr dubios,
aber ich würde doch sagen, ich bin dafür, dass das eher etwas für den Safe Space
Salon ist, weil ich mir doch da, ich will mal so frei von der Leber wegreden, weißt du?
Ja, ich auch. Wir werden heute dennoch als letztes Kapitel dieser Ausgabe hier
außerhalb unseres Salon Safe Spaces,
kurze Anmerkungen zum Buch, beziehungsweise zur Debatte drumherum machen,
denn ein paar Auffälligkeiten gibt es doch und wir werden natürlich im Salon,
wir lesen selten Romane, ich sowieso eigentlich nie.
Ich habe einmal einen Roman besprochen in der FAZ, das war The Circle von Dave Eggers.
Auch ein Buch, das sich ein kompliziertes Verhältnis zur Wirklichkeit,
in der wir so leben, sucht. Und diesmal haben wir es ja wieder so.
Und ich denke, wir haben es mit dem Buch zu tun, das wir sehr ernst nehmen.
Also wenn wir schon einen Roman lesen, werde ich den Text sehr ernst nehmen
und mich einfach und dann auch für uns fragen, was fühle ich denn,
wenn ich einen Roman über Machtmissbrauch lese? Und darum scheint es mir ja
auch vorrangig zu gehen, wenn man dem Autor folgt.
Wir lesen trotzdem nachher ganz kurz in das Spiegel-Interview mit Stuttgart-Bacher
ein, in dem nämlich nicht über sein Buch geredet wird, sondern nur über den
Springer-Konzern und so weiter und so fort.
Und er macht super interessante, wo man wirklich auch mal auf den Wortlaut achten
kann, Anmerkungen dazu.
Plus Stuttgart-Bacher wurde ja ein bisschen ge-highcheckt. Er kam an einem Mittwoch.
An dem Montag zuvor kam ein Podcast und noch Woche zuvor an einem Donnerstag kam ein Zeittext.
Diese beiden Produkte haben einen ganz anderen Auftrag.
Und mischen sich aber ein in Stuttgart-Bares Anliegen. Und zwar,
finde ich, illegitimerweise. Und das werden wir nachher noch mal am gesprochenen Wort ...
Du meinst nicht, es handelt sich um eine konzertierte Aktion?
Nein, es handelt sich ...
Es gibt doch gewisse Verbindungen der Produzenten eines Podcasts und des Romanschutzstellers
zu einem gewissen Verlag, wo das alles publiziert ist, dieses Buch,
nämlich Kiepenheuer & Witsch.
Und wenn man dann noch Verbindungen von Kiepenheuer & Witsch zu ...
Die Erzählungen, die später kommen werden, und Fehler strafen.
Aber ich werde nachher ausdrücklich, ganz explizit, und es ist mir auch ganz
wichtig, behaupten, es ist keine konzertierte Aktion, sondern es wurde der Anschein erweckt, es wäre.
Und das halte ich aber für ein riesiges Problem darin, wie die Debatte gerade
organisiert wird. Sagen wir es mal so.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, über das Inhaltliche des Romans sprechen wir dann lieber.
Ich habe es auch noch nicht, ich habe nur die ersten beiden Kapitel gelesen.
Im Selfspace, ich muss, also mich wundert, mich wundert eigentlich vieles,
also man, und zwar von allen Seiten. Also man, naja.
Wir sprechen außerdem noch über ein kleines Buch von Alexander Kluge,
das heißt Kriegsfibel 2023.
Alexander Kluge, über 90, musste noch mal etwas zu Papier bringen.
Angesichts des Krieges ging es nicht anders. Und er hat hier,
das finde ich schon interessant, am Anfang gesagt, dass er vor allem seinem Lektor dankt.
Denn eigentlich war das ein viel, viel umfangreicheres Buch.
Und es sei so schwer, dann etwas daraus zu entfernen. Eigentlich war dieses
Buch auf 400 Seiten angelegt. Und dann haben sie das alles rausgenommen,
was dann doch vielleicht nicht rein muss. Und so sind sie bei 128 Seiten geblieben.
Darüber sprechen wir auch.
Außerdem möchte ich, ach das machen wir später, gut, wir wollen nur noch darauf
hinweisen, der Salon ist buchbar über Apple, da gibt es auch in der Regel,
Keine Probleme oder ein Support, an den man sich wenden kann.
Für Apple ist ja eh nur gedacht, für die, die es bequem haben wollen,
die sich nicht noch mal bei Steady anmelden wollen.
Außerdem ist es auch für die, die schon bei Patreon sind, bequemer,
das vielleicht über Patreon zu buchen.
Ansonsten präferieren wir Steady. Wir haben es schon oft betont,
da ist alles, was wir je hochgeladen haben, verfügbar.
Das ganze Archiv also.
Und Steady ist nicht nur über die Seite der 29er und über die Steady-Seite buchbar,
sondern auch über, und da sind
wir wieder im Getriebe des Plattform-Kapitalismus, direkt über Spotify.
Das heißt, wer diesen Podcast nicht über einen, wie heißt es dann,
einen unabhängigen Podcatcher hört.
Ein freien, unabhängigen, wie auch immer, über die Hoheit über den eigenen RSS-Feed.
Ja, wer also das über Spotify macht, der kann auch über Spotify den Salon buchen
und dann freuen wir uns, wenn wir uns da sehen.
Ja, wir haben ja letztens gehört, wir sind das billigste Angebot bei Steady,
denn uns gibt es ja für 2,50 Euro und Steady hat uns mitgeteilt,
wir sollten auch mal überlegen, ob wir es auf 3 Euro erhöhen,
denn wenn man sich heute neu anmeldet mit Produkten, kann man gar nicht mehr
unter einem 3 Euro Monatspreis Sachen anbieten.
Stimmt. Uns lässt man aber noch die 2,50 Euro weiterhin durchgeben.
Und dann haben wir gleich gesagt, dann machen wir das weiterhin so.
Dann ist uns die Inflation egal, wir bleiben bei 2,50 Euro.
Wir springen in die Weltpolitik. Annalena Baerbock war in China,
hat dort sich mit dem Außenminister getroffen.
Wir springen in die Weltpolitik und schließen ja an, wo wir beim letzten Mal
schon waren. Du hast ja den NMTus Vortrag aus Berlin mitgebracht und inzwischen gibt es ihn auch.
Ich habe einen Tweet gesehen, wo auch noch jemand darauf hinwies,
dass wir das auch schon besprochen hatten und es gibt jetzt das Video der Veranstaltung.
Also man kann es nochmal selbst nachhören. Sie werden es mit verlinken.
Es war sehr gut, dass er diesen Vortrag gehalten hat. So ließ sich dieser Monat besser einordnen.
Er wurde vorher schon spontan historisiert, bevor Macron losfuhr.
Wir beginnen aber mit Baerbock. Sie war ja auch in China, ist also dorthin gereist,
um sich mit dem Außenminister zu treffen.
Wir hören uns jetzt mal ein paar Auszüge aus dieser Pressekonferenz an.
Wir haben natürlich auch ausführlich über die Lage in Europa gesprochen,
über den Angriffskrieg, den allein Russland zu verantworten hat und der auch
Deutschland und die Europäische Union unmittelbar bedroht.
Deswegen konzentrieren sich all unsere Bemühungen in Europa darauf,
diesen Krieg zu stoppen.
Ein Mann kann diesen Krieg morgen beenden.
Das ist der russische Präsident.
Wo ist sie da nochmal?
Sie ist da jetzt beim chinesischen Außenminister und hält aber eigentlich eine
Rede erstmal so im Allgemeinen, wie der Krieg nochmal einzuordnen ist und dann sagt sie folgendes.
Aber ich muss offen sagen, dass ich mich frage, warum die chinesische Positionierung
bisher nicht die Aufforderung an den Aggressor Russlands beinhaltet, den Krieg zu stoppen.
Wir alle wissen, Präsident Putin hätte jederzeit die Möglichkeit dazu.
Wir sind jetzt hier bei einem Treffen von Diplomaten und das ist jetzt das,
was man an die Öffentlichkeit gibt, dass man sagt, ja China soll mal,
eigentlich sagt sie ja, mich wundert schon sehr, dass China nicht die Position
der NATO längst übernommen hat.
Ja, hast du Clips von Lula de Silva, so heißt er, der neue und alte brasilianische
Präsident, der war ja auch in China.
Hab ich nicht dabei.
Und wir haben ihn aber alle so halb im Ohr, wie er jetzt auch im April sagte,
die Amerikaner sollten jetzt mal auch und die Europäer auch über Frieden sprechen,
wo auch diese Verdrehung, wo man sich auch wieder fragen kann, ah ja, also die.
Ja, jeder vertrete es so, wie er es gerne möchte.
Genau, die NATO-Haltung ist bei uns so präsent, aber im Rest der Welt dann doch
irgendwie nicht. Und das ist ja wirklich hinterfragungswürdig.
Und ich frage mich auch, ob es strategisch klug ist.
Wir werden gleich mal Macron hören, der auch den Krieg anspricht.
Aber vielleicht müssen wir jetzt erst mal dieses Auftreten, das ja jetzt sehr
heftig debattiert wurde.
Ich habe das jetzt nicht noch mal mitgebracht, was da von Precht und Co.
Alles geäußert wurde. Aber es wird ja jetzt sehr darüber debattiert,
wie sollte eigentlich Deutschland auftreten oder wie sollte auch Europa auftreten
gegenüber einer künftigen Weltmacht wie China.
Und es ist ganz interessant, dass wir bei den Grünen eine Strategie jetzt erleben,
die als eine Strategie der Macht durch Selbstkritik betitelt werden könnte.
Denn was sie jetzt sagt, ist erst mal Folgendes.
China hat einen rasanten Aufstieg hinter sich und ist dabei,
eines der mächtigsten Länder der Welt zu werden.
Viele auf der Welt fragen sich, wie China diesen wachsenden Einfluss nutzen wird.
Zur Ehrlichkeit von uns selbst gehört dabei, Europa hat seinen eigenen Aufstieg
vor 150 Jahren mit Expansionismus, Aggression und Kolonialismus verbunden.
Deshalb hören viele genau hin, wenn China verkündet, bis 2049 zur Weltmacht
aufzusteigen Und fragen sich, welchen Weg China dabei einschlagen will und einschlagen wird.
Das finde ich natürlich ein bisschen gemein. Ja. Denn sie unterstellt ja hier
so eine Parallelität in der Geschichte, dass...
Wir wollen mal sehen, wir haben unsere Lektion gelernt, aber wir haben alles
gemacht. Wir haben alles, wir haben alles, Völkermord, alles haben wir dabei.
Haben diesen Aufstieg geschafft und jetzt wollen wir mal gucken.
Also ihr wollt aber doch das jetzt nicht so wie wir machen.
Und ich finde es auch historisch nicht besonders sensibel, wenn man in China
ist und jetzt von den letzten 150 Jahren spricht.
Denn China hatte ja da schon 70 Jahre extrem gelitten. Nämlich wir haben den
Opiumkrieg in seinen verschiedenen Reihen gehabt.
China ist ausgeblutet worden von einem europäischen Land, nämlich von England.
Und danach kam dann der Boxeraufstand um die Jahrhundertwende.
Dann haben wir den zweiten Weltkrieg, der ja bei uns in Deutschland überhaupt
nicht beleuchtet wird im Sinne von, was war da eigentlich in China?
Also man fragt sich ja vielleicht mal als Kind, warum eigentlich Weltkrieg?
Es geht ja vor allem so Europa und Russland und so.
Ja.
Die Chinesen haben, die Schätzung gehen da auseinander, aber ca.
20 Millionen Tote im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Die haben unglaubliche Opfer gebracht, die haben auch natürlich mit ihrer Politik
auch entscheidend dazu beigetragen, dass dann Japan irgendwann sehr geschwächt war.
Also diese Rolle, also dass man jetzt da auftritt und denen das sagt,
wo die extrem unter dem europäischen Kolonialismus und dann auch noch unter
dem Faschismus zu leiden hatten,
ist schon ein starkes Stück und daraus so abzuleiten,
wir haben jetzt, wir machen ja Restitution, wir geben ja Kunstwerke zurück und
so weiter, wir haben unsere Lektion gelernt, deswegen können wir nun auftreten
als die Besseren, das halte ich für sehr, sehr schwierig.
Ja, und es passt vor allem überhaupt nicht in dieses chinesische Selbstverständnis.
Man hat ja in China, während wir hier immer so eine, na ja, die Amerikaner fangen
so bei 250 Jahren an, wir haben dann noch so das Mittelalter mit eingepreist,
also irgendwie so 1.000 Jahre seit den Städtegründungen.
Und man hat ja dieses Phänomen in China, dass die dort Archive führen seit 4.000 Jahren.
Also, da kann ja jeder durch so ein Dorf gehen und dann sieht er so eine Bäckerei
und dann geht er einfach ins jeweilige Dorfarchiv und guckt so nach,
was war denn vor 2.700 Jahren an dieser Bäckerei. Ah ja, auch schon eine Bäckerei, okay.
Ganz anderes Verständnis von Geschichte.
Plus diese Geschichte ist eigentlich immer unterfüttert, wird natürlich propagandistisch
auch so ein bisschen ausgeschlachtet, gerade jetzt mit dem technischen Vorsprung.
Als die Europäer das erste Mal erkannt haben, dass Holz schwimmt,
hatten die schon ihre Flotte fertig in China.
Die Erfindung des Papiers, ah ja, es war gar nicht das europäische Pergament
und so, sondern in China hat man schon 500 Jahre vorher, wie man jetzt weiß
und so weiter, auf Papier ähnliche Sachen gemalt.
Und jetzt gerade führen sie diese Geschichte ja fort.
Die 15 Schlüsseltechnologien sollen bis 2025 unter chinesischer Hoheit sein,
ohne dabei die ganze Welt zu unterjochen
und wie so ein Kolonialherrn in afrikanischen Ländern aufzutreten.
Sondern eben anders. Und da werden wir nachher auch noch mal so ein paar Clips
hören. The Daily und so. Auch in Amerika geht man jetzt sehr kritisch mit diesen
Kamala Harris Besuchen in Afrika um. Wenn man ihnen einfach erklärt,
die Chinesen sind nicht eure Freunde, wir sind es und so.
Weil das Selbstverständnis und die Selbstbeschreibung der beteiligten Länder,
vor allem der afrikanischen, die insbesondere Opfer des Kolonialismus wurden
und der Chinesen, die ihrerseits auch Opfer Und dann ihrerseits aber eine andere,
wir erkämpfen uns unseren Posten in der Welt schon zurück, auch wenn wir ab
und zu mal Dellen haben wie die letzten 100 Jahre.
Da ist das einfach inkompatibel.
Und dass Baerbock dann, und das muss man dann wirklich sagen,
ich fand die Kritik von Precht sehr scharf vorgetragen, aber inhaltlich natürlich
irgendwie doch gerechtfertigt, kann man da so als Lehrmeister auftreten?
Insbesondere, wenn man wie Baerbock aufgrund eines Parteienproporzes es mit
sehr jungen Jahren und ohne Berufserfahrung in diesen Posten kommt und die Chinesen
als Counterpart immer nur 30 Jahre gestellte Berufsverwaltungskarrieristen an
die Spitze der Ämter schickt,
ob man sich auf Augenhöhe begegnet und welche Situation sie da eigentlich für sich nutzt.
Da würde ich auch sagen, so richtig gerechtfertigt ist das nicht,
so eine Pressekonferenz dafür zu nutzen.
Ich finde es auch strategisch nicht klug. Es ist ja eigentlich eine Pressekonferenz,
so schien mir, für die deutschen Medien, die dann sagen können,
toll, jetzt hat sie es Ihnen aber gezeigt, aber sie zeigt es Ihnen ja nicht,
sondern sie zeigt nur den deutschen Medien, dass sie es scheinbar Ihnen gezeigt
hat, während die in China natürlich sehr irritiert sind. Ich will das hier noch
mal ganz klar unterstreichen.
Ich möchte nicht im chinesischen System leben. Und klar ist auch,
dass der Podcast, den wir hier zusammen machen, in China nicht produziert werden könnte.
Aber man muss ja mit den Gegebenheiten leben. Ich kann nicht als Missionar dorthin
rennen und sagen, ich werde besonders laut auftreten.
Dann werden die sich schon nach mir richten. Das wird wahrscheinlich nicht der Fall sein.
Wir haben das auch in dem ganzen Ukraine-Diskurs, in dem man immer solche Sätze wiederholt.
Wir müssen den Krieg gewinnen. Keiner kann aber genau sagen, was das bedeutet.
Wer muss daran mit an einem Tisch sitzen, damit es nicht ein zu hoher Verlust wird?
Das ist eine eigenartige Sache, dass wir so eine Politik gutheißen,
die in den sozialen Medien gut ankommt. Die medial noch mal gespiegelt wird.
Wir werden gleich Macron noch hören, der dann ganz anders rezipiert wurde.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die ganze Welt so darauf blickt, sondern das ist eine
sehr deutsche Perspektive.
Mitunter ist die Perspektive ja nicht mehr überall in Amerika zu finden.
Also es ist auch erstaunlich, dass selbst konservative Historiker wie Nile Ferguson
oder so ganz andere Positionen auch noch mal einnehmen, Zum Beispiel zum Thema
Ukraine-Krieg oder Weltkriegsgefahr.
Nun, wir hören jetzt noch mal weiter, kurz Baerbock.
Davon hängt auch ab, wie sehr wir in Zukunft auf wirtschaftliche Verflechtung
mit China als Europäer bauen können.
Schließlich haben wir unsere Energieabhängigkeit von Russland gerade mehr als teuer bezahlt.
Und Fehler sollte man bekanntlich nicht zweimal machen.
Sie sagt das dem Außenminister. Wir haben einen Fehler mit Russland gemacht.
Wir machen jetzt derisking, weil wir den Fehler nicht noch mal machen wollen.
Ihr könntet ja morgen Taiwan angreifen, sagt sie jetzt so implizit.
Aber ist das sinnvoll, in dieser Weise zu drohen?
Öffentlich auf einer Bühne, Bühne, wo auch gerade die Repräsentation in China
nochmal eigentlich höhere Bedeutung hat als bei uns.
Also die Risking ist ein Diskurs für sich, was das bedeuten soll,
also ob es überhaupt geht. Die Coupling wurde ja einfach nur abgeschwächt.
Die Frage ist, gibt es das überhaupt, dass man ein Risiko rausnimmt,
aber die Verbindung da irgendwie bleiben.
Diese ganze Diskussion, es ist jetzt eine chinesische Globalisierung,
aber es ist trotzdem weiterhin eine Globalisierung, finde ich auch hochinteressant.
Schwingt ja da auch im Untergrund mit.
Dieser Vorwurf oder diese Anmerkung von ihr, wir haben uns ja von Russland abhängig
gemacht bei den Fossilen. Wir sind ja bei den regenerativen Energien und Technologien
abhängig von China, so wie wir vorher bei den Fossilen von China waren.
Russlandabhängig waren, nur da gibt es ja zwei Wege, die man jetzt gehen kann.
Als grüne Partei muss man nicht nur, weil es russland ist, sondern weil es vor
allem fossile Energieträger sind, sich unabhängig machen.
Und dann in dem Falle vom Lieferanten russland. Aber da geht es ja dann eigentlich
ums Klima gehen. Das ist ja bei der Abhängigkeit von regenerativen Energien.
Und wir haben jetzt die Aufstellung bekommen.
Also Fissmann, dieser Hersteller von Wärmepumpen in Deutschland,
geht jetzt so eine Kooperation mit einem amerikanischen Hersteller ein und das
führende deutsche Unternehmen wollte 500.000 Wärmepumpen pro Jahr herstellen.
In China ist aber Gang und Gäbe, dass die Firmen dort 20 Millionen anpeilen als Stückzahl pro Jahr.
Das heißt, so viel Wachstum ist gar nicht denkbar in Deutschland,
insbesondere unter demografischen Gesichtspunkten.
Sollten wir uns wirklich von China abhängig machen oder erkennen,
ah ja, anders als die russische Abhängigkeit, wo es ja darum ging,
fossile Brennstoffe zu kaufen, brauchen wir eigentlich mehr Verbindungen mit
China, weil die uns mit diesen Technologien versorgen können.
Also sollten wir nicht genau den Standard einschlagen.
Autarkie verschaffen. Also Öl brauche ich ja immer wieder. Das muss ja fließen.
Die Wärmepumpen werden ja dann installiert, dann sind die ja da.
Die sind ja dann hier, genau.
Ist ja nicht so, dass ich dann morgen, wenn China mir die Wärmepumpe abdreht,
dass ich da Angst haben muss, das passiert ja dann nicht.
Das ist ja dieser Diskurs wie bei G5, da sind ja geheime Chips drin,
die man dann aus China fremdsteuern kann und dann sind alle Wärmepumpen kaputt, weißt du.
Ja gut, wenn sie das machen, haben wir aber glaube ich ganz andere Probleme
als nur die Wärmepumpe. Sie spricht noch die Menschenrechte an.
Da die Einhaltung der Menschenrechte auch in unserem ökonomischen Interesse liegt,
habe ich meinem Kollegen in unserem bilateralen Gespräch erläutert,
dass wir es mit Sorge sehen, dass Freiräume für zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement
in China immer weiter schrumpfen und Menschenrechte beschnitten werden.
Was dies für Uiguren bedeutet, hat der Bericht der Hohen Kommissarin für Menschenrechte
schwarz auf weiß dokumentiert.
So zugestandenerweise, das ist deutsche Staatsräson, das zu machen.
Man muss aber in Deutschland akzeptieren und mit akzeptieren meine ich so verstehen
und auch die Rationalität dahinter so ein bisschen mitlaufen lassen,
dass das niemals irgendein Chinese mitbekommt, wenn das da gesagt wird.
Da sitzen 20 Journalisten, die dürfen das nicht aufnehmen, die dürfen das nicht weiter verbreiten.
Also es findet faktisch einfach gar nicht statt.
Es findet wirklich nur für den deutschen Journalismus statt.
Und ich finde dennoch gäbe es Einflugschneisen, auch für einen deutschen Außenminister,
dort zu diesem Thema tätig zu werden.
Es gibt ja immer noch diese Besuche, die dann irgendwie so stattfinden,
wo man auch mal gucken muss, wem bringt man da eigentlich Gefahr mit und so.
Aber es auf der Bühne einfach zu sagen, ist, und das ist meine Kritik,
für heute ein bisschen zu einfach.
Also sie macht es sich da zu einfach.
Ich finde es gut, dass sie es anspricht, also dass es ein Thema ist natürlich.
Ich glaube aber, dass das eine reine Demonstration ist von, seht her,
wie sehr ich das anspreche.
Ich erwähne die Uiguren und erwähne noch den Bericht hinzu. Das hätte jetzt
Merkel natürlich nie gemacht, noch mal auf diesen Bericht verwiesen,
ist bei der Sorge darüber, dass Diskursräume sich verengen oder so etwas, belassen.
Aber ich glaube auch, dass man viel klarer zeigen müsste, was man eigentlich
da vor Ort noch tun kann. Und ich meine, wir haben auch da dieses große Problem bei Menschenrechten.
Ich meine, der Außenminister könnte sie fragen aber warum machen
sie gerade so wenig im iran ja das ist
das ist kein whataboutism nein man
macht bei solchen sachen also das
ist wie wenn eine deutsche gewerkschaft 4,8 prozent für seine eigenen mitarbeiter
und so weiter für die eigenen mitglieder fordert man muss immer auch ein politisches
argument darüber machen ja sie hat ja hier kurz angemerkt das hat auch ökonomische
gründe sich für menschenrechte und so weiter das kann durchaus mal ausgeführt
werden bei solchen sachen also so ein paar funktionelle argumente neben dieser
Moral sind dann nicht verkehrt.
Und es ist kein Wortebautismus, darauf hinzuweisen, dass man,
wenn man in China das macht.
Kann man auch einen universalistischen Punkt machen, der alle Menschen in der ganzen Welt betrifft.
Denn das ist wirklich nur gerade eine Bühne für das Thema.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie, wir werden das bei Noch Wach auch noch thematisieren,
alle deutschen Journalisten fragen sich, ist das jetzt ein Springer-Roman,
ja oder nein? Und dann sagt irgendwie
Stuttgart-Wache, nee, das ist ein Einzelfall als Menschheitsfall.
Wir haben versucht, diese Figur irgendwie und alle so, nein,
das ist doch Döpfner, ich sehe das doch und so. Und hier ist das genauso.
Baerbock ist in China und redet
über die Uiguren, aber sie muss so einen allgemeinen Punkt damit machen,
um diese ganzen Waterboard-Tism-Dinge, die nämlich, weil man könnte das ja auch
einfach wie so ein Speer, der gerade auf die Chinesen fliegt,
umdrehen und sagen, ja, die UN sagt, wir haben die letzten 30 Jahre weltweit
so und so viele Menschen aus der Armut geholt, übrigens alles Chinesen.
Das ist also die Leistung der kommunistischen Partei für die UN,
die dann ein universalistisches Argument macht, dass sie sagen,
hör mal zu, das waren alles nur unsere Leistungen und das stimmt alles.
Und deswegen ist das super schwer, solche Punkte dann so zu machen.
Wir werden gleich mal ein bisschen klugen Worte-Bautismus betreiben.
Wir hören jetzt mal gerade einen Ausschnitt aus Makrons Pressekonferenz,
dann mit Präsident Xi saß er dort.
Wir wissen, dass wir unterschiedliche Gesellschaftsmodelle haben und die vereinbaren, die wir treffen können.
Unsere Abkommen nehmen natürlich jedes Mal das Thema der Menschenrechte auf.
Das bleibt ein Thema, das für Frankreich sehr wichtig ist.
Aber nicht, dass wir Meinungsverschiedenheiten haben, bedeutet nicht,
dass man die nicht ansprechen darf, sondern man muss es in gegenseitigem Respekt tun.
Und ich glaube, feststellen zu können, dass das für Frankreich wie für China gilt.
Generell schaffen wir es, Ergebnisse zu erzielen, wenn man sich gegenseitig
respektiert. funktioniert besser, als wenn man sich gegenseitig Lehren erteilen will.
Das ist so ein bisschen jetzt die Merkel-Variante, wir teilen uns keine Lehren.
Ich halte das für den klügeren Weg und dann weiß ich ja nicht,
was im Hintergrund noch läuft. Da kann ich jetzt hoffen, beten, was auch immer.
Aber ich finde, man sollte sehr aufpassen, wenn man lehrmeisterhaft auftritt.
Deshalb, weil natürlich ein Land wie China beobachtet, wie wir sonst auftreten.
Und wir wissen, Indien ist die andere große aufstrebende, möglicherweise sehr bald Weltmacht.
Und auch dort war ja Baerbock vor einer Weile zu Gast. Und ich habe mir diese
Pressekonferenz jetzt extra noch mal angehört, nach dieser chinesischen.
Und dann klingt das so, wenn sie dort mit dem indischen Außenminister Jai Shankar steht.
Heute, fast 75 Jahre nach der
Ermordung Ghandis, besteht zwischen unseren Demokratien ein enges Band.
Ein Band, das uns auf der Grundlage geteilter Werte verbindet,
Menschenrechte, Freiheit, Demokratie, das Vertrauen in eine Ordnung,
basierend auf dem Recht.
Wie passt das so zu der hindu-nationalistischen Aufarbeitung der Modi-Politik,
die wir bisher so hatten?
Inklusive Massakern, irgendwelchen Armeen, die dort, Privatarmeen, die da durchrennen.
Es geht dann noch weiter, also sie ist in einem euphorischen Ton,
der mich erschrecken lässt.
Ich danke dir sehr für den offenen Austausch, den wir darüber heute gemeinsam hatten.
Und vielleicht liegt dieser offene Austausch auch daran, dass obwohl dies mein
erster offizieller Besuch in Indien ist, es sich für mich gar nicht nach einem
ersten Besuch anfühlt, sondern eher als würde man einen guten Freund besuchen.
Hochgradig inkonsistent zu der,
eben nicht universalistisch ausformulierten Linie, die man da in China fährt.
Und sie spricht auch hier Russland an und da könnte man ja auch sagen,
Indien profitiert ja momentan wahnsinnig von diesem Krieg auch in Form von Ölimporten.
Indien importiert von Russland 20 mal mehr Öl als vor dem Krieg.
Könnte man ja zum Beispiel ansprechen, dass man das auch mit Sorge sieht. Es klingt aber hier so.
Ich möchte deswegen dir, lieber Jaishankar, als Außenminister ganz herzlich dafür danken,
dass die Übernahme dieses G20-Vorsitzes nicht nur ein bisschen as usual ist,
sondern – das hast du bei unserem Gespräch auch deutlich gemacht – dass das
eine ganz besondere Aufgabe ist, die ihr auch ganz besonders und ein bisschen
anders als zuvor gestalten werdet.
Aufgrund der besonderen Verantwortung übernimmt Indien in diesem schwierigen
Moment eben nicht nur einen G-20-Vorsitz, sondern globale Verantwortung – Verantwortung
für die dringendsten Aufgaben unserer Zeit.
Da sind die globalen Auswirkungen des brutalen, völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieges
Russland gegen die Ukraine, die die ganze Welt in eine schwere Schieflage gebracht hat.
Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2017
die aber gerade auch euer Land mit Blick auf Energielieferung und Düngemittel
vor enorme Herausforderungen stellt.
Ist das auch wieder so ein bisschen auch für das deutsche Publikum gemacht,
um uns die Lage schön zu reden, bevor aus Deutschland wieder zu viele Arbeitsaufträge
kämen, aber hast du auch die Menschenrechte angesprochen, aber hast du auch
die Verwicklung mit China, mit Russland angesprochen?
Keine Ahnung. Nun, es gibt diese große Sehnsucht danach, eigentlich ja schon
eingeleitet von Obama und Clinton, dass man Indien für sich gewinnt.
Indien will das aber gar nicht. Warum sollten die das jetzt auch tun?
Sich ganz klar auf eine Seite schlagen, so wie die Chinesen sich das auch denken.
Und jetzt umgarnt man sie, wo man nur kann und blendet alles andere aus.
Im Journalismus wird es ja da nicht grundsätzlich ausgeblendet.
Hier einfach mal einen kurzen Beitrag aus dem Mittagsmagazin von vor zwei Wochen,
folgendes ist da zu hören.
In Modi's neuem Indien wird das Leben vor allem für Journalisten immer schwerer.
Laut Reporter ohne Grenzen landet Indien in Sachen Pressefreiheit nur noch auf Platz 150.
Die Organisation schreibt, Hasskampagnen gegen Medienschaffende bis hin zu Aufruf
zum Mord sind in sozialen Netzwerken alltäglich und werden von Troll-Armeen
aus dem Umfeld der hindu-nationalistischen Regierung befeuert.
Behördenkritische JournalistInnen werden oft mit Strafverfolgung mundtot gemacht.
Also Platz 150 bei 190 Ländern auf der Welt bedeutet.
China ist auf Platz 175. Also da ist noch ein bisschen schlechter.
In der großen Aufteilung die Hälfte der Welt gut, die andere Hälfte der Welt
schlecht. Bist du schon mal auf der schlechten Hälfte und in der schlechten
Hälfte bist du noch auf der negativen Seite. Genau. Nicht gut.
Aber sonst ist eigentlich alles prima mit Indien. Wir hören jetzt noch mal kurz
Xi, der so spricht, als er da neben Macron sitzt.
Wir unterstützen gegenseitig, wir bemühen uns um die globale Governance,
es geht um und die Demokratisierung der internationalen Beziehungen.
In Zurückweisung der Blockkonfrontation und der Logik des Kalten Krieges.
Wir haben mit großen globalen Herausforderungen
zu tun. China unterstützt Frankreich in diesen Bemühungen.
Klar, China möchte keine Blockbildung und spricht jetzt nochmal den Europäern Mut zu.
China betrachtet Europa immer noch als unabhängigen Pol in einer multipolaren
Welt und unterstützen die Bemühungen Europas um eine strategische Autonomie.
Die chinesisch-europäischen Beziehungen hängen von keinen Dritten ab und sie
brauchen auch nicht die Unterstützung irgendwelcher Dritter.
Wir sind uns sicher, dass die europäischen Beziehungen zu China sich in aller
Unabhängigkeit entwickeln werden.
Strategische Autonomie, das, was ja Adam Tooze ausgeführt hat,
bedeutet für China jetzt auf Europa geblickt, wir helfen ihnen,
also wir helfen ihnen loszukommen, das sagt er jetzt ja nicht wortwörtlich,
von den USA, damit sie selbstständiger sind.
Das ist das, was Macron dann vorgeschlagen hat bei seinem Interview,
das er Politico gegeben hat.
Und so ist also diese strategische Autonomie, die hier im Munde geführt wird,
eine ziemlich andere zu der strategischen Autonomie, die jetzt Ursula von der Leyen ausspricht.
Wir haben ja diesen Toos, diese Toos-Clips, wo ich aber am letzten Mal noch
angemerkt habe, wir wissen ja gar nicht, mit wem er da sprach.
Also diese schießende Auseinandersetzungen, welche US-Demokraten sind das denn?
Ist das so der politische Mittelbau sind das schon die Führungskräfte des Weißen
Hauses oder wie auch immer.
Und jetzt Shi, der hier auch noch mal darauf hinweist, es gibt diese Blockbildung.
Das hat sich ja im April jetzt so ein bisschen hochgeschaukelt,
also höher als ich von Toos aus,
aber es war ja wirklich sehr voraussehend irgendwie, was den April angeht.
Dass es so schnell kommt, habe ich auch nicht gedacht.
Genau. Und zum Thema Blockbildung, bevor ich jetzt, weil ich ja sehe,
du hast ja die Christine Lagarde gleich als großen Block.
Will ich mal einen Clip aus dem Deutschlandfunk spielen.
Der Deutschlandfunk hat ein ganz langweiliges Segment, nämlich Pressekommentare,
Zeitungskommentare, Zeitungsstimmen am Ende der Tageszusammenfassung,
kurz bevor die Hymne gespielt werden und eigentlich alle schon schlafen und so.
Das ist eigentlich immer super langweilig, weil da werden einfach die Eckenbrüller
der Zeitung nochmal vorgetragen in Kürze.
Und zum Thema Ukraine und den Leaks, die es in Amerika gab. Auf Discord gab
es ja so verschiedene Dokumente, die dann irgendwie dann doch das Kriegsgeschehen
ziemlich wahrhaftig darstellen, auch wenn darum viel rumgefakt wurde und so.
Und ein Zeitungskommentar hat sich mit diesen Leaks mal befasst und für mich
auf überraschend deutliche Art und Weise plötzlich in dieses Thema eingeschlagen.
Die Beratung aus Heidelberg stellt fest, mit den geleakten Papieren wird erstmals
verschriftlicht, dass der Ukraine-Krieg ein direkter, wenn auch indirekt ausgetragener
Konflikt zwischen Moskau und Washington ist.
Diese Erkenntnis macht aus dem Aggressor Putin natürlich keinen Friedensengel,
aber, anders als oftmals behauptet, steckt hinter dem Überfall auf die Ukraine
eben mehr als ein rein russisch-ukrainischer Konflikt.
Ein Kriegsende ist nur unter Beteiligung
der USA möglich, weil Washington strategisch tief involviert ist.
So, Macron sitzt im Flieger aus China zurück und kritisiert die Abhängigkeit
Europas von Amerikanern.
Alle wundern sich, Norbert Röttgen dreht völlig durch, kann sich das gar nicht erklären.
Gütekoffer.
Gütekoffer, findet das unsäglich, das war ein großer Schaden für Europa und so weiter und so fort.
Marco Rubio, also der auch mal
Präsident werden wollte und wahrscheinlich jetzt wieder antritt und so,
der republikanischen Partei, stellt sich vor die Kameras und sagt,
naja, wenn Macron uns nicht helfen will, Taiwan zu verteidigen,
wieso helfen wir eigentlich Europa im Kampf gegen Russland auf ukrainischem Boden?
Und dann stellt sich aber raus, nö, man kann diese ganzen Leaks zum Thema,
wie wird der Krieg eigentlich organisiert, und zwar da abseits der Öffentlichkeit,
wo man nur aus Versehen mal Einblick erhält, kann man auch die Leseart rauslesen,
das ist gar nicht der europäische Krieg gegen Russland, sondern das ist,
so wie wir vorher auch die Debatte hatten zum Thema ist das jetzt ein Stellvertreterkrieg oder nicht.
Es ist eine Auseinandersetzung Amerikas gegen Russland.
Ukrainischen Boden und sozusagen peripher in der politischen Dimension mit Europa
noch zu tun hat, durch regionale Nähe.
Aber eigentlich ist es eine russisch-amerikanische Auseinandersetzung.
Und das ist natürlich interessant, wenn man weiß,
wie diese Eckenbrüller-Kommentardinger zustande kommen,
dass nämlich die Zeitungen sowieso schon so ein offensichtliches Thema eigentlich
immer in die Ecke oben schreiben als Kommentar Kommentar und dann noch mal so der eine Absatz,
der quasi gar nichts sagt, aber schön formuliert ist, an die Deutschlandfunkredaktion
weitergeleitet wurde, sodass da eigentlich nur noch Nonsens vorgelesen wird.
Also das, was man sich auch von selber denkt, werden einfach fünf Kommentare
zusammengestellt und vorgelesen und dann plötzlich wird aber so eine tiefen Schafe,
wo man sich denkt, naja gut, das sollte man vielleicht mal nicht nur als Kommentar
auf Seite 1 kurz abhandeln, sondern nochmal in Seite 3 das Stück zuschreiben.
Steht in diesen Dokumenten eigentlich wirklich drinnen, dass das eine große
Auseinandersetzung zwischen Russland und Amerika ist.
Aber überraschenderweise wurde es einmal so in die Welt getragen,
dass man es hier nachlesen kann. Da würde ich sagen, das ist doch ein Auftrag
an den einen oder anderen außenpolitischen Journalisten, dieser Fragestellung mal nachzugehen.
Inwieweit zeigen diese Dokumente, dass es sich hier um eine erste kriegerische
Aushandlung dieser Blockbildung ist, die Macron eigentlich kritisiert.
Ja und wie würdest du das einschätzen? Sehen wir gerade doch jetzt in den letzten
Wochen sehr viel mehr das Leid auch der Soldaten in den Medien gespiegelt?
Mir scheint es ein bisschen so, vielleicht aber auch weil ich jetzt einen Fokus
darauf gerichtet habe und dadurch fallen mir diese Artikel mehr auf.
Mir werden diese Videos mehr angezeigt, aber ich lese dann selbst in einem News-Sticker
der Bild-Zeitung, dass in der Ukraine Deserteure,
sehr, sehr scharf geahndet werden, dass sie ins Gefängnis gesperrt werden,
wenn sie den Dienst an der Waffe dann verweigern, wenn sie das nicht aus religiösen Motiven können.
Da war ein ziemlich skandalöser Fall. Also solche Dinge, kurze Videos von Soldaten
von beiden Seiten, von Russland wie von der Ukraine, die sich wundern,
was machen wir eigentlich hier?
Ich würde sagen, es nimmt ein bisschen zu, aber in einer insgesamt erheblich
abschwächenden Thematisierung des Krieges überhaupt.
Also das stimmt. Wenn ich jetzt so Abendnachrichten schaue für einen Fernsehpodcast,
da kommt das eigentlich kaum noch vor. Also wirklich nicht an relevanter Stelle.
Und es wird ja nach wie vor gestorben.
Ohne Ende. Ja, aber wir haben ja in Deutschland wieder mal eine,
was ist mit meinem Eigentum?
Irgendwelche älteren Leute, die sich glücklicherweise noch zu der Generation
hören, die sich Wohneigentum leisten konnten, haben irgendwas mit ihrer Heizung.
Und das musste natürlich hoch und unter diskutiert werden, auch in den Talkshows.
Und hat den Krieg so ein bisschen verdrängt.
Ja, das kann ganz leicht gehen. Wir sprechen, glaube ich, heute nicht über Biden, oder?
Es ist auch interessant, dass wir da angekündigt bekommen, wir haben hier einen
Autor, der ein Buch über die Alten Republik geschrieben hat.
Jetzt haben wir einen Präsidenten, bei dem man sagte, das ist so ein Übergangspräsident,
der wird dann auf jeden Fall die nächste Amtszeit nicht mehr machen,
sondern das macht dann eher eine jüngere Frau wahrscheinlich aus dem Reich der Demokraten.
So sieht es aber nicht aus, sondern Biden tritt wieder an.
Also wir können uns da ganz kurz abhandeln.
Und ist dann glaube ich 82, wenn er das Amt antritt und damit ist er dann knapp
40 Jahre älter als Ron DeSantis, der wahrscheinlich sein Widersacher wird.
Ja, also Donald Trump pokert schon hoch und sagt, ich drehe bei den Debatten im Fernsehen nicht an.
Was bedeutet im Herbst, wenn dann Ron DeSantis irgendwann seine Kandidatur öffentlich
erklärt und es ist immer noch Stefan, wieso Ron DeSantis, wer ist denn das und so.
Also die Super-PACs sind alle bereit, die strategischen Entscheidungen sind
alle getroffen. Ron de Sentes ist jetzt zum vierten Mal in Israel,
um auch da wieder Stimmung und so weiter zu machen für die entsprechende Wählerbasis.
Also Ron de Sentes wird irgendwann seine Kandidatur.
Es ist nur noch eine strategische Frage, wann man es genau macht.
Donald Trump pokert hoch und sagt, ich schwänze die Fernsehdebatten,
weil er weiß, er hat ja eine Base hinter sich.
Die Frage ist, wie weit kann er Ron de Sentes torpedieren und ihn da irgendwie schaden?
Oder muss er es auf einer Debattenbühne austragen? Nur wir kennen ja die Donald-Trump-Show schon.
Wir wissen ja, beim letzten Mal hat er ja dann gegen Megan Dingsda-Booms von
Fox News und so scharf geschossen, dass das plötzlich dieses Clip-Phänomen immer
war. Man hat nur noch diese Clips gesehen und gar nicht die Debatten an sich.
Denn in den Debatten an sich hat Trump verloren, aber diese Clips waren halt
so überragend und faszinierend.
Und jetzt hat man dieses Phänomen. Und das kommt in Deutschland wahrscheinlich
bis zum Wahltag nicht an. die amerikanischen wahlen werden.
In drei bundesstaaten dort entschieden dass es
gibt nur noch drei battle states haben jetzt bei the
daily haben sie eine kurze auflistung gemacht und wenn
beiden oder die demokraten nur einen davon gewinnen sind sie schon durch also
die mathematik gibt für den wahlkampf so wenig spielraum da auch die demografischen
veränderungen sind wie sie sind Dass man eigentlich nicht ernsthaft von einem persönlichen Kampf,
der Wahlkampf und da ist dann wirklich fast egal, wie alt ist denn Biden,
wie alt ist denn irgendwer.
Es gibt zu viele Menschen, die einfach niemals Donald Trump wählen würden und
es gibt zu viele Menschen, die einfach nur Donald Trump wählen würden.
Und der Spielraum dazwischen ist so klein, dass es wirklich fast egal ist,
wer jetzt so antritt. Also die Kräfteverhältnisse.
Bei Ron DeSantis, du würdest nicht sagen, dass der noch mal ein Klientel mobilisieren
kann, das Trump nicht mehr erreicht.
Also wir wissen ja wie Ron DeSantis gerade auftritt, nämlich als jemand der
sich vor Disney verklagen lässt, weil er dann lieber so ein Vogue-Feldzug gegen
Disney führt als und so weiter.
Also nur Kulturkampf eigentlich. Also er legt sich mit der zentralen Wirtschaftskraft
seines eigenen Staates an, nur um für so ein paar Wähler, die es interessiert,
so ein Vogue-Dings durchzuführen.
Und ich sehe natürlich auch jetzt so Szenarien wie Ron DeSantis kommt dann auf
eine Debattenbühne gegen Joe
Biden, wo Joe Biden vielleicht diesen Move machen kann wie Trump jetzt.
Also Trump will natürlich nur pokern entsprechend. Ich komme nicht zur Debatte,
damit das Fernsehen ihm entsprechende Zugeständnisse gemacht,
mit ja, dann machen wir das so und so und so und dann kommst du doch.
Joe Biden wird, wenn es zur Auseinandersetzung mit Ron DeSantis kommt,
wahrscheinlich wirklich der erste Präsident sein, der einfach sagt,
ich mache kein Fernsehduell mit Ron DeSantis.
Warum sollte ich irgendwelche Wähler, die schon längst entschieden sind,
nochmal aufschrecken mit irgendwelchen Stotteranfällen auf der Bühne neben Ron DeSantis?
Wenn ich einfach das vermeide, kriege ich zwar eine Debatte,
die dann irgendwie ausgetragen wird mit Oh, er tritt nicht an im Fernsehduell
und so weiter und die Republikaner werden dann irgendwie ihre eigene Fernsehshow
für diesen Abend machen, wo das terminiert war.
Aber das wird ja kein demokratischer Wähler, der auf gar keinen Fall jemanden
wählen möchte, möchte, der Abortion-Bands unterschreibt, einen Kulturkampf gegen
Disney führt und so weiter. Die wählen ihn einfach nicht.
Auch wenn auf der Fernsehbühne in Deutschland immer gesehen wird,
oh Ron DeSantis, 43 Jahre, der wirkt ja wirklich super agiergegen den alten
beiden und so. Ich glaube, wir sind jetzt in diesem Zeitalter.
Es begann ja damals mit Kennedy, das erste Fernsehduell. Nixen guckt auf die Uhr.
Das wird dann weithin kommentiert als der wirkte gelangweilt und so weiter.
Ich kenne die, wirkte ja viel agiler und viel junger und so weiter.
Ich glaube, jetzt sind wir in diesem TikTok-Zeitalter und so weiter,
wo einfach das Fernsehduell nicht mehr von Bedeutung ist.
Wo auch alle Fragen des, wie stellt er sich dar, wie wirkt er,
wirkt er überzeugend und so weiter, die Wähler sind irgendwie entschieden.
Nur diese Fragen stellen sich ja schon, auch für das Image, das die USA nach
draußen verkörpern müssen. Also, dass wir es da mit einem Präsidenten zu tun
haben, der alt ist. So kann man es ja ganz einfach sagen.
Es regiert das weiße Haus und nicht Joe Biden. Da sitzen 4000 Leute,
die die Amtsgeschäfte führen.
Ja, das glaube ich jetzt schon, dass die Mühen von Joe Biden am Ende nicht kriegsentscheidend sein werden.
Nur es ist doch schon ein sehr, sehr trauriges Bild für eine demokratische Partei,
wenn man sich am Ende nur auf einen Kandidaten einigen kann, der uralt ist.
Also ich musste tatsächlich, als ich dieses Video mir ansah,
das jetzt veröffentlicht wurde von Joe Biden, die ganze Zeit denken,
man versucht mit ganz vielen schnellen Schnitten und sehr viel Bewegung,
er bewegt sich von links nach rechts, um am Abend jemanden noch irgendeine Dynamik
herzustellen, die aber de facto nicht mehr da ist.
Das fand ich eigentlich das interessante, dass man die ganze Zeit so tut, als sei er fit.
Es ist noch ein Video, das einen Präsidenten im Amt zeigt. Hast du gesehen,
wie die Republikaner darauf reagierten?
Die haben sich ja vorbereitet. Die wussten ja, irgendwann wird die Ansage kommen.
Joe Biden hat ja auch zweimal schon Anmerkungen gemacht, dass er es auf jeden
Fall möchte, aber die Kandidatur noch nicht erklärt. Jetzt hat er die Kandidatur erklärt.
Die Republikaner hatten in der Minute, in der die Demokraten diese Welle losgetreten
haben, er ist unser offizieller Kandidat.
Oder er tritt an gegen dann andere, aber das weiß man ja, wie die Partei sich
dann verhält, wenn der amtierende Präsident antritt. Also die große Einigungsshow
findet jetzt statt. Die Republikaner haben in der Minute ein Video veröffentlicht
zum Thema 2. Amtszeit Joe Biden.
San Francisco umzingelt irgendwie, keine Ahnung, zu viele, man braucht die Nationalgarde,
damit überhaupt noch für Sicherheit gesorgt werden kann.
Das ganze Land geht vor die Hunde, das Weiße Haus kann nicht mehr ordentlich
regiert werden. Wie haben Sie das gemacht? Die 2. Amtszeit ist noch nicht da.
Das Video besteht ausschließlich aus AI-generierten Bildern.
Um dann einfach zu zeigen, wie das so aussähe, so aussehe, wenn San Francisco
unter Lockdown wäre und so weiter und so fort.
Das heißt, die Republikaner haben jetzt schon als Gegenprogramm zu Joe Biden
ein Fake Joe Biden mit einem negativen Vorzeichen hingestellt und so werden die auch regieren.
Also wir werden die Diskussion bei noch wach ausführlich haben,
wie weit kann man mit einem Roman, einer Fiktion der Wirklichkeit kommen,
um ein Gefühl hervorzurufen.
In dem Falle, was ist eigentlich Machtmissbrauch? Kann man das dem Leser erfühlbar machen?
Und die Republikaner haben jetzt mit der Ansage, das ist alles computergeneriert,
das ist alles fake, das ist alles Zukunft, wir können gar nichts wissen,
aber wir wollen trotzdem bei euch schon das Gefühl hervorrufen.
Und diese Entrückung von, und wir dachten immer alle, ja gut,
man kann es auf die Spitze treiben, in dem man sagt, okay, schon vor zehn Jahren
war die politische Rede von Barack Obama komplett von der Realität entrückt.
Er hat eine Stimmung im Stadion hergestellt für den Moment, in dem er geredet
hat, und das sollte dann bis zum Wahlkampf irgendwie, bis zum Wahltag anhalten.
Und diese Entrückung, also die politische Rede hat sich schon vor 20 Jahren
entkoppelt von der Realität.
Künftig wird sich jede politische Kommunikation wie so ein AI-generiertes Video
komplett von der Realität entrücken. Und in der Hinsicht wird es irgendwann egal sein.
Wer jetzt Präsident ist. Ich kann mir auch gut vorstellen, dass im Sommer noch
so einiges passiert, dass dann doch irgendwie The Rock Dwayne Johnson sagt,
ich kandidiere auch und dann steht da plötzlich so einer mit auf der Debattenbühne
und dann sagt irgendwie Oprah Winfrey, ja dann halte ich da dagegen und dann
steht sie plötzlich bei den Demokraten auf der Debattenbühne und sowas.
Also es ist ja in jeder Richtung alles jetzt möglich und es wird aber mit einer
politischen Realität einfach gar nichts mehr zu tun haben. Es ist nur noch Fernsehshow.
Das war sehr schön zu erleben bei Markus Lanz, als dieser FDP-Politiker Dörr dort war.
Dann ging es um die Frage, muss man die Heizungen austauschen,
wenn das Habeck-Gesetz kommt?
Er wurde immer wieder von Lanz gefragt, stand jemals in dem Gesetz drin,
dass Leute ihre funktionierenden Heizungen rausreißen müssen,
um die Wärmepumpen zu installieren?
Dann sagte er immer nur, es wurde der Eindruck erweckt,
Es gab das Gefühl, es hatte den Anschein, dass, also es waren immer nur fiktionale
Beschreibungen, so würden wir jetzt an den Stuckrad-Bacher-Romanen dann dran gehen.
Und Lanz fragte immer wieder nach, ja aber Stand ist irgendwo drin,
denn das ist ja sowas von hirnrissig, dass da drin steht, alle Deutschen sollen
ihre Heizungen rausreißen, ab sofort gibt es Wärmepumpen.
Dürr hat ja wirklich versucht Gravitas herzustellen über, auch Verbände haben
den Eindruck geteilt, dass da drinnen stünde, man müsste jetzt seine Heizung ausbauen. Ja.
Und da hatten alle irgendein Gefühl. Und da können wir es jetzt der FDP verdanken,
dass dieses Gefühl nicht gesetzt wurde.
Genau, dass sie diesem Gefühl widersprochen haben in einer ganz großen Welle
an ausgedachter Nachrichtenproduktionen bei Übermedien oder so.
Die haben ja mal so eine Kache gemacht. 20 Bildzeitungsüberschriften zum Thema Heizungsausbau und so.
Alles fake, hat alles nichts mit Wahrheit und Wirklichkeit zu tun,
aber ich erinnere daran, ich habe auch vor zehn, elf Jahren oder so in der FAZ,
da gab es noch die alten Bilder und Zeiten, mal so ein ganzseitiges Ding geschrieben
über ausgedachte Wirklichkeiten.
Damals am Beispiel die Homeland der Serie,
Wir wussten ja nicht, was ist ein Schläfer, wie organisieren die sich und so
weiter und so fort. Und plötzlich gab es so Drehbuchautoren,
die gesagt haben, wir zeigen euch das jetzt mal.
Oder West Wing, Chad Bartlett, Nobelpreisgewinner, Ökonomiewirt,
amerikanischer Präsident, eine ganz idealtypische Darstellung,
wie ein Präsidentenalltag so abläuft.
Völlig übertrieben, aber in diesen echten Limits, also den wirklichen Limits.
Beispielsweise der Präsident muss alle fünf Minuten einen neuen Termin haben,
damit alle, die einen Termin bei ihm haben wollen, auch einen bekommen und so
weiter. Wie fühlt sich das eigentlich an? Wie sieht so ein Arbeitsalltag aus?
Und da war dann meine Argumentation, wenn eine Fernsehserie sich zum Anspruch
nimmt, ganz nah an die Wirklichkeit heranzurücken Und dann aber feststellt,
mit Journalismus schaffen wir das nicht, weil wir dann zu viele Lücken in der Erzählung haben.
Wir müssen den roten Faden mithilfe eines, einer Fiktion, eines Romans,
eines Drehbuchs, wie auch immer, spinnen.
Dann rücken wir noch näher heran an die Wirklichkeit, wie sie wirklich ist,
als Fernsehjournalisten, die uns abends das Tagebuch der Merkel erklären.
Und meine Argumentation war dann einfach, die haben recht damit.
Wenn man eine Fiktion einfach mit den realistischen Limits und dann inhaltlich
ausfüllt, kommt man mit Drehbuch-Argumentation oder mit so Romanen wie noch
wach wahrscheinlich näher an die Realität ran, aussagekräftiger.
Man kann den Rezipienten, Leser, Zuschauer, wie auch immer, noch besser mitfühlen
lassen, wie es ist amerikanischer Präsident zu sein, als das über Journalismus möglich ist.
Und dann gab es diesen Punkt,
in dem deutsche Journalisten erklärt haben, Barack Obamas Chief of Staff im
White House kündigt, um Bürgermeister in Chicago seine Heimatstadt zu werden.
Ist auch alles genau so passiert, er hat dann gekündigt, Emanuel Rahm hieß er
glaube ich, und ist dann Bürgermeister in Washington geworden.
Und dann haben die deutschen Journalisten versucht, dem deutschen Publikum zu
erklären, was der Chief of Staff im White House ist und haben dann so gesagt,
ja, das ist so einer der wichtigsten Berater des Präsidenten und so.
Jeder, der The West Wing gesehen hatte von Aaron Sorkin, wusste, was das bedeutet.
Dass der Chief of Staff nicht einfach nur so ein wichtiger Berater ist,
sondern dass dass das der eigentliche Präsident ist, dass er ist,
durch dessen Schreibtisch alles geht.
Präsident ist dann nur dafür da, um für die Öffentlichkeit nochmal die Rede
zu halten und sich dann darauf vorzubereiten. Dem sagt man dann,
kümmer dich nicht hier um unsere Gesetzgebung und so weiter,
bereite dich lieber darauf vor, dass du morgen ausgeschlafen fürs Fernsehen aussiehst.
Während die die Amtsgeschäfte führen. Und dann kommen die deutschen Journalisten
und erzählen uns irgendwas von, ja das ist ein ganz wichtiger Berater,
eigentlich macht der die Arbeit der Obama, der sitzt an seinem Schreibtisch
und dann kommt so der Berater rein und berät die nochmal in der einen oder anderen Fragestellung.
Aber nein, es ist natürlich genau umgedreht. Und das konnten deutsche Journalisten
nicht darstellen, was es bedeutet, wenn der Chief of Staff zurücktritt.
So, wenn man die Fernsehserie gesehen hat, hatte man das voll im Gefühl, was es bedeutet.
Ja, ich will nur eine Anmerkung dazu machen. Wir haben ja über ein sehr gutes
Buch mal im Salon gesprochen, Bruno Marques. Das haben wir sehr ausführlich
besprochen, History Has Begun. Und da ging es genau um die Fiktionalisierung.
Da ging es noch mal um Reagan, um Trump, um Amerika ohnehin immer als großes Show-Business.
Das war wirklich ein augenöffnendes Buch, das man jetzt wieder rausholen muss
eigentlich, um jetzt den nächsten Wahlkampf zu begreifen, um vielleicht dann
auch diese beiden Auftritte zu sehen.
Denn ich betrachte sie natürlich auch nur als Fiktion. Ich sah beiden dort und
musste sofort an Marie Karöck denken.
Die wird ihr jetzt nicht sagen, das war eine Operettensängerin und Tänzerin
in solchen Filmen mit Johannes Heß, das sind 50er, 60er Jahren.
Und sie war, wie Jopi Heß, das auch unglaublich robust, tanzte und sang bis
ins hohe Alter. Aber irgendwann, nun ja, war es auch für Marie Karöck an der
Zeit, eigentlich die Bühne zu verlassen, aber sie ließ nicht davon ab.
Und mit 85 trat sie immer noch auf und tanzte.
Und es stand dann damals, ich glaube, es war in der Bild-Zeitung,
der wunderbare Satz, Marie Karöck tanzt nicht mehr, sie wird nur noch geworfen und gefangen.
Und daran musste ich jetzt denken, als ich Biden sah, der auch immer nur noch
so von einem Armen den nächsten geht und da so rum tänzelt, aber man weiß es
gar nicht, ob es noch aus dem Eigenantrieb ist.
Und das zeigte aber, dass ich natürlich auch eine völlig fiktionale Wahrnehmung
dessen habe, was da eigentlich geschieht.
Ja, ich meine, als letzten Punkt dazu, wenn Joe Biden jetzt diese Kandidatur
durchhält und so weiter, mit allem, was dazugehört, dass für ihn alles getan wird.
Er muss da keine innerliche Arbeit mehr machen. Er muss einfach nur die Schlussvorlagen
vortragen, unterzeichnen, wie auch immer.
Dann ist das Einzige, was ihm wirklich noch zum Verhängnis werden kann, sein Alter.
Ich habe jetzt in Hamburg bei der Körperstiftung auch mal aufgedröselt,
selbst Frankfurt am Main, wo man in der Bevölkerungsstatistik kein Babyboom
sieht, weil einfach so viele junge Menschen in die Stadt ziehen,
Bedeutet es trotzdem, wenn die Menschen im Rentenalter.
Hier Uwe Becker als Bürgermeister haben wollen und auch nur die Rentner eine Mehrheit da haben.
Und die jungen Leute mit 3 zu 1, 4 zu 1, die Erstwähler, 75 zu 25,
entscheiden sich für Mike Joseph.
Selbst im Alters, also die Frankfurts Durchschnittsalter ist 42 Jahre.
Selbst in dem Alter hat Mike Joseph einen doppelt so hohen Vorsprung gehabt,
also 2 zu 1 gegen Uwe Becker.
Wenn selbst in solchen Städten die Rentner sagen, wir wollen Uwe Becker,
kommt Uwe Becker auf 48,3 Prozent ran.
Also die Jugend hat gar nichts zu melden. Also wir haben auf dieser Ebene,
was den Wähler angeht, die Kategorie Alter, die alles andere schachmatsetzt.
Also das Alter ist einfach das prägende Merkmal bei demokratischen Wahlen mittlerweile.
Und jetzt haben wir es auch auf der aktiven Seite, auf der Kandidatenseite.
Das einzige, was Biden zum Verhängnis werden kann, inhaltlich alles geklärt.
Das haben die auch im The Daily Podcast noch mal gesagt, die Republikaner können
tun, was sie wollen. Die Amerikaner kennen Joe Biden, seit 50 Jahren.
Die lassen sich jetzt nicht in drei Wochen Wahlkampf darüber irgendwie erzählen,
das ist aber eigentlich doch ein ganz fieser Kommunist oder sowas.
Alles ist geklärt. Außer die Frage, wird ihm sein Alter zum Verhängnis?
Wenn Joe Biden jetzt stolpert, wenn er eine Woche ausfällt wegen Krankheit und
er braucht eine dreimonatige Reha oder sowas, das kann ihm zu Verhängnis werden.
Also wir haben jetzt auf beiden Seiten, auf der Wählerseite und auf der gewählten
Seite das Alter als maßgebliche Kategorie und letzten Stolperstein,
der auf beider Seiten sozusagen die demokratischen Prinzipien dann wirklich
schachmatt setzen kann.
Also deren Sicht wird es ein sehr interessanter Wahlkampf.
Aber eigentlich dann noch ein Wahlkampf, bei dem man sagen kann,
naja, also wir glorifizieren ja sehr die Demokratie und haben aber jetzt eigentlich da so jemanden,
der die nur noch nach außen spielt für uns, also der spielt den Präsidenten.
Klar, dann gibt es schon Unterschiede, ob eine demokratische Partei oder eine
republikanische regiert, aber es ist jetzt auch nicht gerade ein Glanzlicht für das, was...
Also wir sehen doch die ganze Zeit eigentlich wie, und das wäre auch nochmal
ein ganz klares Argument gegen Baerbock,
wir sehen doch hier die ganze Zeit, wie Demokratie beschnitten wird durch entweder
solche Dekrete wie Macron,
die dann einfach verlässt und dann ist das jetzt so, oder wir sehen dann Parteienstrukturen,
die dafür sorgen, dass eigentlich die, die wirklich was bewegen könnten,
wollten, sich nicht durchsetzen können.
Und man dann ja so eine Präsidentenfigur hat,
das ist so wie abends die Schlagersendung im Fernsehen, wenn man sagt,
gut, wer lebt noch von denen, die eh schon alle kennen, dann können wir die
nochmal das Medley singen lassen.
Also die Demokratie von außen betrachtet glänzt nicht so sehr,
wie wir sie immer hoch polieren am Sonntag, wenn die Reden gehalten werden,
ist natürlich ein ernsthaftes Problem.
Und man muss auch immer wieder darauf hinweisen, die Demokratie hat als Prinzip
in Europa und Amerika so einen großen Stand, weil die erste Generation die Demokratie
erlebt hat, also die Nachkriegsgeneration ab 45.
Bei denen korreliert die Erfahrung mit der Demokratie, die politische Bewusstwerdung
in die Demokratie hinein, mit dem enormen Wohlstandswachstum durch,
naja, was halt so nach Kriegen ist, Wirtschaftswachstum und so.
Wunder, Wirtschaftswachstumswunder. Und diese Verkoppelung wird ja heute ganz
anders gemacht. Die Menschen, die heute politisch bewusst werden,
erleben ja Demokratie nur noch als Krüppel, weshalb sie auch zur Hälfte einfach nicht hingehen.
Also die Wahlbeteiligung bei der Stichwahl in Frankfurt waren irgendwie 14 Prozent
der Erstwähler oder sowas. Also das findet quasi gar nicht statt.
Und in der Hinsicht haben wir es auch mit so einer goldenen Generation zu tun,
die jetzt ins Rentenalter kommt, weil für die im Kopf total verkoppelt ist,
Demokratie ist gut, weil es hat mich reich gemacht.
Und das ist aber die einzige Generation, die das jemals so erlebt hat.
Also können die noch so viele Sonntagsreden über Demokratie halten,
wenn sie andere nicht an ihrem Vermögenswachstum beteiligen,
sondern einfach sagen, Demokratie ist ganz cool, und jetzt zahlen wir mal meine
1.000 Euro Miete für 30 Quadratmeter hier in Frankfurt.
Danke, dass du da bist und die Stadt so attraktiv machst, sonst wäre meine Miete
viel geringer, die ich hier bekomme jeden Monat.
Dann klappt das nicht. Man muss diesen strukturellen Unterbau der Demokratie oder nicht,
aber wenn keine Vermögenswachstumswirtschaftliche Fortkommenserwartung geknüpft
ist an das das hohe Lied auf die Demokratie, dann stirbt.
Das ist auch aus mit der Baby-Boomer-Generation. Das Jubellied der Demokratie
ist eine ganz kleine, also historisch betrachtet eigentlich die kleinste Gruppe
überhaupt denkbar, die Demokratie so ganz uneingeschränkt super toll findet.
Deshalb ja autokratische Strukturen immer dann gut funktionieren,
wenn es ein Wohlstandswachstum gibt.
Das wird ja das große Problem für China werden, wenn die Mittelschicht dann
nicht weiter anwächst und jetzt gerade sich abzeichnet, dass Jobs gebraucht
werden, auch geschaffen werden.
Aber nicht mehr für die mit höherer akademischer Bildung, sondern plötzlich
wieder einfache Jobs und dann sagen sich Eltern aus der Mittelschicht,
ja, weil wir haben ja jetzt alles investiert, Klavierunterricht schon mit drei
Jahren und jetzt gibt es doch keinen Bildungsaufstieg.
Und dann ist natürlich die Abkehr von einem autokratischen System sehr viel wahrscheinlicher.
Das hat aber da nichts mit einer ideologischen Entscheidung in dem Sinne zu
tun, sondern geht aus einem egoistischen Impuls heraus, dass man sagt,
vielleicht könnte ich in der Demokratie doch reicher werden oder die Berufswahl wäre etwas freier.
Ja, das muss Xi jetzt managen. Mal sehen, wie er es hinbekommt.
Er hat ja gedacht, die Corona-App ist für ihn so ein Ausweg.
Aber jetzt hat er festgestellt, nee, Wirtschaftswachstum ist doch ein bisschen
wichtiger als mein restriktives Durchgreifen. Ich erkläre Corona für beendet,
jetzt hat er auch diese App nicht mehr.
Mal sehen, also die Herausforderungen sind riesig in China.
Zugleich sind die Herausforderungen für die deutschen Autobauer ja katastrophal
jetzt mit Blick auf China.
Es gab einen Artikel in der Wirtschaftswoche von Martin Seibert,
das will ich nun ganz kurz anführen. Und da heißt es hier, deutsche Autohersteller
haben auf ein langes Leben des Verbrenners in China gehofft.
Doch der jüngste E-Auto-Boom könnte die Hoffnung zunichte machen und das Ende
der Erfolgsgeschichte von VW und Co.
Dort einläuten. Wir haben ja die ganze Zeit diese Debatte gehabt,
E-Fuels und weiß ich nicht was. Und die FDP glaubt, dass die Freiheit stirbt,
wenn der Verbrenner stirbt. Und dann assistiert die Welt dann noch mal nach Kräften mit.
Aber hier heißt es, die deutschen Hersteller VW, BMW und Mercedes werden nun
in einem Tempo abgehängt, das sie selbst nicht kommen sahen.
Mit ihnen aber auch viele Berater nicht. Sie haben sich getäuscht.
Februar schaffte es der jahrzehntelange Marktführer Volkswagen beim Neuwagen-Absatz
nur noch auf Platz zwei hinter den chinesischen E-Auto-Hersteller BYD.
BMW und Mercedes waren in der Top Ten der größten Anbieter nicht mehr vertreten.
Zunehmend wird aber klar, dass China gar nicht tricksen muss,
um die westlichen Hersteller zu treffen. Also weil da immer jetzt gesprochen
wird, was lassen die dazu?
Nee, die setzen einfach ganz auf E-Autos und damit ist Deutschland so gut wie
raus. So kann man natürlich auch D-Cup-Längen betreiben auf eine ganz andere Weise.
Also die deutschen Autobauer leiden ja darunter, dass sie diesen riesigen Forschungsvorsprung
beim Thema Verbrenner haben, den man nicht mehr braucht, wenn man E-Mobilität macht.
Ich würde sagen, die Deutschen wurden einmal so richtig an der Nase vorgeführt,
denn die Chinesen wussten, wir brauchen Mobilität.
Sehr viele Menschen müssen einfach in die Städte rein pendeln und so weiter.
Und wir hören ja auch immer, dieses Neujahrsfest ist dann die größte Migrationsbewegung
der Welt, wenn da irgendwie 800 Millionen Chinesen einmal durchs Land reisen.
Also dafür brauchen sie Züge und Autos.
Also hat man die deutschen Verbrennerhersteller eingeladen zu sagen,
verkauft mal jetzt sofort eure Autos bei uns, damit es schneller geht,
macht eure Fabriken bei uns und so weiter und so fort.
Und dann hat man aber diese riesigen Förderprogramme gemacht für die E-Mobilität,
die natürlich in die eigenen Hersteller ging.
Und man hat genau gesehen in den Statistiken, wann das Überkreuzen stattfindet.
Also VW ist jetzt Platz zwei. Und jetzt hören wir hier in den Abendnachrichten in Deutschland am 18.
April mal die Quote, VW und so weiter aufgestellt sind beim Thema E-Mobilität in China.
Elektromobilität. Aktuell liegt VWs Marktanteil bei E-Autos in China bei etwa
2,7 Prozent. 2,7 Prozent.
VW ist perspektivisch nicht mehr existent auf dem chinesischen Markt.
Die haben ja schon vor zehn Jahren angefangen zu sagen, 8 Prozent der Flotten müssen E-Mobil sein.
Daraufhin ist Sigmar Gabriel hingeflogen und hat dafür geworben,
dass die 8-Prozent-Regel einfach nicht gilt. Chinesen haben gesagt,
doch, doch, doch, die gilt.
Und besonders blöde ist natürlich, dass die Öffnung des chinesischen Marktes
für die Autos einherging mit der chinesischen Ansage,
dann wollen wir aber eure Solar- und Dingsbranche genauso offen haben,
wodurch die komplett einmal nach China gewandert ist.
Jetzt haben wir zuerst unseren Weltmarktführeranspruch beim Thema Solar- und
Windenergie Und zehn Jahre später wird unsere Autobranche da gekillt.
Was bedeutet das hier? Das ist die letzte gute Nachricht, die wir von der Autobranche hören.
In Deutschland können für das abgelaufene Geschäftsjahr auf hohe Dividenden
hoffen. Die börsennotierten Unternehmen wollen eine Rekordsumme ausschütten.
Mehr dazu von Anja Kohl aus der Frankfurter Börse.
Möglich wird der Dividenden-Regen, weil Großkonzerne erneut rekordhohe Gewinne
haben. erneut rekordhohe Gewinne eingefahren haben.
So, der DAX macht ein Dividendenregen in Rekordhöhe.
Die Hälfte davon entfällt auf BMW, Mercedes und VW.
Und wir wissen ja, dass sie irgendwie 60, 70 Prozent ihres Gewinns in China erwirtschaften.
Also das ist jetzt einfach abgelaufen. Da hat China einfach uns schachmatt gesetzt.
Und vielleicht, um mal ein bisschen diese Konfusion zu erklären,
bei der Bild-Zeitung jetzt bei der Berichterstattung über Habeck,
das ist ja ganz interessant, Habeck ist ja einfach der Feind der Bild-Zeitung jetzt.
Und auch generell der Springer-Presse in einer Vehemenz, wie das selten da war.
Interessanterweise aber wird zugleich Baerbock hofiert.
Also das hat es so auch noch nicht gegeben beim Springer-Konzern,
wie sehr sich alle hinter Baerbock stellen, selbst noch so Leute wie Henrik M.
Broder, die sie dann verteidigen, wo man es ja dann gar nicht mehr vermutet.
Aber das ist natürlich diese Blockbildung, die erwünscht ist von Springer,
dass man sagt, ja das ist doch gut, wenn wir jetzt hier den westlichen Block
gegen China bilden und alles was Habeck macht, wird so gedeichselt,
als so hingestellt, als sei dies eigentlich auch eine Annäherung an China,
ein Ausverkauf, was weiß ich alles.
Auch diese Fiesmann-Sache wird ja völlig falsch dargestellt und es ist so interessant,
man müsste ja eigentlich sagen, naja wirklich schwächen würde Deutschland weiterhin,
wenn wir diese Blockbildung haben, nämlich die deutsche Autoindustrie und die FDP ist eigentlich,
die Deutschland nicht an China verscherbelt, sondern die FDP sorgt dafür,
dass hier die Innovationen alle ausgeblieben sind und ausbleiben werden.
Und dadurch hat man natürlich China sehr viel mächtiger gemacht,
als man es eigentlich möchte.
Habeck hat ja noch mal darauf hingewiesen, gestern glaube ich,
die FDP möchte immer zwei Sachen,
keine Staatsverschuldung, also kein großes Investitionsaufkommen,
staatlich gefördert wie in Amerika mit diesen ganzen, es heißt ja nur pro forma,
Inflation Reduction, sondern es ist ja natürlich dieses Förderprogramm.
Und die FDP möchte immer so viel Freihandel wie möglich.
Beide Sachen, die total fördern, dass natürlich die ausländischen Unternehmen
kommen und sagen, wir könnten denen mal Fisman kaufen und so.
Also die FDP macht strukturell immer genau das, was sie dann semantisch auf
ihren Parteitagen kritisieren. Aber wenn wir Zeit haben, kommen wir ja auch noch auf die FDP.
Wollen wir versuchen. Wir springen jetzt zu Christine Lagarde,
die war zu Gast beim Council for Foreign Relations,
seinem Think Tank und sprach dort über, wie die Währung der Zukunft so aussieht,
welche Währungen es gibt.
Sie sagt zu Anfang, den Clip habe ich jetzt nicht mitgebracht,
dass sie hier ja als Zentralbänkerin auftritt.
Also sie sagt in gewisser Weise damit auch, ich kann natürlich nicht alles sagen,
was ich so denke, aber sie sagt
doch relativ viel und wir hören uns diese Räder einmal in Auszügen an.
Die Idee zu akzeptieren, und das tue ich nicht, weil es nicht unbedingt ein
schönes Bild ist, aber die Idee zu akzeptieren, dass wir uns in eine zertifizierte
oder mehr zertifizierte Welt bewegen, als wir es bisher hatten.
Und dass wir nicht unbedingt in einer völlig bipolaren Situation sind,
sondern dass wir in diese Richtung bewegen könnten.
Und dadurch, als Zentralbanker, müssen wir schauen, was die Optionen,
die Risiken und die Szenarien sind, die möglich sind.
Eine Fragmentierung der Welt. Wie reagieren jetzt Zentralbanker darauf?
Das ist die Frage, die sie sich stellt. Sie betont dann nochmal die Blockbildung.
Wir erleben eine Fragmentierung der globalen Ekonomie in konkurrierende Blocks.
Mit jedem Block, der versucht, so viel wie möglich aus dem Rest der Welt zu
seinen eigenen strategischen Interessen und gemeinsamen Werten zu ziehen.
Um welche Blocks es sich da handelt, ist auch, glaube ich, klar.
Und diese Fragmentation, wie ich bereits erwähnt habe, kann sich gut um zwei
Blocks lediglich von den Vereinigten Staaten und von China, die zwei größten
Ökonomien der Welt, zusammenfassen.
Was bedeutet das für die Zentralbanken?
Aber heute möchte ich in meinen Worten die Bedeutungen für die Zentralbanken erforschen.
Ich fokussiere mich auf diese beiden Dimensionen, denn es gibt viele andere.
Ich bin mir sicher, dass die Akademiker und Schüler viele andere erforschen
werden. Aber aus unseren Perspektiven können wir zwei profane Effekte auf die
Politik für die Zentralbanken sehen.
Erstens können wir viel mehr Unstabilität sehen, als die globale Supplei Elastik wächst.
Und zweitens können wir mehr Multipolarität sehen, als geopolitische Stränge aufwachsen.
Das ist jetzt erstmal nicht überraschend. Und wir hören mal weiter.
Wie blickt jetzt Christina Gant zurück auf die Zeit?
So, let's backtrack a little bit, and let's remember the decades after the Cold War.
The world benefited from a remarkably favorable geopolitical environment.
Under the hegemonic leadership of the United States, rule-based international
institutions flourished and global trade expanded.
And this led to a deepening of global chain.
Dieses amerikanische Zeitalter, wenn man genau ist, begann das ja auch weit vor 89.
Also zwar gab es den kommunistischen Block, den sozialistischen Block,
aber dennoch haben wir ja da schon eigentlich die eigentliche Power immer von den USA aus gehabt.
Also wir hatten ja nicht den Verdacht, dass es wirtschaftlich so sein kann,
dass die Sowjetunion gleichzieht mit dem Westen, sondern das war ja eine Frage
der militärischen Auseinandersetzung.
Wird da jemand zündeln oder nicht?
Auch kulturell. Wir wurden ja immer geprägt von mehr der westlichen als der östlichen Seite.
So, jetzt haben wir das Jahr 2001.
Und als China mit der Weltökonomie, bald der WTO, zusammengekommen ist,
ist ein massiver Aufstieg in der globalen Arbeitsversorgung stattgefunden.
Und als Ergebnis wurde die globale Versorgung mehr elastisch zu Veränderungen
in der hessischen Anforderung, was zu einem langen Zeitraum von relativ niedriger
und stabiler Inflation führt.
Ja, Werkbank China.
Genau, das war das Modell und da hoffte man, dass das möglichst lange so ist.
Und das hat in der Tatsache ein Politik-Framework eingeführt,
in dem unabhängige Zentralbanken, nicht in allen Ländern der Welt,
aber in unseren Körnern, auf Stabilisierung der Inflation fokussieren können,
indem sie die Anforderungen steuern, ohne zu viel Aufmerksamkeit zu bezahlen,
um Seiten-Disruptionen zu erzeugen.
Das heißt, man ist eigentlich ganz funktionalistisch vorgegangen,
hat geschaut, ob man die Inflation in den Griff bekommt.
Das hat man ja eher dann schon in eine deflationäre Richtung gebracht.
Dann hatte man Niedrigzinsen, Nullzinsen, um wenigstens so ein 2% Ziel zu erreichen.
Das gelang auch nicht so richtig, aber man konnte so ganz diesem nachgehen.
Musste sich also nicht mit Geopolitik herumschlagen, weil es ohnehin alles in
die eine Richtung ging, nämlich die Richtung, die unter der Pax Amerika vorgegeben war.
Also man musste sich geopolitisch allenfalls, das hat ja Thoes schön formuliert,
mit Kriegen, die man sich aussuchen konnte, befassen.
Aber man wurde nicht überrascht jetzt von Angriffskriegen.
Genau. Und wir haben es aber nun mit einer anderen Situation zu tun.
Es gab ja schon vor über einem halben Jahr so einen Aufsatz.
Ich glaube, bei Bloomberg war der erschienen von Niall Ferguson,
wo er über die Gefahren eines möglichen dritten Weltkriegs war,
Und da auch nochmal so zeigt, wie es eine Abhängigkeit gibt von Inflation und
Kriegen, wie sich das eigentlich durchzieht durch die Geschichte.
Also, Neil Ferguson, nicht, dass wir uns da missverstehen, das ist natürlich
ein sehr, sehr konservativer Historiker, aber er hat das da nochmal sehr gut
aufgedröselt, wie das eigentlich funktioniert. Und Plagat referiert jetzt auch so eine Studie.
Eine recent study based on data since 1900 finds that geopolitical risks led
invariably to high inflation,
lower economic activity and a fall in international trade.
Und ECB-Analysen belegen, dass ähnliche Ergebnisse für die Zukunft erwartet werden.
Ja, das ist ja manchmal bei so Historikern, dass sie dann doch im Thema sich
gut verständigen können und dann ist wahrscheinlich auch Ferguson nicht so provokativ.
Aber ich meine, wir haben ja diese enorme Armut jetzt auch schon hier.
Also wir sehen das ja, wir haben einen Reallohnverlust, der so hoch ist wie zuletzt 2008.
Also die Leute werden de facto ärmer.
Sollen aber doppelt so teure Häuser kaufen.
Genau. Und wir haben dann zugleich diese unglaubliche Renaissance von Hunger in der Welt.
Auch das haben wir, wenn wir es jetzt global betrachten.
Und dann sind wir doch eigentlich an einem Punkt schon jetzt angelangt,
wo man sagen kann, wie lange wird das in dieser Instabilität gut gehen?
Oder gibt es so eine neue, im Westen jetzt auch, dass man sich mehr einrichtet in der Ungleichheit?
Also ich meine, es gibt ja Länder, die sind sehr viel ungleicher.
Brasilien, Südafrika, wir könnten ganz viele nennen.
Deutschland ist zwar auch ziemlich ungleich, aber es ist noch nicht so krass.
Es gibt auch hier schon gated communities, aber noch nicht so viele.
Also man geht noch nicht mit Privatschutz auf die Straße, wenn man Zahnarzt ist oder so etwas.
Ja und jetzt merken wir aber, wie eigentlich diese Kluft immer größer wird.
Ich meine, wir sehen das auch doch in Städten, wenn ich würde schon sagen,
dass auch im Stadtbild die Armut viel präsenter geworden ist.
Das scheint mir nicht nur so ein subjektiver Eindruck von mir zu sein.
Ich würde es auch noch weiter treiben, diese ganzen Kritiken an den jüngeren
Menschen, dass sie irgendwie freitags nicht arbeiten wollen und hier und da
und die Anforderungen und die breiten sich ja gar nicht aufs Alter vor, niemand spart.
Das ist ja auch so ein ne, angesichts der Weltlage, wie sie ist,
finde ich mich mal damit ab, dass ich jetzt erstmal sage, ich will heute einen schönen Tag haben.
Ich weiß nicht genau, was morgen ist. Und das schlägt sich da auch nieder.
Also wir haben das so im Gemütszustand, diese große politische Lage haben wir
im Gemütszustand schon viel weiter vorangeschritten, als, wir wissen ja,
wenn die Redaktion die Geschäfte führt, da immer akzeptiert und zugestanden wird.
Entsprechend laufen die Kommentare.
Und es ist absurd, was man den jungen Menschen zumutet. Mir schrieb ein Hörer und Student,
dass es nun in seinem Studentenwohnheim, natürlich in Baden-Württemberg,
wo kann sonst so etwas ausgerichtet werden, ein Energiesparwettbewerb stattfindet.
Und zwar treten dann die Wohnheime gegeneinander an, welches Wohnheim am meisten sparen kann.
Hier könnt ihr euch bei Livemusik, Afro-Dance und leckerem nachhaltigem sowie
kostenlosen Fingerfood über den Ablauf des Energiesparwettbewerbs informieren.
Da ist dann irgendein Event mitgebrachte Tupperdosen erwünscht. Dann am 23.05.
Werten wir einen Zwischenstand für jedes Wohnheim aus. Dieser Zwischenstand
wird auf allen unseren Online-Kanälen veröffentlicht.
Bei der finalen Messung im Juni wird dann der veränderte Stromverbrauch pro
Kopf in den Wohnheimen ermittelt. Das Wohnheim, das am meisten Strom einsparen
konnte, gewinnt als eine Wohnheimeinheit das Preisgeld für ein Wohnheimfest.
Wie zynisch kann eine E-Mail sein?
Du lebst auf 15 Quadratmetern, lädst dein Handy und dein Computer.
Das ist dein Stromverbrauch.
Zehn Meter weiter ist das erste Eigenheim von wem auch immer.
Da wird einfach jeden Sonntag eine Stunde mit einem 500 Watt Rasenmäher gemäht.
Sonntag hoffentlich nicht. Samstag.
So viel Strom kannst du gar nicht sparen. Also du kannst natürlich gegen die
anderen, die auf 15 Quadratmeter wohnen, ihr Handy nur halb so oft laden oder
sowas. Da kannst du noch Gewinne rausholen.
Aber es tut mir sehr leid für die ganzen baden-württembergischen.
Das ist wirklich schlimm da.
Ja, wir sprechen jetzt über die Rolle des Dollars.
Während der Pax Americana, nach 1945, wurde der US-Dollar als die globale Reserve-
und Transaktionskredite festgelegt.
Wir haben das ja jetzt nochmal ganz deutlich gesehen, nicht nur was die Sanktionen
anbelangt, sondern wenn die Fed die Zinsen anhebt, dann können die anderen Zentralbanken
nicht die Finger stillhalten,
müssen in gewisser Weise dann vielleicht etwas verspätet nachziehen,
aber sie müssen sich darauf ausrichten.
Ich frage mich, ob sich nicht hier auch schon so ein Bröckeln der MMT andeutet,
also wir haben es ja bei der MMT mit einer Idee zu tun, die natürlich sagt,
wir können Geld schöpfen und wir können dort nicht, wir müssen nicht auf den
Schuldenstand achten, solange wir eine produktive Wirtschaft haben.
Man kann natürlich ganz viele MMT Regime einführen, indem man jetzt,
sagen wir mal, wir hätten fünf Währungen, die etwa alle gleich auf sind, ja.
Dann sind die aber auch wieder voneinander in anderer Weise abhängig.
Und das bedeutet dann, dass möglicherweise dann das, was jetzt zum Beispiel
Griechenland oder so erlebt hat, dann einfach auf einer globalen Ebene nochmal
ganz anders stattfinden mit konkurrierenden Währungen.
Insofern ist dann natürlich irgendwann die Möglichkeit der Verschuldung auch
sehr stark limitiert durch die Interdependenzen, die sich ergeben,
indem man dort konkurrierende Währungen hat und dann Kapitalmärkte, die darauf reagieren.
Bröckeln, schwierig. Es ist ja immer die Frage, was heißt bröckeln?
Es kann natürlich diesen großen Knall geben.
Also Amerika, die Republikaner drehen irgendwie durch, pokern zu hoch und dann
heißt es, ja Staat ist jetzt pleite.
Schuldengrenze wurde nicht angehoben, aber die Schuldengrenze liegt jetzt bei 31 Billionen Dollar.
Nicht bezogen auf den Dollar, also wenn das Dollar-Regime jetzt so bliebe,
habe ich da keine Zweifel dran, aber jetzt stell dir mal vor,
wir hätten jetzt fünf Währungen neben dem Dollar oder drei neben dem Dollar,
die gleich stark sind in etwa in der Welt vertreten.
Dann wäre ja die Verschuldung, die dann doch wieder eine,
die in Abhängigkeit nicht einfach nur zu fett passiert, dass wir,
dass die einfach sagen, gut, dann machen, drucken wir nochmal,
sondern die bezieht ja, passiert dann auch in der Abhängigkeit zu dem, was gerade in Peking.
Ja, aber das halte ich für fast irrelevant, da ja die Europäer sagen,
für uns 500 Millionen Europäer gibt es nur den Euro als Verkehrswährung,
so wie die Amerikaner sagen auf amerikanischen.
Aber die internationalen Kapitalmärkte.
Ja, aber das ist ja egal, du brauchst ja die internationalen Kapitalmärkte gar nicht in diesem Ausmaß.
Dann müsste man die aber, das müsste man radikal reformieren.
Wenn du nicht allzu viel einkaufen musst von außen. Die Amerikaner haben ja
das Problem, dass sie sehr viel einkaufen müssen, dann können sie natürlich
in Abhängigkeiten kommen, wenn dann einfach gesagt wird, aber nicht mehr einen Dollar.
Ein Dollar, aber solange die Amerikaner jetzt diesen Weg da gehen und sagen,
die Schlüsseltechnologien werden über den in Anführungszeichen Inflation Reduction,
weil das gerade unser Problem ist, was wir medial gut verkaufen können, gefördert.
Also wir holen, reindustrialisieren das alles.
Und spielen auf Augenthöhe nicht nur auf Konsum,
sondern auch auf Angebotsseite mit, also die AI, der Tesla und so weiter,
kommt auch relativ viel aus Amerika, dann hat man glaube ich kein Problem damit
sich zu refinanzieren, auch bei der eigenen Zentralbank, egal was woanders auf
der Welt noch stattfindet.
Momentan jedenfalls noch nicht. Die anderen merken es ja, dass sie nicht einfach
Geld produzieren können, sondern dann, wenn sie zum Beispiel Entwicklungsland
sind, Schwierigkeiten haben.
Wenn ich gleich jetzt nicht die die MMT damit abwickeln will,
ich würde nur sagen, dass sich durch so eine neue geopolitische Machtkonstellation.
Also du siehst ja am Beispiel Japan, die ja mit ihrem eigenen Geld sich auf
250 Prozent verschulden und die sind ja genauso eingebunden in ein Weltsystem,
das nun nicht sehr viel Rücksicht auf den Yen nimmt und trotzdem finanzieren die sich da ohne Ende.
Ja, ja, das ist immer das Gegenbeispiel. Japan, damit funktioniert es.
Das kann Europa genauso machen. Wir sind jetzt beim Schuldenstand von 68 Prozent,
das heißt 200 Prozent sind noch offen. Die 200 Prozent kann man ja mal übertragen
in BIP pro Jahr. Und wie viel ist das eigentlich? Also wir haben noch extreme
Verschönerungsmöglichkeiten.
In diese Richtung ist noch ganz viel möglich, das selbstverständlich,
ich habe jetzt auf lange Sicht mich gefragt,
wie sich eigentlich so eine Theorie dann modifizieren müsste,
wenn wir jetzt Währungen hätten, mehrere Währungen,
die etwa gleich stark sind und wie sich dann diese Dominanz dann auch darin
ausdrückt, dass man dann den anderen die Verschuldung nicht gestattet oder inwieweit
man sich dann auch autonom machen kann.
Das ist natürlich ein Ansinnen der MMT sich dann da auch zu lösen,
dass man nicht nur in der Dollarhegemonie ist, also die amerikanische MMT reflektiert
ja selten, die Dollarhegemonie, die europäische MMT macht das natürlich schon sehr viel stärker.
Die Macht der Zentralbanken ist aber dann ja auch eine andere jetzt.
Payment Infrastructures, that's a topic, I tell you. It's highly technical,
it can come across as not so glamorous, but it's pretty important.
Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2017
Western Payment Infrastructure hat also einen immer größeren globalen Roll gespielt.
Zum Beispiel in der Dekade nach dem Berlin Wall, haben die Zahl der Länder,
die die Payment Messaging Networks nutzen, auf den Swift-Niveau gedreht.
Sie sind mehr als verdoppelt.
Und 2020 wurden über 90% der Cross-Border-Transmissions durch Swift signalisiert.
SWIFT kennen wir alles jetzt seit dem Ukraine-Krieg ganz wichtig als Infrastruktur
für die Payments, aber es ändert sich da was.
Die aktuellen Forschungen zeigen, dass es eine signifikante Korrelation zwischen
den Ländern, die mit China handeln, und den Resserven in den Renminbi hat.
So ist das halt, würde ich mal sagen. Da leben 1,4 Milliarden Menschen,
die gucken sehr viel mehr Fernsehen als die Amerikaner.
Es gibt sehr viel mehr chinesisch sprechende Menschen auf der Welt als englisch sprechende Menschen.
Und ja, auch beim Geld legt sich das nieder.
Es gibt sehr viel mehr Länder, die jetzt chinesisches Geld horten, um es als Dollar,
verwenden zu können.
On our western payment system and currency frameworks.
Also diese Blockbildung deutete sich schon an. Manche hatten ja auch die These,
und der würde ich zustimmen, möglicherweise konnte der Westen ein letztes Mal
so auftreten, mit Blick auf die Sanktionen, wie er das jetzt tat.
Ja, er ist aber auch das erste Mal so aufgetreten, muss man auch sagen.
Das stimmt wohl, ja. Zentralbanken so wegzubomben, das gab es ja vorher auch nicht.
Ja, und auch dieser Ausschluss aus Zwift, das gab es mal vorher schon mal tendenziell
mit dem Iran, aber dass man das so vehement gemacht hat, ist vielleicht dann
das erste Mal, aber in gewisser Weise auch schon möglicherweise das letzte Mal.
Für internationales Handeln, wie z.B. den chinesischen Renminbi oder den indischen Rupee.
Wir sehen auch eine erhöhte Akkumulation Gold als Alternativreservesatz,
möglicherweise von Ländern, die geopolitisch viel näher sind als China und Indien.
Crypto hat sie bemerkenswerterweise nicht erwähnt. Gold wäre dann noch eher
das, was Ijo Mamangold vielleicht erorten könnte.
Wenn der Krieg jetzt einen Krypto-Boom ausgelöst hätte, und zwar in dieser Ideologie,
ich muss mich in Sicherheit bringen, ich gehe jetzt in Krypto,
dann hätte es sich wahrscheinlich gemacht, hätte auch nochmal die eigenen Krypto-Ambitionen
der Zentralbanken betont.
Aber jetzt hat man ja gesehen, dass es einfach praktisch keine Rolle spielt.
Warum soll ich es nennen?
Dann lieber das Geld in Renminbi parken, oder? Hast du schon Renminbi?
Nein, aber ich denke gerade darüber nach. Also Amazon hat ja mal so diesen Amazon Coin hervorgehoben.
Es gibt ja so eine kleine Annehmlichkeit, die ich selbst auch nicht nutze.
Man kann bei Amazon sein Konto aufladen, sodass nicht jeder Kauf einzeln abgebucht wird auf dem Konto,
was ja gerade bei Geschäftskonten dann so ein bisschen, was haben sie da schon
wenn man so ein Konto hat, in dem man nur wichtige Sachen für seine Geschäftstätigkeit
kauft, kann man sich ja einmal im Monat von Amazon einfach 1000 Euro abbuchen
lassen und dann regeln die das intern auf der Plattform.
Und da könnte man dann so eine Umwandlung machen im Sinne von,
man lädt 1000 Euro auf und hat dann aber Amazon Coins, sodass die dann ihrerseits
wieder damit spielen könnten, was kann man jetzt eigentlich für die 1000 Euro kaufen.
Also kann man denen vielleicht noch eine Annehmlichkeit machen,
so wie Apple jetzt auch, Und sagt, wenn ihr euch bei uns verschuldet oder bei
uns ein Konto einrichtet oder wie auch immer, wir geben euch so vier Komma irgendwas
Prozent wie keine andere Bank.
Also das dann plötzlich über so eine, wir haben dich als Konsumenten und du
hast auch schon einen Account bei uns und wir haben deine Kreditkartendaten und so weiter.
Jetzt geben wir dir auch noch ein paar bänkerische Annehmlichkeiten und setzen
damit andere Banken Schachmatt, die dann einfach auf diesem Felde jemand bestellt
was und es wird nach Hause geliefert, gar nicht mehr mitspielen können.
Und jetzt gibt's ja in China Alibaba, noch größer als Amazon.
Wir kaufen aber bei Amazon nur Sachen, die aus China kommen.
Wir kriegen es nur nicht so richtig mit, weil Amazon ja für uns alle Sachen
regelt, inklusive das, was hier eingefahren wird und so.
Und es ist ja so weit geregelt, dass in Deutschland Warenhäuser sind,
die noch als chinesisch gelten, sodass alle Formalitäten erst greifen,
wenn aus dem auf deutschem Boden befindlichen Warenhaus ausgeliefert die Haustür abgelegt wird.
Was wäre, wenn Alibaba jetzt kommt und sagt, wir machen jetzt Konkurrenz zu Amazon.
Aber eben bei uns kauft man nicht in Euro, sondern in Alibaba-Coin.
Man kann also mit Euro da ein Konto aufladen.
Das wird dann automatisch, dieser Alibaba-Coin mit der chinesischen Währung korreliert,
sodass alle Synergieeffekte hinsichtlich, wir haben die Lieferketten,
wir haben viel besseren Zugang zu der chinesischen Regierung,
um Exportbestimmungen zu klären und so weiter, also dass da relativ viele ...
So Rabattsysteme greifen, die Güter billiger machen, aber unter der Bedingung,
dass der deutsche Kunde die demnächst in chinesischer Währung bei Alibaba abrechnet und kauft.
Und dann erhältst du plötzlich ganz viele Leute, die ganz schön viele chinesische
Währung auf ihren Verkehrskonto hätten,
in Anführungszeichen, weil die dann plötzlich feststellen, Mein kleiner Geldberg,
den ich bei Alibaba geparkt habe, ist mir vielleicht wichtiger als mein Girokonto.
Weißt du? Also da gibt es für die Zukunft,
gerade wenn das alles so in Smartphones wandert und wir wissen ja,
was Elon Musk gerade plant, dass man mit X, wie er Twitter jetzt in der Dachgesellschaft
heißt, künftig auch Micropayments macht und so.
Also da gibt es ganz schön viele Einflügschneisen, um den Dollar so ein bisschen
aus dem Spiel zu nehmen und den Euro auch.
Hast du schon mal was bei Alibaba bestellt?
Nee, noch nicht.
Nutzt man das? Wird das in Deutschland schon stark genutzt?
Also Amazon hat ja so richtig eigene Infrastruktur. Ja. Also bis hin zum Postboden,
der das bringt, eigene Warenhäuser, also Warenlager, in denen das dann organisiert wird.
Alibaba ist ja mehr so ein Netzwerk, die das halt so organisieren.
Deswegen sind die da sehr viel flexibler in so Ausgestaltung von,
wie man das künftig organisiert und so.
Aber ich habe keinen Account da. Ich höre aber immer Scott Galloway,
der sagt, wenn man irgendwo rein investiert, dann sollte man jetzt in Alibaba
investieren, weil er da irgendwelche Sachen erwartet.
Also eine kleine Sensorik dafür, was passiert denn da so. Aber mal sehen.
Noch, aber ist die Welt in Ordnung?
So far the data do not show substantial changes in the use of international currencies.
But they do suggest that international currency status should no longer be taken
for granted and that we should be really attentive to the currency in which
trade transactions are organized.
That is in my view particularly the case for oil.
Aha, ja, Energielieferungen und das dann in der Landeswährung,
das ist ja etwas, was immer wieder die Debatten anheizt und die Amerikaner nervös macht.
Wir merken uns mal, noch ist alles in Ordnung und hören erstmal noch einen Clip
aus der Diskussion danach, die nicht besonders interessant war.
Aber da sagt Lagarde plötzlich mal so etwas und du hast es eben auch schon mal ausgesprochen.
Keiner in diesem Raum oder weiter kann sich vorstellen, dass die Vereinigten
Staaten auf ihre Schulden verzichten.
Das ist überall in der Falschgau.
Und das wäre die natürlichen Folgen, wenn man nicht die richtige Entscheidung im Juni machen würde.
Und es würde kein Deflagration in diesem Land sein, sondern es würde Schockwaves um die Welt schicken.
Ja, wir haben das im Fernsehpodcast schon mal thematisiert, die Demokraten haben das weiße Haus,
die Republikaner haben die Mehrheit im Kongress und im Kongress gibt es aber
innerhalb der republikanischen Mehrheit so eine kleine Gruppe von 40 Leuten oder so oder 20,
die ja Kevin McCarthy die Speakerrolle abgesprochen haben.
Wir haben einfach gesagt, so wie bei Kai Wegner, du stellst dich hier zur Wahl.
Wir sagen Nein, das ist eine geheime Wahl, aber wir geben uns trotzdem zu erkennen,
weil wir hier ein Statement machen wollen und dann gibt es irgendwelche Zugeständnisse
und man weiß nicht so genau.
Und die Abweichler haben ja besonders Wert darauf gelegt, anzumerken,
bei der Anhebung der Schuldenbremse als Resultat der Haushaltsverhandlung,
wie viel kann Amerika ausgeben und so weiter, möchten wir Veto einlegen.
So Lindenartig diese ganzen Exzesse in der Verschuldung, das geht ja alles gar
nicht. Der Staat muss mal zurückgefahren werden, wie man es halt so kennt von den Republikanern.
Und da kam auch die Debatte auf, was bedeutet das jetzt eigentlich?
Sie hat es jetzt auch noch mal betont, ja, wir können uns das nicht so richtig
vorstellen, aber irgendwie steht es halt auch im Raum, weil die Entscheidung
muss dann gefällt werden. Jetzt haben die Republikaner so ein kleines Zugeständnis.
Also man rettet sich jetzt mit einer Billion extra oder so durch die nächste
Zeit, aber die große Debatte soll noch kommen.
Und vielleicht war unsere These damals, ich wiederhole sie nochmal,
Da wird die Haushaltsdebatte und die Anhebung der Schuldengrenze ein parlamentarisches Resultat zeigen,
dass die beiden eigentlich verfeindeten Parteien, die sich gar nichts mehr gönnen,
dann doch zusammenarbeiten.
Denn das Repräsentantenhaus braucht einfach eine Mehrheit.
Jetzt gibt es eine Mehrheit dadurch, dass die Republikaner die größere Fraktion
sind. Nur wenn die in der Fragestellung keine Mehrheit organisieren,
werden die Demokraten nicht daneben stehen und sagen, das ist nicht unser Programm.
Wir verweigern jetzt die Mehrheit, sondern dann werden sich in dem Maße,
wie Republikaner ausfallen, Demokraten finden, die die Mehrheit herstellen.
Also wenn einfach 27 Leute bei der ersten Abstimmung sagen Nee und so,
dann wird es bei der zweiten Abstimmung 28 Demokraten geben,
die dann plötzlich sagen, Ja doch, wir organisieren mal diese Mehrheit,
weil dieses Szenario ist wirklich einfach undenkbar.
Und wenn aber sowas passiert, also so ein Bipartisan-Dingsda-Bums,
und es ist wirklich rein hypothetisch so, dann haben wir es mit einer neuen
Realität zu tun, weil die dann in Amerika auch von den Journalisten nicht mehr
darstellen können, dass sie eigentlich einen totalen Nonsensstreit führen.
Dass sich einfach da nur zwei Parteien als Vitocracy gegenüberstehen,
sich gar nichts untereinander gönnen, damit nicht der jeweilige Präsident als
hat ja was geregelt bekommt,
weil man kann, also man gewinnt gar nichts, wenn man als republikanische Partei
am Ende von einer Amtszeit des Präsidenten sagt, guck mal, der kriegt ja gar
nichts geregelt, nicht mal die Schuldenbremse anzuheben, weil dann gibt es einfach kein Amerika mehr.
Also dann greift so ein Szenario, dass wir alle nicht formulieren können.
Wir wissen alle nicht, was bedeutet, wenn Amerika sich Bankrott erklärt.
Bemerkenswert aber, dass sie es ausspricht.
Ja, aber das hieße ja wirklich, dass keine einzige Gehaltszahlung an irgendeinen
amerikanischen Soldaten mehr stattfindet und das ist einfach nicht denkbar.
Das wäre auch totaler Quatsch, sowas zu organisieren, nur um dem weißen Haus
eins auszuwischen. Und dann hat man aber eine andere Diskussion.
Also die Journalisten würden, also die Demokraten würden es nicht darauf ankommen
lassen, dass es nicht zu einer Schuldenanhebung kommt.
Und die Journalisten können dann nicht einfach sagen, ah ja,
da sind die Demokraten eingeknickt oder sowas und haben dann plötzlich dieses
andere Programm mitgestimmt oder so, sondern das muss dann wirklich anders diskutiert
werden und würde es dann auch.
Wir hören noch einmal Lagarde.
This will be pivotal in determining whether the euro remains among the leading
global currencies or others, those exotic ones that I mentioned earlier on, take its place.
Das ist eine Idee, die Macron auch jetzt laufend vorbringt, die sie hier noch mal artikuliert.
Alle außer Lindner. Außer Lindner, genau. Alle außer Lindner.
Wir haben ja sowieso doch ein bisschen schwieriges Verhältnis zwischen Deutschland
und Frankreich gerade. Ich würde schon sagen, dass Olaf Scholz und Macron nicht best friends sind.
Sagen wir es mal so, Macron fährt nach China und nimmt Lagarde mit,
dann kommen die deutschen Journalisten. Er nimmt Ursula von der Leyen mit.
Ursula von der Leyen mit.
Dann kommen die deutschen Journalisten und sagen, die sind sich aber gar nicht
grün, die Ursula von der Leyen fährt ein ganz anderes Programm als Macron.
Keiner kommt auf den Gedanken aufzuschreiben, ja Scholz fuhr damals hin und
hat Ursula von der Leyen nicht mitgenommen.
Obwohl das eigentlich, dass da zwei Europäer hinfahren, die eine leicht unterschiedliche
Meinung haben und so, okay.
Aber dass Olaf Scholz einfach als allererster Staatsgast nach Chies Wiederwahl
und Wiederwahl in Anführungszeichen, also Ausrufungen auf Lebenszeit und so
weiter, da einfach Stimmung macht und niemand mitnimmt.
Das ist der Skandal. Und Macron kennt ja die Position von von der Leyen.
Der sitzt ja nicht in Peking und denkt, ach so, die sind das jetzt gar nicht ganz genauso.
Ein paar deutsche Journalisten haben sich noch mal daran erinnert,
als sie betonten, dass es einen großen Streit gibt zwischen Ursula von der Leyen
und Macron. Nicht nur, dass Macron sie eingeladen hat mitzukommen,
sondern dass es Macrons Vorschlag war, Ursula von der Leyen überhaupt in den Posten zu gehen.
Sonst wäre es ja jemand anderes geworden, wie wir wissen.
Also man sieht so langsam, der deutsche Journalismus, sie kriegen die eigenen
Inkonsistenzen nicht mehr in Texte zusammengebunden, weil dann immer jemand kommt und so.
Ja stimmt, das passt ja gar nicht. Ich möchte gar nicht über den Streit streiten,
aber das würde gar nicht passen.
Lagarde probiert es jetzt mit Literatur.
Und ich möchte jemanden paraphrasieren, den ich extensiv gelesen habe und der
seine Zeit in Europa gut verbracht hat,
Ernest Hemingway, der über eine Bankrupte-Situation spricht,
in der der Sonnenschein auch aufsteigt.
Ich werde paraphrasieren, ich spreche hier nicht über Bankrupte. Don't get me wrong.
Ich sage, dass es um Fragmentation geht. Fragmentation kann in zwei Wegen passieren.
Graduell und dann plötzlich. Die Zentralbank muss eine Stabilität in einem Alter
geben, in dem es nur stabil ist. Und ich habe keine Zweifel,
dass Zentralbanken die Herausforderung nachweisen werden.
Sicherlich werden wir bei der Europäischen Zentralbank. Thank you.
Dies ist aus dem Roman Fiesta und es ist ein Dialog und da wird dann gefragt, how did you go bankrupt?
Und die Antwort ist in two ways, gradually, then suddenly.
Und ich finde interessant, dass sie hier nochmal erläutert, dass sie Hemingway studiert hat.
Das ist eines der bekanntesten Zitate von Hemingway und wird fast überall in
Finanzblocks ständig immer herbeizitiert,
wenn es um Inflation, Deflation, Also Christine Lagarde ist viel beschäftigt
und sie liest mehr bellitteristisch als ich, wie ich hier raushöre.
Wobei ich hier wieder denke, irgendwer aus ihrem Umfeld wird dieses Zitat und
so, wenn sie vielleicht fasziniert gewesen sei, wie auch immer.
Das glaube ich schon, dass sie das auch selbst kennt.
Ich finde jedenfalls mal wieder gut, wenn man sie so hört. Man hört ja auch
diesen Ton, Stimme und Stimmung. Gut, dass sie da irgendwie da ist.
Maurice Höfgen war jetzt in so einem Bitcoin-Podcast, wo er auch nochmal anmerkte,
bisher war das für Zentralbanken super easy.
Sie hat es ja auch genannt, dieses Steering through the history und so weiter.
Es war halt bisher, hat man mit nicht viel Turbulenzen und Fragmentierungen
und geht ja irgendwer pleite und so, Anmerkungen zu kämpfen.
Jetzt ist das Aufgabenportfolio größer und die Zentralbanken wissen aber,
wir können hier nur Zins machen, nur Zins steuern.
Und wir wissen nicht genau, wir haben ja im Allerersten damals als Lagarde da
saß und meinte, wir wissen nicht genau, was Inflation ist. Wir müssen uns das
noch mal genau angucken und so.
Und ich höre dann irgendwie immer wieder raus, wenn man sie so hört, gut, dass sie da ist.
Jetzt hat ja Christine Lagarde im April auch, wir werden uns das auf jeden Fall noch anschauen.
Eine neue Regulierung der Schuldenregeln, also der Maastricht-Regeln,
kennen wir ja, 60 Prozent, drei Prozent pro Jahr und so, angemerkt.
Und das deutsche Finanzministerium hatte nichts Besseres zu tun,
als am Tage der Veröffentlichung der neuen Regeln, als Vorschlag,
über die jetzt mal zu diskutieren ist und so weiter, ein Financial Times Op-Ed
von Christian Lindner zu veröffentlichen, in dem das alles torpediert wurde.
Und wenn hier irgendwer an, und wir haben ja gehört, in welchem Maße wissen
wir nicht, Untergang aussieht, wenn irgendwer schuld ist, dann Christian Lindner.
Ja. Es ist wirklich eine ganz große Dramatik, die wir hier erleben, jeden Tag aufs Neue.
Es ist wirklich ganz schlimm und ich habe mit Absicht,
damit wir hier auch den Puls niedrig halten, Keine Clips vom Deutschlandfunk,
die sich sehr gelangweilt haben auf dem FDP-Parteitag, weil das ach so große
rhetorische Talent Christian Lindner dann doch mal eine eher langweilige Rede gehalten hat und ich.
Dachte mir nur, ja dann hört euch doch mal die Inhalte an.
David Axelrod hat eine sehr interessante Anmerkung gemacht zum amerikanischen
Wahlkampf, das so in diese Richtung geht.
Obama, und er war ja damals Obama's Wahlkampfleiter, Obamas größtes Problem war 2004,
bei der Convention für den damaligen,
ich weiß gar nicht wer angetreten ist, John Kerry oder so, eine Wahlkampfrede
zu halten bei der Convention, große Bühne, das ganze Publikum ist voller Wahlkämpfer
und so weiter, dass ja die Welt erschüttert hat.
Daraufhin sagte sich dann Sorkin und so weiter, wir bauen in Westwing auch so
einen Kandidaten ein, der so funktioniert wie.
Und dann haben sie plötzlich diesen und so weiter ersten schwarzen Präsidenten
auf dem Papier und dann sagt Obama später, ja, ich habe mich eigentlich an eine
Fernsehserie orientiert und die Fernsehautoren sagen, ja, wir haben es eigentlich
an Obama. Also es gab diese 2004er Rede.
Alle wussten, oh, dieser Senator aus Illinois, das wird mal eine große Nummer.
Viertelstunde hat uns alle gefesselt es gibt kein besseres rhetorisches Talent
als dieser Barack Obama. Dann beginnt der Vorwahlkampf.
Barack Obama tritt also an, alle sind in großer Erwartung, gehen zu diesen Reden
hin und stellen fest, boah, das war irgendwie langweilig.
Das war ja gar nicht die 2004 Rede, die ich erwartet habe. Der hat ja irgendwie
eine Stunde lang irgendwelche Inhalte erzählt. Ich wollte doch einfach nur zehn
Minuten lang, was ich bei YouTube gesehen habe und so.
Und das größte Problem für den Wahlkampf war zu organisieren,
dass die Leute nicht so krasse Erwartungen haben an diesen Fernsehauftritt 2004.
Obama hält die große Rede für John Kerry.
Und daran ist er dann gescheitert. Und das bedeutet aber wieder,
wenn jetzt alle Welt betont, der Joe Biden, der ist ja kurz vor Tod und so weiter
und er macht dann eine gute Szene im Fernsehen, dann gehen alle wieder rum, nicht schlecht.
Und in der Hinsicht ist diese Entkopplung von Realität und überhaupt,
das ist immer wieder bezeichnend und schlägt sich leider bis hin zu FDP-Parteitagen
nieder. Oder bei Friedrich Merz hatten wir das genauso.
Die Journalisten haben ja noch 20 Jahre nach der letzten großen Rede von Friedrich
Merz behauptet, das ist ja ein ganz tolles rhetorisches Talent,
um uns dann jedes Mal wieder zu sagen, also das war aber diesmal wirklich nicht gut.
Er gilt ja eigentlich als rhetorisches Talent, aber diesmal nicht gut.
Also Stefan Dittjen hat ja noch nach der 17.
Rede und der zweiten Niederlage als Vorsitzenderkandidat darauf hingewiesen,
das ist ja eigentlich ein großes rhetorisches Talent, nur diesmal ist er leider gescheitert.
Also das sitzt so tief und so fest, dass auch die, ich erwarte nichts mehr von
deutschen Journalisten beim Blick auf Christian Lindner, außer dass sie mir
noch 20 Jahre lang erzählen, dass es aber ein ganz großes rhetorisches Talent
ist. Aber diese Rede war leider langweilig.
Wir hören uns erst ein akustisches Rätsel an.
So Stefan, du siehst auch etwas dabei. Du siehst hier ein Viertel einer Großstadt
und du hörst dieses Geräusch. Kannst du das einordnen?
Also ich sehe natürlich, was du in den Clip reingeschrieben hast. Es ist Topfschlagen.
Genau. Die Franzosen schlagen auf die Töpfe als Demonstration gegen Macrons Rentenreform.
Ich dachte, als Dank an die Sozialbeamten.
Und es werden jetzt auch bei irgendwelchen öffentlichen Auftritten von Macron
immer die Taschen durchsucht, die Taschen durchsucht von der Polizei,
ob Leute Töpfe mit reinbringen.
Die Gelbweste, die alle verpflichtend in ihrem Auto haben müssen.
Den Topf, den jeder zu Hause in seiner Küche hat.
Das ist wirklich hervorragend, was sie da machen. Und Macron war dann in Den
Haag beim Nexus-Institut und hat dort eine Rede gehalten.
Da wurden nicht Töpfe geschlagen, aber da ging es auch erst mal munter zu.
Demonstranten störten dort die Rede. Es ging um mangelnden Klimaschutz und es
ging selbstredend um die Rentenreform.
Macron nimmt das dann sehr locker und setzt dann wieder an und erläutert hier
mal ganz nonchalant sein Demokratieverständnis, das meinen Augen auch das eine
oder andere Defizit aufweist.
Was sollte Demokratie beitragen, wenn man wählt und die Menschen wählt?
Und die gewählten Menschen wählen für Regeln, und sie müssen die Strukturen
respektieren. Und diese Strukturen wurden von Menschen gewählt.
Aber das Gegenteil ist, dass man Respekt braucht, und das ist das Ende der Violenz.
Den Tag, an dem man sich vorstellt, dass,
wenn ich mit dem Gesetz, das verpasst wurde, oder mit den Menschen,
die gewählt wurden, entgegne, kann ich tun,
was ich will, weil ich die Entscheidung für die Legitimität meiner Arbeit mache,
Er hat ja gerade die Demokratie stark beschädigt dadurch, dass er das durchgedrückt hat.
Zwar gibt das die Gesetzgebung vor oder ermöglicht es, dass man das machen kann,
aber man kann nun wirklich jetzt nicht davon sprechen, dass das ein besonders
demokratischer Akt ist, den er da vollzieht.
Es gibt immer ganz verschiedene, ganz komische, wie auch in Amerika.
Du kannst einmal ein Haushaltsgesetz machen pro Jahr und dann kannst du es genau
einmal überarbeiten als Präsident, ohne dass du dafür eine parlamentarische
Mehrheit brauchst. Aber einmal.
Weshalb ja Biden dann immer kam mit, mein neues Gesetzespaket ist sechs Billionen
groß, weil ich habe ja nur einen Schuss.
Und lauter solche Sachen. Also ganz verrückt. Und dann reicht es einmal mit
einer Fifty-Fifty-Mehrheit, wo man dann nicht eine eigentlich 60-40-Mehrheit
im Senat, die ja völlig ausgeschlossen ist, schon seit ewig.
Und bei der EU-Kommission ist ja auch, die EU-Kommission wird halt besetzt.
Und dann kam mal die Kritik, das ist ja alles gar nicht demokratisch.
Und dann war die Antwort, naja, du hast ja Staatschefs, die Kandidaten ernennen,
also die Regierung ernennen, dann Kommissionskandidaten.
Und das Europäische Parlament segnet sie ab. Und wir haben ja das Parlament
gewählt, wir haben ja unseren Staatschef gewählt, also unsere Regierung,
unsere Bundesregierung und unsere Parlamentarier im europäischen Parlament.
Das heißt, wenn die beiden, dann ist es doppelt aber indirekt demokratisch legitimiert.
Also die EU-Kommission ist formal, so lernt man es, wenn der Professor vor einem
steht und dann sagt, wie das Gesetz entsteht, sagt, ja, da kommt die EU-Kommission,
die ist ja doppelt indirekt demokratisch legitimiert, etwas zu entscheiden.
Die Grenzen sind eigentlich so ein bisschen schwammig, wo ist es noch?
Es ist ein bisschen so, wir wissen betrunken Autofahren ist verboten,
aber wenn ich vielleicht nur Gas trete und du lenkst, dann können wir es machen.
Dann ist ja verteilte Verantwortung und dann sind wir beide nur halbschuldig.
Es ist schon, naja, so sieht es Macron jedenfalls. Jetzt spricht er über sein
eigentliches Thema, europäische Souveränität.
European sovereignty could seem as a strange word.
For years, this concept may have sounded like a French fantasy,
or perhaps like European wishful thinking. I have to say, when I delivered a
speech in La Sorbonne, September 17th, a lot of comments were about...
Okay, europäische Sovereigenschaft ist eine französische Idee,
es ist nur ein Wort, es wird nie passieren.
Das finde ich schön, dass er hier nochmal darauf Bezug nimmt,
dass er da einfach nicht ernst genommen wurde, missverstanden wurde.
Vor allem die sechs Jahre alte Rede, hier hört man nochmal, wie wichtig sie
ihm war. Er erwähnt sie nochmal und sagt dann a lot of comments,
also aus Deutschland gab es ja gar keine Kommentare.
Ja, es ist schlimm.
Er zitiert von Spinoza aus dem Politisch-Theologischen Traktat.
350 Jahre her, hier in der Stadt von The Hague,
schrieb einer der Gründer der politischen Modernität, Baruch Spinoza,
in Artikel 17, Kapitel 2 seines Tractatus Politicus, Die Rechte werden durch
die Macht der Mehrheit definiert.
Wir nennen es Sovereignis.
Identität und Souveränität sind verbunden.
Und ich denke, es ist sehr wichtig, diesen Link zu verstehen.
Und der Fakt, dass Spinoza ihn
als eines der grundlegenden Konzepte der politischen Philosophie macht.
Denn wenn du dir die Souveränität verlassen willst, Das bedeutet,
wenn man auf andere Mächte abhängt, stellt man sich in die Situation,
sich nicht für sich selbst zu entscheiden und sich nicht dafür zu verantworten,
dass man genau weiterholt, präsentiert, entwickelt seine eigene Identität.
Das, finde ich, ist aber eine sinnvolle Identitätskonstruktion, dass man sagt,
sie sich nur da ausbilden kann, wo man von anderen Mächten nicht beeinflusst
wird oder nicht unter deren Vormacht steht.
Ich würde allerdings sagen, dass man mit dem Identitätsbegriff eigentlich da
gar nicht operieren müsste.
Zumal wir es ja in Europa mit so vielen Identitäten zu tun haben,
allein schon auf den nationalen Ebenen und dann noch mal in der Bevölkerung.
Also als deutscher Staatsbürger bin ich eh schon überfordert,
dass ein Politiker so viel mit mir reden möchte und dann noch philosophisch,
das bin ich gar nicht gewohnt.
Wir hören uns jetzt seine Definition von Souveränität an.
Das heißt, wir müssen unser eigenes Schicksal in die Hand nehmen können.
Das bedeutet also nicht, das nur zu machen, was unser NATO-Partner USA möchte
und bedeutet auch, dass wir uns unsere Partner selbst aussuchen sollen.
Sprich, wenn Macron mit China zusammenarbeiten will, dann soll das auch französische
Souveränität bedeuten, dass sie das können.
Übrigens, China ist ja relativ wichtig auch für den reichsten Mann der Welt,
Bernard Arnault, der ja in Frankreich lebt.
VMH hat ja jetzt einen neuen Aktienrekord und dieser Rekord verdankt sich auch
einer doch sehr engen Kooperation mit China, denn dort gibt es auch reiche Leute,
die viele teure Sachen kaufen wollen.
Nun schlägt Macron eine neue Doktrin vor. Und für mich sollte diese neue Doktrin
auf fünf Pillaren basieren.
Die erste Pillar ist sehr bekannt, aber ich möchte darauf hinweisen,
dass sie der Native der Europäischen Union ist.
Das ist Kompetenz und eine stärkere und bessere europäische Integration.
Also diesen Produktivitätszuwachs, den man erwartet, kriegt man ja vielleicht,
wenn man nicht gegen den Gemütszustand, sondern mit dem Gemütszustand arbeitet,
so hin, dass es am Ende faktisch vielleicht sieben Prozent wären.
Dann teilt man das aber durch zwei und beteiligt beide Seiten,
Arbeitgeber und Arbeitnehmer.
Also man sagt einem Arbeitnehmer, arbeite mal bitte fünf Prozent mehr,
aber wir beteiligen dich nicht mit null, sondern mit 3,5 Prozent.
Es sei denn, und dann macht man irgendwelche Anreizsysteme, um das so rauszukitzeln.
Das ist ja eine deutsche Debatte, die auch noch zu führen ist.
Ja, ich befürchte nur, dass es gar nicht darum geht, in irgendeiner Weise die
Bevölkerung froh zu machen, sondern das ist ein Gesetz, das sich so umsetzen muss.
Ausrichtet, dass erst mal das Kapital im Inland froh gemacht wird dadurch.
Und zum anderen, dass die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit auf internationaler Ebene damit
gestärkt wird. Und das ist ja das Problem auch bei diesen ganzen Souveränitätsdenken
und wo ich auch dann als Linker meine höchsten Probleme damit habe.
Souveränität im Sinne von, dass wir uns da ein bisschen unabhängiger machen
in Entscheidungen als Europa ist das eine.
Aber Souveränität in dem Sinne, dass wir in dieses Konkurrenzsystem treten,
bedeutet natürlich und die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit verstärken, dass die Arbeiter
grundsätzlich dem zu dienen haben, was das Interesse des Kapitals ist.
Und das bedeutet dann natürlich, dass der Druck nach unten abgegeben wird,
also dass man das entweder über Lohndrücken macht oder Aufstocksysteme, Agenda 2010.
Oder man macht das jetzt über Verlängerung der Arbeitszeit.
Also wir kommen ja nicht drum rum, dass solche Produktivitätsdiskurse jetzt
geführt werden, weil einfach das Erwerbspersonenpotenzial schrumpft,
aber wir am Wachstum festhalten.
Also wir brauchen ein neues Paradigma. Und jetzt mal die normativen Sachen ausgeblendet.
Wenn wir den deutschen Rentnern ... Es gibt ja zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder wir sagen ihnen, arbeite länger.
Das ist ja auch, was die heißt von der Körperstiftung auf der Bühne.
Können wir nicht einfach länger arbeiten? Dann sag ich, nein,
wir können nicht einfach länger arbeiten. Wir sehen zum einen,
die Menschen wollen so gar nicht. Und die Frage ist, wie organisiert man das überhaupt?
Wenn man jetzt aber das Angebot macht zu sagen, und da ist ja Deutschland schon
auf dem Weg, zu sagen, darfst du unendlich dazu verdienen.
Es gibt gar keine Obergrenze mehr. Also jeder im Rentenalter darf sich für Gehaltszahlungen,
die bei ihm anlanden, produktiv für Arbeitgeber und so weiter einbringen.
Und dann, wenn du einmal im Rentenalter bist, bezahlst du ja nicht mehr die Rentenkasse ein.
Also du kriegst schon mal mehr netto vom Brutto. Wenn man jetzt sagt,
naja, wir streichen einfach alle Sozialabgaben, weil du hast ja 45 Jahre oder
was auch immer, Also du bist ja über die Altersgrenze gerutscht und dazu sagt
man noch es gibt auch keine Lohnsteuer mehr.
Menschen im Rentenalter arbeiten nur noch für die eigene Tasche.
Also sie kassieren das Brutto-Gehalt.
Heute ist ja so, dass man selbst die Rentenleistung, die man bekommt,
noch mal versteuern muss als Einkommen.
Wenn man dann sagt, naja, das belassen wir, also auf deine Rente musst du Steuern
zahlen, aber auf das Einkommen, das du zusätzlich generierst,
fällt gar keine Abgabe und gar keine Steuer mehr an.
Dann hättest du nämlich dieses Phänomen, dass Menschen einfach vor die Wahl
gestellt werden, okay, 3.800 brutto und dann 2.700 netto. Möchtest du einfach
noch ein Jahr dranhängen und dann für 3.800 netto. Und dann wird ja eine ganz
andere Entscheidung getroffen.
Das ist ja eine ungeheure Subventionierung von Arbeit im Alter.
Naja, aber die Sozialabgabe ist ja trotzdem abgeleistet erstmal.
Die wird ja wirklich nicht mehr fällig, weil du zahlst ja nicht mal die Rentenkasse
ein, dein Beitrag ist ausreichend eingedrängt.
Nur wenn dann auch keine Steuern darauf anfallen, ist es ja ein unglaublicher
Wettbewerbsvorteil alter Leute gegenüber jungen Leuten.
Ja, aber ich bin ja sowieso, ja, also das zum einen und deswegen ist es ja auch eine Diskussion.
Also erstmal geht es ja nur darum, Produktivität rauszukitzeln aus dem Erwerbsversuchspotenzial
und danach mit den Folgen politisch zu hantieren.
Und da wäre ich nämlich sowieso dafür, dass man sagt, naja, dann machen wir
mal bei den Älteren und die Einflugsteile sind ja immer die Älteren,
auch beim bedingungslosen Grundeinkommen wie in Amerika.
Wenn du kriegst, dass man grundsätzlich deine Gesundheitssachen bezahlt und
so, die dir vorher immer verwehrt wurden, gewissen Altersgrenze bezahlt der
Staat dann schon deine medizinischen Rechnungen.
Wenn man dann sagt, naja, ja,
aber das Modell der nicht mehr belasteten Lohnarbeit ist damit etabliert,
wenn man sich dann fragt, aber wo sollen denn dann die Staatseinkommen herkommen,
dann kann man ja sagen, 10 Prozent Erbschaftsteuer, 25 Prozent Kapitalertrag, 40 plus Arbeit.
Gut, da sind wir ja mal begannt.
Ja, aber wenn man die drei Säulen hat, wenn man die Arbeit entlastet,
um wie viel muss man dann Kapitalerträger und Erben eigentlich drauflegen,
um da einen Ausgleich zu finden.
Und das muss man sich halt überlegen, wenn man das nicht organisiert,
fehlt die Produktivität.
Weißt du eigentlich, dass es mal jemanden gab, der sich dafür eingesetzt hat,
dass man ab 100 keine Steuern mehr zahlen muss?
Ab 100 was?
Ab 100 Jahren. Wer?
Johannes Heesters. Ja, klar.
Und er ist ja 108 geworden und es gab damals sogar eine Aktion bei Florian Silbereisen
in der Show, ich weiß noch, als sei es gestern gewesen.
Da sind sie zum Finanzministerium, also Florian Silbereisen oder dieser Redaktion
und hat mit Hans Eichel gesprochen. Hans Eichel sitzt da und sagt,
nee, das geht leider nicht.
Also auch die über 100-Jährigen müssen Steuern zahlen.
Ja, also man wird als Kapitalhaber vor die Wahl gestellt.
Wir müssten deine Kapitalertragssteuer ein bisschen erhöhen.
Dafür bleiben dir aber Arbeiter.
Deine Produktivität bleibt dann. Oder du bleibst bei deinen Kapitalerträgen,
aber damit verschwindet auch entsprechend der Entwicklungen Produktivität aus
deinem Unternehmen, weil du wirst keinen Nachwuchs finden.
Nun geht es jetzt hier bei dieser Rentenreform nur um Produktivität.
Es geht doch erstmal darum,
dass Macron ein System geschaffen hat, das Reiche nochmal sehr viel reicher macht,
dadurch, dass er Spitzensteuersätze gesenkt hat,
dass er eigentlich die Reichen nochmal gut aus der Rechnung rausgenommen hat
und jetzt werden, um diese Sozialsysteme zu finanzieren, die anderen zu Kasse
gebeten, in der Form, dass sie länger arbeiten. Eher rechtfertigt das aber jetzt folgendermaßen.
Das heißt die Souveränitätsrede, die er hier hält und die Verteidigung der Souveränität
ist ein und dasselbe Programm mit dem,
was er mit der Rentenreform macht,
das heißt, wenn wir das hier im Podcast manchmal tun und unterscheiden,
es gibt den unsozialen Macron in der Innenpolitik, aber den durchaus sinnvoll
agierenden Außenpolitiker, Da müssen wir natürlich schon zur Kenntnis nehmen,
dass das beides zusammen geht.
Es müsste aber nicht so in dieser Weise umgesetzt werden. Ich würde sagen,
es ist genau falschrum. Wie Macron das macht.
In seinem Sinne auch.
Und das liegt aber daran, dass er an dieser Wettbewerbsfähigkeit festhält,
die er auch auf europäischer innerer Ebene dann sieht.
Also zum einen will er auch, wie Lagarde, den einheitlichen Kapitalmarkt und
so etwas. Und dann sieht er aber schon auch die Staaten als Konkurrenten zwischen sich.
Und wir haben ja auch unser Salonbuch im übrigen über das Buch von Patrick Katzmerik gesprochen,
über Kampf der Nationen, wo er sehr schön zeigt,
dass diese Wettbewerbsfähigkeit innerhalb Europas natürlich zu einem Preisdumping
führt, dazu führt, dass selbst die eigentlich produktiven Industrien nicht mehr
produktiv sein können. Wenn du eine Wettbewerbsfähigkeit.
Bauen möchte oder erhalten möchtest und du weißt, das kostet Anstrengung,
muss man dieses Ansinnen, wir möchten uns sozusagen rein zwingen in den Weltmarkt,
inventieren statt kopieren.
Du kannst es nicht gegen deine Bevölkerung machen, sondern du brauchst ja eigentlich
besondere Anreizsysteme, damit die alle mitmachen.
So ein Freiwilligkeitsding, so wie jetzt in Amerika, dass man einfach sagt,
wenn du in erneuerbaren Energien gehst, dann sorgen wir für die Hälfte deines
Profits und so und dann wird es einfach staatlich finanziert.
Und so wäre das ja hier auch. Man braucht Anreizsysteme, damit die Menschen
das mitmachen, weil gegen sie, also es ist ja Quatsch, die verschwenden jetzt
sinnlos Zeit eigentlich.
Dieses ganze Land liegt brach. Die wollen, also die Lobbyleute haben sich jetzt
mit ihren Vermögen durchgesetzt für eine Wertsteigerung, die ihnen aber von
der eigenen Bevölkerung zerschossen wird. Weil die natürlich sagen,
wir steigen jetzt erstmal eine Woche.
Damit geht eine von 50 Arbeitswochen erstmal mit Produktivität Null ein in die
Rechnung und das ist wirklich bescheuert.
Die Chance, die Kraft von Europa ist unser einziger Markt. Und es geht darum,
diesen einzigen Markt besser zu integrieren. In der Digitalisierung,
in der Industrie und so weiter.
Erstaunlich geht hier ganz ähnlich wie China und Indien vor,
den Binnenmarkt zu stärken, dass er meint, das könnte nochmal so eine neue Kraft
geben, was sicherlich richtig ist, also zumindest für einige Felder.
Die zweite Säule ist dann.
Was die Alpha und Omega unserer ökonomischen Politik war. Having industrial policy was forbidden.
Weil es eine Intervention auf dem Markt war, um etwas zu entscheiden,
um zu interfieren, um Bias zu erzeugen und so weiter. Aber wir brauchen es.
Ja, das ist das, was wir beobachten. Die Industriepolitik kehrt zurück.
Das ist aber auch so irre. Du hast jetzt 20 Jahre diese Geschichte,
sagen wir mal so Google gründet sich, 98,
25 Jahre diese Geschichte, inklusive allen Narrativen, Erzählungen,
Filmen und so weiter, wie diese
Finanzierung funktioniert. Venture Capital und so weiter und so fort.
Und trotzdem hast du nicht eine Bemühung, nicht ein Erfolgsrezept in Europa,
das nachzumachen und jetzt hast du diese nächste Intelligenz,
also künstliche Intelligenzwelle da in Amerika plus diese Subventionierung des
erneuerbaren Energiesektors und Europa steht wieder daneben und sagt, ne Schuldenbremse.
Lindner zerschießt das wieder alles. Und es ist wirklich verrückt,
dass man 2023 auf der Bühne steht, wir bräuchten jetzt mal eine Industriepolitik,
die so ein bisschen klüger abläuft, auf Augenhöhe.
Ja, gute Frage. Warum?
Weil unsere Kompetenten in der heutigen Zeit in der Marktwirtschaft verunreinigt sind.
Und weil wir uns in einer Situation befinden,
in der wir uns zu viel abhängig machen müssen, weil der Markt- und die öffentliche
Intervention in Europa unbalanziert ist.
Wenn man keine industrielle Politik hat, kann man seine Autonomie nicht progressiv
kreieren, oder zumindest die Energie zu riskieren. Das ist unmöglich.
Man kann seine eigene Industrie nicht kreieren oder stärken,
weil die anderen Mächte darauf hinterführen und sie eine industrielle Politik haben.
Damit einher geht die dritte Säule, nicht Protektionismus, aber Der dritte Pillar
dieser Strategie ist die Protektion, die Protektion unserer Interessen.
Basierend auf Sicherheits- und öffentlichen Ordnerkriterien,
hat die EU zum ersten Mal ein Werkzeug entwickelt, das uns ermöglicht,
zu blockieren, zu verhindern, Haltungen oder freie Bekaufungen in Strategiefirmen.
Also er ist nicht jemand, der jetzt den totalen Ausverkauf machen will,
das war ja zum Teil jetzt so rezipiert wurden, der verkauft uns noch Anti-Chinesen und sonst etwas.
Nein, er ist nämlich jemand, der auch mal kritisch aufarbeitet,
wie war denn das eigentlich mit der Euro-Krise?
Und er sagt nun folgendes.
Wir haben genau das Gegenteil gemacht, übrigens, nach der Finanzkrise,
als wir einige Mitgliedstaaten in Zahlen aufheben mussten, um kritische Assette
zu verkaufen. Zum Beispiel für chinesische Interessen.
Ich meine Energiefirmen, Sport und so weiter. Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2017.
Die griechischen Häfen.
Also Griechenland gilt ja bei uns immer noch als das arme Land und so weiter,
aber die Häfen in Griechenland und die Flotten und Rädereien,
die es da gibt, sind ja die größten der Welt.
Also die haben ja noch Öl, also selbst in der Hochzeit vor einem Jahr,
es hieß jetzt darf kein chinesisches Öl mehr und so, es gab eine explizite Ausnahmeregelung.
Griechische Räder dürfen natürlich
am Ölmarkt teilnehmen, auch wenn sie russisches Öl transportieren.
So wichtig war uns das. Zehn Jahre vorher, den Griechen lassen wir gar nichts
durchgehen. Die müssen jetzt alle Häfen verkaufen, alle Flughäfen.
Die Hälfte der Flughäfen gehört hier dem Frankfurter Flughafen,
wo man sich denkt, was hat das für einen Sinn?
Also das ist total bescheuert. Und die ganzen Häfen gehören China.
Also super erfolgreiches Refinanzierungsprojekt. Die Griechen haben damit Geld
generiert, das sie dann an wen gezahlt haben? An die 5000 Menschen,
die man die Märkte nennt?
Wahrscheinlich.
Es ist wirklich so grotesk.
Das wäre doch jetzt eigentlich die Pointe der Weltgeschichte.
Jetzt haben ja Zelensky und Xi miteinander telefoniert, sehr lange,
sehr ausführlich. Und jetzt gibt es ja so eine China-Delegation,
die nach Kiew fährt, also in die Ukraine, um dort Friedensverhandlungen auf den Weg zu bringen.
Aber zugleich haben wir ja diese Meldung, dass die Ukraine dringend Geld braucht
und und jetzt auch Staatsunternehmen verkaufen oder verscherbeln will.
Und da bin ich ja mal gespannt, ob wir da auch noch vielleicht das eine oder
andere erleben, dass jetzt das China sagt, oh, da könnten wir doch auch mal mitmachen.
Also wenn China mit der Ukraine so umgeht wie mit der deutschen Automobilindustrie,
ist das demnächst China dort.
Die vierte Säule.
Der vierte Pillar unserer Doktrinen ist Reziprozität.
Es hat fast zehn Jahre gedauert, bis die EU das internationale Prokurentinstrument
ergriffen hat, nur um Reziprozität in öffentlichen Prokurenten zu versichern.
Warum? Denn die europäische Angelegenheit ist immer eine Art komplexe Integration,
eine Addition nationaler Interessen.
Und manchmal treffen die offensiven Punkte einander nicht mit den defensiven
Punkten anderer Länder.
Und das Ergebnis ist, dass wir den Markt für den Job brauchen.
Wir brauchen Reziprocität.
Die EU ist eine Fehlkonstruktion,
wenn sie auf dieser Binnenwettbewerbsfähigkeit beharrt und solange sich das
nicht entscheidend ändert, kann man da ein schönes Wort für finden,
aber da wird sich nicht etwas so gestalten lassen, dass man,
eine sinnvolle Politik zusammen macht.
Reziprozität im Sinne von so ein Ausgleich finden, dass man Abhängigkeiten beiderseits
organisiert und nicht einfach, wir wollen eure Kunden haben in China und dafür
verkaufen wir euch gerne unser ganzes Research und Development.
Also zwar so nicht sehr reziprok, aber Reziprozität scheint mir ein sehr viel
wichtigerer und angesagter Begriff zu sein, als dieses derisking von Annalena Baerbock.
Das ungefähr der auf fail augenhöhe mit ihrer feministischen außenpolitik ist.
Muss man echt sagen, also die hat wirklich keinen guten track record.
Ich glaube auch, dass die reziprozität auf der internationalen ebene viel besser funktioniert.
Ich hatte das jetzt eben bezogen auf die eu-ebene, dass wir da immer dieses
große problem haben und klar diese kritik richtet sich jetzt von macron nach deutschland,
obwohl er deutschland in dieser ganzen rede, wenn ich mich recht erinnere,
nicht ein einziges mal erwähnt, Aber es ist eigentlich eine Rede gegen Deutschland,
gegen diese Art des Nicht-Wechselseitigen, sondern wir würden gern mal diktieren, wie es läuft.
Und ich glaube aber, das ist auf der internationalen Ebene, ich glaube,
da bei der EU gibt es ein Fake-Konstrukt, was das immer auch schwierig macht.
Aber auf der internationalen Ebene kann man natürlich anders agieren.
Und da würde ich auch sagen, ist dieser Begriff der Reziprozität sehr,
sehr sinnvoll. Und ich habe ja das letzte Mal gesagt, man darf dieses Wandel
durch Handel nicht einfach verabschieden.
Man muss es sicherlich sinnvoller gestalten, als man das vorher gemacht hat,
wo man einfach so, naja, wir nehmen das, uns egal, was sonst ist.
Aber dass man das auch wechselseitig organisieren kann, ist sinnvoll.
Und zur fünften Säule kommen wir dann auch sofort.
Und hier kommt er nochmal zu seinem Thema, das er eigentlich aus China dann mitgebracht hat.
Multilateralismus möchte er haben, das ist für ihn ganz entscheidend. Er zieht dann das Fazit.
Mit diesen fünf Pillaren – Wettbewerbsfähigkeit und Einzelmarkt,
Industriepolitik, Schutz, Reziprozität und Kooperation – können wir eine neue
ökonomische Doktrine aufbauen,
die uns ermöglichen wird, Jobs zu schaffen, unser soziales Modell zu finanzieren, mit Klimaschutz.
Und mehr sovereign zu sein und für uns selbst zu entscheiden.
Und ich denke, das ist kritisch.
Nun wird auch er noch einmal literarisch. Er kommt auf George Steiner zu sprechen.
Das ist ein Literaturwissenschaftler und Philosoph, der sehr wichtig ist.
Auch vieles wurde ins Deutsche übersetzt.
Interessanterweise habe ich aber nicht den Essay gefunden über Europa von George
Steiner. Der wurde nur in einem Auszug meinem Cicero abgedruckt.
Da ist aber auch das Entscheidende nachzulesen, was jetzt auch Macron hier zitiert,
aber als Ganzes ist ja nicht zu finden. George Steiner ist ein interessanter
Denker und der hat auch schon mal in diesem Institut gesprochen und darauf kommt
er jetzt hier zu sprechen.
Ich erwähne sehr oft diesen Moment von Steiner, und ich glaube vollständig an den Geist von Café,
wie Steiner es sagte, der auf unserem großen Kontinent aufwächst,
von Lisbon nach Odessa, weil Cafés sind geschlossen,
wo Menschen gebombt werden, und Cafés sind die Plätze, wo man Kontroversen,
Diskussionen haben kann, you can share these agreements, that at the very end, you dream.
Our Europe is made of dreams. But actual dreamers are very pragmatic.
Otherwise they finish with the dreams of the others.
Wir sollen nicht die Träume der anderen träumen. Die Cafés, die Kaffeehäuser,
das ist das, was die europäische Identität ausmacht, sagt George Steiner.
Und hier entpuppt sich doch Macron wieder als Habermasianer.
Ja, ich wollte es gerade sagen. Denn Habermas ist ja der, der sagt,
in dem Salon, in dem Gespräch, dann im Kaffeehaus, wo er auch immer da ist,
das resonierende Publikum, da beginnt deliberative Demokratie.
Der Stammtisch.
Der Stammtisch ist dann das, wovon man sich eher fürchtet, aber wohl auch das.
Das deliberative Gequatsche ohne Ende, bis man dem Konsens ohne Macht endlich
herbeigeführt hat, den Herrschaftsfeindiskurs.
Aber zumindest hat man ein resonierendes Publikum, das nicht ein stumpf konsumierendes
ist und dann am Ende nichts mehr voneinander unterscheiden kann und irgendwann
auch das glaubt, was die Republikaner sagen.
Das gesprochene Wort, was ja da so im Zentrum steht, ist vielleicht nicht ganz verkehrt.
Ich finde es auch immer wieder gut. Wir haben ja nicht nur einen französischen
Präsidenten, der überhaupt mal irgendwas sagt im Vergleich zu einem deutschen
Kanzler oder einer Kanzlerin, sondern der sich dann auch noch eine Sprache nimmt,
die wir einfach mal verstehen.
Es wäre ja cool, wenn auch unser deutscher Kanzler mal eine Rede halten würde,
die vielleicht die Welt versteht.
Also für uns eine wäre auch mal schön, also eine Weihnachtsansprache.
Möchtest du mal eine Rede vom Kanzler haben?
Ja, zumindest mal so eine Grundlage irgendwie. Abseits eines Parteitags.
Aber die große Redner in der deutschen Politik in den letzten Jahrzehnten.
Das Kriterium ist doch hier so ein französisches Englisch, wo man sehr genau
hinhören muss, um zu verstehen, was er sagt.
Achso, du meinst nur die Performance, das heißt den Inhalt.
Es reicht völlig, dass ein Text zur Verfügung steht, von dem bekannt ist,
dass ihn der Olaf Scholz ausgesprochen hat und dann hat man eine Diskussionsgrundlage.
Sie muss nicht besonders gut performen. Ich erwarte weder ein Lindner,
rhetorisches Talent, noch ein Merz, rhetorisches Talent, noch ein Obama.
Aber Inhalte wären auch mal nicht schlecht.
Willst du uns den letzten Clip da noch spielen? Da liegt noch einer.
Leben und Träumen, das ist doch...
Europäische Sovereignheit ist nicht nur ein Konzept oder eine Fantasie,
sondern es ist in einem gefährlichen Weltraum eine Nötigkeit,
um für uns selbst als Europäer zu leben. Danke.
Und nun konfrontiert uns Stefan
mit einem Albtraum, Traum, denn es geht um die Situation der Kinder.
Es ist ganz schlimm.
Ich nutze die Gelegenheit, um gleich mal hier anzumerken, denn auf Twitter bekomme
ich ja dann immer viele gute Hinweise, wenn ich so was mache.
Dass jetzt meine Materialsammlung zum Thema Familie beginnt,
um dann nächstes Jahr darüber zu schreiben.
Unter anderem mit diesem Anliegen der Fragestellung nachzugehen.
Wir haben die deutsche Geschichte, also wir haben jetzt ungefähr 100.000 Jahre
politische Geschichte.
Arbeitslosigkeit ist ein echtes Problem. Wenn ein Unternehmen auch nur andeutet,
eventuell mit Arbeitslosigkeit zu drohen, steht das ganze politische Berlin
Spalier, bittet um Hinweise, wohin man das Geld überweisen soll,
Hauptsache keine Arbeitslosigkeit.
Also die deutsche Regierung, die hat sich ja einmal der Deutschland AG komplett ausgeliefert.
Wir erinnern uns alle an Helmut Kohl und Gerhard Schröder und 5 Millionen Arbeitslose
und rote Laterne und so weiter.
Wenn ein Unternehmen mit Arbeitslosigkeit droht, finito, dann steht Deutschland
stramm und dann wird Arbeitslosigkeit vermieden, um was es auch immer dabei
geht. Jetzt haben wir das Problem umgedreht.
Demografie, wir haben ja gar keine Arbeitslosen mehr. Uns fehlen ja Arbeitskräfte.
Und niemand kümmert sich darum, dieses Problem zu lösen. Also die Arbeitslosigkeit
war immer das zentrale Problem.
Arbeitskräftemangel ist irgendwie gerade so gar kein. wird viel bejammert und so weiter,
aber man sieht jetzt nicht irgendwie die große politische Anstrengung zum Beispiel
für Nachwuchs im Erwerbspersonenpotenzial zu sorgen oder für die wenigen erwarteten Nachwuchskräfte,
Klammer auf, Kinder und Jugendliche, Klammer zu, sich so um die zu kümmern,
dass man sie bestmöglich ausbildet und für den Arbeitsmarkt bereit hält,
sondern es ist irgendwie so ein Gestocher im Nebel und nichts funktioniert. Und jetzt haben wir ja.
Also Schulabbrecher und all diese traurigen Meldungen, die sich da anhäufen.
Das geht drunter und drüber. Also wir haben 10 Prozent Schulabbrecher und dann
haben wir 30 Prozent Studenten,
die psychisch angeschlagen sind und Leute, die mit 35 immer noch befristet arbeiten
und niemand wird so richtig, also das Rauskitzeln von Produktivität können wir
Deutschen noch nicht besonders gut.
Anreizsysteme gibt es da nicht. Und wenn wir ein was besteuern,
dann die Arbeit, sodass auch bloß niemanden von der eigenen Teilhabe,
also wie soll man sagen, Beibringung von Produktivitätskraft auch nur irgendetwas
bleibt, das vielleicht ein bisschen nach Spaß aussieht.
Man geht gerne arbeiten oder so. Findet alles nicht statt.
Während Corona haben wir ja in Deutschland ein bisschen strenger Schulschließungen
durchgeführt, auch mehrfach.
Und der amerikanische Präsident Joe Biden stand ja schon auf der Bühne,
ich habe es ja auch in der alten Republik zitiert, und meinte,
im Wettstreit mit den Systemkonkurrenten Chinas stärken wir jetzt die Familienpolitik.
Plötzlich gab es Elterngeld in Amerika, unerhört, plötzlich gab es Rentenzahlungen,
auch für diejenigen, die vielleicht gar nicht so viel beigesteuert haben vorher,
und man hat eine Pflegeversicherung und lauter solche Sachen.
Und in Deutschland gab es jetzt einen Abschlussbericht der interministeriellen
Arbeitsgruppe über die gesundheitlichen Auswirkungen der Corona-Pandemie auf
Kinder und Jugendlichen.
Ich würde den Satz umbauen und sagen Abschlussbericht des interministeriellen
Arbeitsgruppe über die gesundheitlichen Auswirkungen der Corona-Pandemie auf
unser kommendes Erwerbsversumtspotenzial.
Und dazu gab es eine Aussprache im Bundestag, angeführt von unserer Familienministerin Lisa Paus.
Und ich will gleich dazusagen, es ist ein ganz großes Drama.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie das mit den Redezeiten läuft, aber bei so wichtigen
Themen wie angedeutet, kann man
ja durchaus erwarten, dass es eine Regierungserklärung gibt oder so was.
Also, wenn man schon Lisa Paus da mal da hat. Aber nein, diese Rede ging nur
5 Minuten und 4 Sekunden.
Wir hören uns 8 Clips an. Also, ich habe alle inhaltlich relevanten Sachen für uns rausgeholt.
Und wenn man keine Spuren von Inhalten findet, ist das ein Problem,
das nicht an meiner Clips-Arbeit liegt, sondern vielleicht an der politischen
Arbeit, die dem zugrunde liegt. Wir beginnen mal, inhaltlich geht sie,
versucht sie all in zu gehen.
Mehr als 70 Prozent der Kinder und Jugendlichen fühlen sich im Jahr 3 nach Ausbruch
der Pandemie noch immer psychisch gestresst.
Und weitere Krisen wie der Ukraine-Krieg, die Folgen der Klimakrise belasten
junge Menschen natürlich zusätzlich und wie so oft trifft das sozial Benachteiligte am härtesten.
Zum Beispiel haben Kinder von Eltern mit geringer Bildung, die zusätzlich einen
Migrationshintergrund haben und in einer zu kleinen Wohnung leben,
ein viermal so hohes Risiko für psychische Auffälligkeiten.
Es darf aber nicht vom sozialen Status abhängen, wie gut junge Menschen durch
die Krise kommen oder welche Chancen sie haben.
Aber es hängt doch die ganze Zeit von diesem Status ab.
Ja, also ja, vor allem, es mangelt ja nicht an Problembewusstsein.
Sie sagt ja, viele sind angeschlagen. Nun gibt es viele, muss man jetzt allen
helfen. Nein, sie fügt sogar noch an, den sozial Benachteiligten mit relativ
niedrigem sozial- ökonomischen Status geht es besonders schlecht, vierfach häufiger.
Dann weiß man ja eigentlich, eins plus eins ist zwei. Also dann ist ja klar, wo man helfen kann.
Dann hier auch wieder, ist auch ein Problem für sich, finde ich.
Ja gut, die reichen Familien haben es hingekriegt für uns.
Da müssen wir als Staat nicht tätig werden. Ich würde sagen,
erstmal, man kann sich grundsätzlich mal um Kinder kümmern, egal wo.
Es gibt überall Probleme. Aber eigentlich hat sich ja hier so markiert,
ja, also die Kinder haben Probleme und manche, die wir ganz klar definieren
können, haben speziell Probleme. Also könnten wir da eigentlich helfen.
Jetzt folgt auf dieses Problembewusstsein das Lösungsbewusstsein.
Die interministerielle Arbeitsgruppe Kindergesundheit hat sich deshalb vor allem
mit den psychischen und sozialen Belastungen von benachteiligten Kindern und
Jugendlichen beschäftigt.
Sie hat die Situation gründlich analysiert und sie hat auf wissenschaftlicher
Grundlage Maßnahmen entwickelt, um die Belastungen aufzufangen.
Wir haben als Gesellschaft und als Politik hier eine klare Aufgabe,
die Nöte und Anliegen von Kindern und Jugendlichen ernst zu nehmen,
ihnen mehr Raum zu geben und diese in unserer Prioritätensetzung auch stärker zu berücksichtigen.
Also es gab eine interministerielle Arbeitsgruppe, die jetzt ihrerseits die
Probleme ganz deutlich herausgearbeitet hat und so weiter, was dazu führte,
dass es jetzt eine Absichtserklärung gibt, man wolle ja jetzt auch helfen.
Mehr kann sie nicht verkünden. verkünden. Es ist eine Absichtserklärung.
Wir haben eine Absichtserklärung der Arbeit aus dieser Gruppe,
die das jetzt und so weiter. Also da ist einfach, es findet kein Inhalt statt
in diesem ganzen Kram. Jetzt haben wir gehört, hier setzt der Applaus ein für
die Absichtserklärung und nach dem Applaus ging es so weiter.
Die jungen Menschen im Land, sie haben Solidarität mit den Alten gezeigt.
Unsere Aufgabe ist es, ihre Unterstützung stärker in den Mittelpunkt unseres Handels zu stellen.
Wir im Bundesfamilienministerium setzen diese Empfehlung mit folgenden Maßnahmen um.
So, wir setzen folgende, also das ist der allererste inhaltliche Einschlag.
Wir versuchen jetzt zu verstehen, worüber redet sie eigentlich?
Wir haben die frühen Hilfen in diesem Jahr um 10 Prozent aufgestockt.
Welche frühen Hilfen? Hat sie einfach gar nicht genannt. Weiß ich auch nicht.
Also irgendwelche frühen Hilfen.
Ich wundere mich jetzt auch gerade, wir sind jetzt im April 23.
Wir haben doch schon vor etwa einem Jahr Studien von Krankenkassen im Salon
oder sonst wo vorgestellt, wo das schon alles benannt wurde,
wie schlecht es Kindern während dieser Pandemie geht.
Brauchst du nicht nochmal einen neuen Arbeitskreis? Oder da kann der Arbeitskreis
nochmal ganz schnell drauf gucken. Ach ja, hier sind diese drei Studien.
Sieht wohl ziemlich schlimm aus. Da muss ich mich ja nicht mehr groß beraten
über die Situation, sondern nur noch, wie kommen wir da raus?
Also wer weiß, wir haben die frühen Hilfen. Zitat.
Muss man nochmal nachgucken im Bundestag, was die frühen Händler jetzt tun.
Aber das ist jetzt das Neue, mal lässt du mir was sagen, hattest du das gesehen bei Aspekte,
war Herbert Krönemeyer, der sich doch jetzt überlegt,
Ungleichheit ist auch so ein Problem in Deutschland und dann wurde er da vorgestellt,
wie er jetzt da so eine große Initiative stand, da denkt man auch gut, was passiert jetzt?
Also er will sich jetzt mit anderen einflussreichen Leuten treffen,
also mit anderen Worten, er trifft andere reiche Menschen und sie wollen jetzt
die nächsten Jahre über darüber sprechen,
was eigentlich los ist mit der Ungleichheit und wo liegt das Problem,
wie kommen wir daraus, das soll also ein Projekt angelegt sein über viele, viele Jahre.
Und ich denke mir, Herbert, ruf doch einfach mal Marcel Fratsche an,
hilf mir mit dem 10 Minuten, dann weißt du doch alles.
Ja, ich springe nach vorne mit einem kleinen Auszug aus Stuttgart,
Barres Interview beim Spiegel.
Die Translationsleistung können wir alle selber erbringen, wenn ich das vorlese.
Mich erinnert das immer an Hannes Jennecke, der uns ja das Rätsel aufgibt,
ob nun er die Meeresschildkröten rettet Oder ob nicht doch die Meeresschildkröten
Hannes Jennecke retten.
Zum Thema der Kunst, der Künstler und die Realität. Und die große Show,
die da drum stattfindet.
Und das heißt jetzt Matthias Döpfner rettet eigentlich Stuttgart-Bara?
Ja, es ist ein Geben und Nehmen. Hauptsache die Probleme sind einmal benannt.
So, Lisa Paus lässt uns also im Unklaren die frühen Hilfen und 10% mehr.
Also man macht eine relative Angabe, man weiß gar nicht, was sind jetzt 10%?
Das ist viel, das ist wenig. Worum geht es überhaupt?
Im Folgenden nennt sie mal Zahlen, die wir dann mal runterbrechen.
Wir investieren rund vier Milliarden Euro in den nächsten zwei Jahren in die Kita-Qualität.
Und wir nehmen viel Geld in die Hand zum Ausbau der Ganztagsbetreuung von Grundschulkindern.
So vier Milliarden für die Kita Qualität deutschlandweit und Zitat viel Geld
für die Ganztagsbetreuung in den Schulen.
Vier Milliarden, wie viele Kitas haben da?
Vier Milliarden. Ich habe extra nochmal nachgeschaut in Frankfurt gibt es so 700 Kitas.
Das ist schon viel.
Und jetzt muss man überlegen als Maik Josef hier antrat als Oberbürgermeister
hat er plakatiert eine Milliarde für die Schulen und er meinte nur Frankfurt.
Und da fand ich auch, das ist okay. Also für die Frankfurter Schulen,
es gibt ja über 100 Grundschulen und ausreichend Gymnasien und so weiter,
da kann man ruhig mal eine Milliarde fordern.
Vier Milliarden für alle deutschen Kitas, also deutschlandweit sind es 60.000
Kitas, das heißt man hat 66.000 pro Kita, also eine Stelle.
Jetzt haben wir ja diesen E-Mail-Verkehr, bitte holen Sie Ihr Kind früher ab,
wir haben Personalnot und so, freitags machen wir zu und der ganze Kram.
Also mit vier Milliarden für Kita-Qualität, was ja nur bedeutet,
keine Ahnung, da sind wieder tausend Programme, die erstmal auf Qualität getrimmt
werden müssen, bevor man sagt, na gut, stellt einfach jemanden ein.
Ja, müssen wir erstmal einen Beraterstab noch engagieren.
Geht erstmal, die Hälfte verloren. Also man wird so 50, 40.000 Euro pro Kita
pro Jahr haben, das ist gar nichts. Also das ist ein bisschen Papier zum Malen
oder so, kann man in Windeln kaufen, aber das ist wirklich nicht der Rede wert.
Nächstes Projekt, das sie uns vorstellt.
Ab dem Sommer starten die Mental Health Coaches an den Schulen.
Und damit werden mehrere 10.000 SchülerInnen mit Prävention und Hilfe in psychischen
Krisensituationen erreicht werden.
Mehrere 10.000 Schüler von 10 Millionen heißt so ungefähr jeder 200 bis 300
oder 400 oder vielleicht auch nur jeder Tausendste wird erreicht von so einem Programm.
Mit dem Mental Health Coach. Und was machen die? Also wer sind die?
Naja, das sind dann immerhin Menschen, die einfach mal so als Ansprechpartner
schon mal so Jugendhilfe ausbauen oder wie auch immer.
Aber jeder Tausendste, das ist dann fast noch einfacher sich dann doch auf den
klassischen Therapieplatz zu bewerben, oder? Statt einen Mental Health Coach zu bekommen.
Das stört, das ist so auf Augenhöhe mit der Quote. Wir sitzen hier ja bekanntlich
neben einer Schule, in der ungefähr 1000 Schüler sind, 1400.
Das heißt, die haben jetzt einen Ansprechpartner für alle 1.400 und das bewegt
das ganze Stadtteil hier, wenn hier morgens die Schüler kommen und so.
Wenn du sagst, da läuft jetzt noch einer mehr mit, der morgens zur Arbeit fährt
und dann als Ansprechpartner.
Also es ist wirklich verschwindend gering. Es ist unglaublich eigentlich.
Außerdem stärken wir die Nummer gegen Kummer.
116111 und bringen sie stärker an die Schulen mit der sogenannten Schulboxaktion.
Und wir haben mit dem Jugendstärkungsgesetz neue Rechte und Angebote in der
Jugend- und Familienhilfe geschaffen.
Kinder und Jugendliche können sich nun beim Jugendamt direkt beraten lassen,
ohne dass ihre Eltern darüber informiert werden.
Das ist ein Skandal für sich, dass das nicht längst gang und gäbe ist.
Ich habe diese Studien sowohl im Buch als auch im Salon, haben wir es schon gelesen.
Die Schule in Deutschland ist kein Safe Space.
Da ist nur noch die Türkei auf
Augenhöhe mit Deutschland. Überall anders funktioniert das, ganz anders.
Dass ein deutscher Schüler in einer Schule ein Problem haben kann,
ohne es ansprechen zu können bei einem Lehrer, weil es an die Schule und an
die Eltern weitergeleitet wird,
ist einfach kein Zustand, den man aushält. Das ist diese Ronald-Dragon-Ideologie.
Für die Kinder sind die Eltern zuständig. Das ist deren Pflicht,
sich darum zu kümmern. Das ist genetisch programmiert. Wir als Politik dürfen
uns da gar nicht einmischen.
Nein, genau das Gegenteil ist richtig. Manchmal muss man auch als Politik Kindern
ein Angebot machen gegen ihre eigenen Eltern.
Nur, dass Kinder wohl im Mittelpunkt gerückt. Also das ist wirklich skandalös,
dass man das jetzt so langsam mal organisiert, für Kinder überhaupt mal Safe
Spaces einzurichten, in denen sie auch mal unabhängig von ihren Eltern irgendwie
tätig werden können. Na ja.
Und außerdem habe ich Ende vergangenen Jahres das Bündnis für die junge Generation ins Leben gerufen.
Es lädt zusätzlich junge Menschen ein, unsere Gesellschaft mitzugestalten. Ein breites Bündnis.
Also das ist ein Bürgerrat.
Ja, das Bündnis für junge Generationen lädt niemanden ein, sondern das besteht
erst mal nur aus einer gemeinsamen Erklärung.
Es gibt einfach eine gemeinsame Erklärung zu irgendwas. Da wurde noch nie ein
Kind angesprochen oder sonst irgendwie. Das ist einfach nicht existent,
worüber sie hier spricht. Naja, Finale.
Werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen, wir reden in der Politik oft über Dinge,
die nicht gut funktionieren.
Die Interministerielle Arbeitsgruppe Kindergesundheit, sie ist ein gutes Gegenbeispiel.
Sie zeigt, wir können als Bund,
Länder, Wissenschaft und Zivilgesellschaft konstruktiv zusammenarbeiten.
Und solche Prozesse brauchen wir, um für künftige Krisen besser gerüstet zu sein.
Die Interministerielle Arbeitsgruppe, sie hat einen guten Weg aufgezeigt,
wie wir uns für die Zukunft besser aufstellen können, und zwar mit der Einrichtung
eines Expertinnengremiums, das interdisziplinär arbeitet und Bund und Länder zugleich berät.
Ich werbe dafür, dass diese Zusammenarbeit zum Wohle der Kinder auch fortgesetzt wird.
Herzlichen Dank. Das ist jetzt im Kopf nicht auszuhalten. Das heißt,
man hat jetzt ein paar Tropfen auf sehr, sehr heiße Steine präsentiert als großen
Erfolg und macht weiter in der Arbeitsgruppenbildung.
Die interministerielle Arbeitsgruppe hat jetzt eine interministerielle Arbeitsgruppe
im Anklang. Also gründet jetzt eine gerade.
Die interdisziplinär arbeiten wird.
Ja, so dass alle mitziehen können und jeder noch mal. Also es ist wirklich ganz, ganz schlimm.
Das ist aber auch schon Chachipiti, oder?
Ja, also wir brauchen hierfür kein Familienministerium.
Das ist einfach ein guter Prompt an Chachipiti. Gib mir eine Rede,
die man ungefähr fünf Minuten reden kann. Sie muss folgenlos sein,
aber gut klingen und so. Dann kriegt man genau das.
Das ist wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz bescheuert. Und jetzt haben wir es ja so auf
die fünf Minuten, vier Sekunden,
die natürlich nochmal durch eine Minute Applaus, also vier Minuten Rede,
folgt natürlich einer Aussprache und jetzt regiert gerade die grüne Partei.
Das Familienministerium, das war natürlich vorher auch schon in Regierungshand
und die CDU ist ja auch nicht weit, die war ja auch erst kürzlich in Regierungsverantwortung.
Also die CDU war sogar während Corona in Regierungsverantwortung und Mareike
Lotte-Wulff von der CDU eröffnet als erste in der Aussprache auch wie folgt.
Die Folgen der Pandemie sind bei Kinder und Jugendlichen sehr spürbar.
Die allgemeine Gesundheit hat sich um 15 Prozent verschlechtert.
Symptome von Depressionen haben bei Jugendlichen stark zugenommen.
Und, das ist besonders hart, Kinder aus schwierigen sozialen Verhältnissen und
Kinder mit Behinderungen sind besonders hart betroffen.
Und alle diese Fakten zeigen einfach, wie schnelle und wirksame Maßnahmen nötig sind.
Schnelle und wirksame Maßnahmen, im April 2023, um die Corona-Probleme aufzuarbeiten.
Wir könnten auch jetzt noch vielleicht sagen, jetzt hilft uns nur noch ein kurzer, harter Lockdown.
Ja, das ist mehr als drei Jahre nach dem ersten Lockdown, Ankündigung,
also Verkündung, dass es ab morgen losgeht.
Also einige dieser Kinder sind jetzt auch schon groß inzwischen,
die davon betroffen sind. Das ist dann schon ein Problem.
In dieser Zeit kannst du locker von 17-jährig auf voll strafmündig über 21 rutschen.
Also das ist die Zeitspannung.
Es ist wirklich brutal.
Ja, wir haben da schon eine lost generation oder auch die, die eingeschult wurden,
die mit Corona eingeschult wurden oder gerade ein paar Monate in der Schule
waren und dann kam Corona.
Das ist ein riesengroßes Problem.
Ja, wir haben es hier wirklich nur mit Verlierern in der Politik und entsprechend
dann in der Bevölkerung zu tun.
Die Wulff, wir haben ja eben bei Lisa Paus nur das, die frühen Hilfen und so,
die jetzt aufgestockt wurden.
Hier wird das nochmal kurz unterfüttert. Es gab ja mal dieses zwei Milliarden
Paket, was ja auch schon nicht ausreichte, weil das irgendwie 100 Euro pro Schüler waren.
Die große Koalition hat mit dem Programm Aufholen nach Corona damals zwei Milliarden
Euro zur Förderung von Kindern und Jugendlichen bereitet.
Das betont sie nochmal. Das war zeitgleich mit den neun Milliarden für die Lufthansa und so.
Ja, zwei Milliarden und wir geben ja für die Bundeswehr nur noch mal so als Sonderausgabe 100.000.
Aus. 100.000.000.
100.000.000. 100 Milliarden. 100 Milliarden geben wir aus, genau.
Und zwei Milliarden für Kinder, Faktor 50, ja.
Das ist die neue Resilienz in Deutschland, an der wir arbeiten.
Ganz wie der Panzer in der Garage, aber keiner, der immer in der Lage ist,
irgendwie produktiv dann und willens beizusteuern.
Gut, also zwei Milliarden hat ja die ehrenwerte CDU damals in den Raum gestellt.
Eine Milliarde floss in die Länder zur Aufholung von Lernrückständen und eine
weitere Milliarde in die frühkindliche Bildung, in die Freizeitgestaltung,
in die Begleitung von Kindern und Jugendlichen und im Alltag.
Und das war auch notwendig.
Und fortgeführt wird dieses Programm durch ein Zukunftspaket oder vielleicht
sagen wir lieber Päckchen mit gerade mal 40 Millionen Euro.
Also damals hat man schon so gut wie nichts gegeben und jetzt ist es...
40 Millionen für 10 Millionen Schüler und Schülerinnen. Vier Euro pro Nase,
ein Mittagessen. Das ist das Aufholprogramm für Corona.
Man kann ja auch mal Eltern fragen, ob sie diese zwei Milliarden irgendwo gespürt
haben, ob irgendwas besser geworden ist und wie wird es jetzt erst bei den 40 Millionen sein?
Das ist unglaublich. Nun gut, es soll konstruktive Gespräche geben.
Wir von der Union rufen Ihnen zu, nutzen Sie Ihre Ressourcen,
Ihre Ministerien für die wirkliche Verbesserung der Situation von Kindern und
Jugendlichen in diesem Land. Einige Punkte sind in diesem Bericht genannt.
Sie müssen sie nur umsetzen.
Wir sind für konstruktive Gespräche jederzeit bereit. Vielen Dank.
Konstruktive Gespräche oder konstruktive Geldzahlung? Sie ergänzt sich auch
nur für die Gespräche bereit. Jetzt kommt Karl Lauterbach als dritter Redner.
Bundesminister in der interministeriellen Arbeit natürlich eingebunden,
weil er betrifft ja auch ihn und sein Haus.
Er redet ja immer sehr energisch, man muss aber da wirklich,
er ist ein toller Rhetoriker, aber man muss auf die Inhalte achten.
Wir achten jetzt ein bisschen auf die Wortwahl.
Man muss ganz klar sagen, von allen, die Opfer erbracht haben in der Pandemie,
haben die Kinder die meisten Opfer.
Hier würde ich gerne anregen, macht einen Zusammenschnitt wie Lauterbach nicht
gegen jemanden, sondern gegen sich selbst argumentiert mit Zuschnitten von vor drei Jahren.
Ja, oder von vor zwei Jahren und vor einem Jahr. Genau.
Unterricht fällt jetzt erstmal aus und so weiter.
Und das kann für die Kinder nur das Beste sein, bevor wir die siebte oder achte Welle bekommen.
Genau, dass man jetzt nochmal hier das mal kreuzschneidet.
Kinder haben Ältere und andere geschützt, haben unter den Maßnahmen gelitten.
Die Maßnahmen waren zum Teil zu streng. Die Schulschließungen hätte man in dieser
Länge nicht machen müssen.
Viele Kinder leiden auch heute noch. Sie leiden unter psychischen Störungen.
Ihre Gesundheit ist schlechter geworden. Wir schulden daher den Kindern eine
ernsthafte Debatte, die wir heute führen werden.
Wir machen auch wieder nur eine Debatte. und gucken sich dann noch mal an,
was der Onkel Lauterbach zu sagen hat.
Wir schulden Ihnen eine ernsthafte Debatte, die wir heute am 21.04.23 halten werden.
Danach geht es den Kindern gleich besser.
Danach ist das Thema abgehakt.
Lassen Sie mich zu den konkreten Punkten kommen. Ich sage vorweg,
das reicht nicht. Wir müssen weitergehen.
Ich sage vorweg, das reicht nicht. Wir müssen weitergehen. Jetzt sagt er so
ein paar Sachen, bei denen ich auch wieder denke, Hätte man das nicht,
also wieso musste man das überhaupt ändern?
Aber wir haben sofort die Kinderkliniken, die in einer Notlage waren,
aus dem System der Fallpauschalen so weit entfernt, dass man selbst bei 80 Prozent
der Leistung 100 Prozent des Budgets bekommt. 1.
Januar ist das gekommen. Die Not der Kinderkliniken haben wir beseitigt.
Also die Not der Kinderkliniken ist natürlich nicht beseitigt.
Und diese Fallpauschalen, ja, also, Man hat eine Kinderklinik, hat man am 27.
Des Monats einen Notfall, Budgets sind aufgebraucht, man kann das nicht mehr
abrechnen. Bisher haben die in der Klinik gesagt, ja, müssen wir ja trotzdem
behandeln. Können wir halt nur nicht in Rechnung stellen.
Sie haben also über ihre finanziellen Dinger hinausgearbeitet.
Dann stellte sich heraus, ach so, dadurch kriegen die ganz schön viel gar nicht finanziert.
Und plötzlich stand jedes zweite Bett leer, weil einfach gar keine Finanzmittel da waren.
Die Schieflage war so groß, dass man sich wieder fragt, ja, Aber wieso habt
ihr es überhaupt dazu kommen lassen?
Kann man das wirklich jetzt Corona in die Schuhe schieben oder so?
Das ist doch ein systemisches Problem der Unterfinanzierung.
Und dann lobt er sich hier selber dafür, dass er dieses Problem beseitigt hat,
wo ich es echt sagen muss, ja, aber du hast die Fallpauschale noch eingeführt.
Selbstgeschaffenes System.
Genau.
Da muss man doch eine Evaluierung mitlaufen lassen. Wenn die Kliniken melden, dass sie am 25.
Kein Geld mehr haben für die letzte Woche Arbeit und dann natürlich trotzdem
arbeiten, muss es doch eine Rückkopplung in die Politik geben,
dass man dann nicht erst auf Corona wartet, um dann plötzlich festzustellen,
achso, liegt ein Problem vor. haben wir jetzt beseitigt, da kommt er dann in den April 23.
Die Wunde schließt der Speer nur, der sie schlug. Und das ist ja auch wieder
so ganz typisch für Lauterbach.
Oder auch vielleicht sind wir jetzt in so einer Politik, wo man Simulations,
die Simulation von Debatten eigentlich nur noch vorfindet.
Das war doch schon im letzten Jahr etwa zu etwa fast gleichen Zeit mit der Impfpflicht,
dass man da noch mal eine große Debatte machte, als schon sich abzeichnete,
okay, jetzt mit Omikron und was auch Experten sagen Und auch die Wirkung des
Impfstoffes ist nicht so ganz so, wie man erhofft.
Jetzt ist das eigentlich zu spät. Jetzt braucht man gar nicht mehr.
Und dann haben die ja noch mal eine große Debatte im Bundestag.
Dann sind doch diese ganzen jungen Bundestagsmitglieder aufgelaufen da,
weil sie wahrscheinlich Lauterbach aus der Wochenschau kannten oder Heuteschau, wie das heißt.
Und dann haben sie alle noch mal ihr Großplädoyer gehalten und hat doch Lauterbach
sich auch danach für diese Debatte bedankt.
Und dass er die ganzen Anregungen mitnimmt.
Ja genau, das war ja auch eine Sternstunde des Parlaments wieder.
Genau, damals sehenden Auges, dass es dazu nicht kommt und jetzt ein Jahr später,
sang und klanglos, selbst die Empfehlung für unter 18-Jährige,
es gibt keine Empfehlung des Robert Koch Instituts mehr für weitere Corona-Impfungen,
hat man einfach gestrichen aus dem Papier, ist dann in dem Vergleich des Textes
der Monatsausgaben einfach aufgefallen.
Und jetzt simulieren wir die nächste Debatte.
Ja, es ist wirklich crazy und Lauterbach kommt ja auch nochmal auf die Kinderärzte zu sprechen.
Es sind viel zu wenige Ärztinnen und Ärzte, die sich für den Beruf der Kinderärztin
entscheiden oder des Kinderarztes.
Wir haben diesen Bereich komplett entbudgetiert. Das heißt, jemand,
der jetzt in diesen Bereich geht, der muss sich nicht mehr um Budgets kümmern.
Der kann die Leistung erbringen, kann sich darauf verlassen,
dass die Leistung komplett bezahlt wird. Das macht diesen Beruf im Vergleich
zu anderen Facharztberufen attraktiver.
Das haben wir gemacht. Das ist aber noch immer nicht alles. Wir werden darüber
hinaus die Versorgung mit Psychotherapeutinnen und Psychotherapeuten deutlich verbessern.
Wir werden hier mit Sonderbedarfen arbeiten. Es kann nicht erlaubt sein,
es kann nicht angehen, dass die Kinder und Ministerin Paus hat es eloquent vorgetragen,
die Kinder sind in psychischer Not.
Da kann es nicht sein, dass Kinder ein Jahr lang auf einen Therapieplatz warten,
weil wir nicht genug Therapeutinnen und Therapeuten haben. Daher werden wir
hier mit Sonderbedarfen, werden wir hier den Bedarf decken, daran wird intensiv gearbeitet.
Das ist natürlich alles schön gesagt, nur wenn du mit einem geborenen Kind irgendwo
hinziehst, sei froh, wenn du keine Psychotherapie brauchst.
Du findest auch keine Logopäden, du kannst dich beim kleinen Kinderarzt eintragen.
Du nimmst nur Neugeborene, weil sie es dann müssen. Aber wenn du irgendwo,
das ist alles überfüllt und voll.
Diese Freude darüber, dass das jetzt entbudgetiert ist. Da frage ich mich auch,
bei Kindermedizin, also Kinder brauchen ja auch einen Arzt. Nicht nur,
wenn sie krank sind, sondern du hast ja auch diese Vorsorgeuntersuchungen in
allen möglichen Altersklassen und so weiter.
Du hast also ein relativ überschaubares, festes Repertoire, was ein Kinderarzt machen muss.
Du hast in Deutschland total organisiert Einzugsgebiete für Grundschulen zum Beispiel.
Kinder werden alle durchgezählt, Grundschule und so weiter, alles organisiert.
Genauso kannst du auch Kinderärzte einfach hin installieren,
wo du halt diese Praxis Im Prinzip wie Beamte kann man die...
Genau, die sind dann einfach da, wo auch die Kinder sind, es ist alles geregelt,
es gibt da gar kein Wissensdefizit, wo diese Praxen sein müssten und so weiter und so fort.
Dass man da überhaupt mal auf die Idee kramt und sagen, nee,
das reicht uns nicht, das im Panorama zu organisieren.
Es muss jeder einzelne Handgriff des Kinderarztes aufgeschrieben,
notiert und am Ende in der Kostenrechnung geltend gemacht werden.
Ist total dumm. Also es ist wirklich strunzdumm. Und sich jetzt dafür zu freuen,
dass man das entbudgetiert hat, hat er nochmal ein schönes Wort untergebracht, was total toll klingt.
Es hatte überhaupt gar keinen Sinn vorher, das anders zu machen.
Es sitzt ja auch keiner im Bauamt oder so und rechnet dann abends ab,
was habe ich alles gemacht?
Ich habe drei Bauämter, Bauanträge entgegengenommen und so weiter.
Jetzt möchte ich gerne vom Ministerium so und so viel Geld. Sondern nein,
man kriegt natürlich sein Monatsgehalt dafür, dass man da erscheint und dann
geht die Tür auf, jemand kommt rein und man macht halt eine Amtshandlung.
Und bei den Ärzten wurde das so auf die Spitze getrieben, dass er sich jetzt
dafür feiert, dass er da diese völlig fehl am Platz Ökonomisierung wieder rausgenommen hat.
Also das ist kein Fortschritt, das ist sozusagen eigentlich Vernunftsstatus
quo, zumindest mal wieder ein bisschen Oberwasser.
Von hier an müsste man jetzt mal so langsam losgehen.
Genau, das ist eigentlich die Ausgangslage für. Und jetzt machen wir es mal
klug. Also es ist wirklich haarsträubend.
Die Ampelregierung steht eindeutig hinter der Kindergrundsicherung.
Wir stehen hinter der Kindergrundsicherung.
So, das ist mal so ein kleiner Punkt für die derzeit laufende Debatte,
Kindergrundsicherung.
Die Ampel steht eindeutig dahinter, also auch die FDP will er damit sagen.
Er macht jetzt das einzige kleine Argument bis hierhin Zum Thema,
ja, wir brauchen diese Kinder auch.
Es ist ja eine Win-Win-Situation, wenn wir die erstens uns gut um die kümmern,
die gut ausgebildet sind, die ein gutes Leben führen und wir noch Produktivität
entsprechend abschöpfen können.
Und ich sage es eben mit Absicht auch so ein bisschen nüchterner,
weil wir hier wirklich keinen negativen Effekt haben. Also gut ausgebildeten
Kindern, die Spaß in ihrer Kindheit hatten, geht es einfach besser später und
die werden wohl ertragreicher arbeiten.
Kindergrundsicherung ist notwendig. Natürlich ist es schön und gut zu sagen,
Geld ist nicht alles. Und soll ich Ihnen was sagen?
Frau Rolf, das stimmt doch, Sie haben damit recht, Geld ist nicht alles.
Nicht aus, aber wenn sie in der Kindheit Armut erleben...
Dann sind Ihre Chancen auf Gesundheit, auf eine gute Ausbildung,
auf einen guten Schulabschluss, die sind viel schlechter. Kein Kind kann für
die Armut seiner eigenen Eltern.
Kein Kind kann sich das aussuchen.
Daher brauchen wir unbedingt hier eine Gerechtigkeitsinitiative.
Und da stehen wir alle dahinter. Trotzdem, ich danke Ihnen dafür,
dass wir diese Debatte haben. Hier soll nichts verschwiegen werden.
Es soll über alles gesprochen werden.
Aber es ist ganz klar, wir schulden den Kindern viel. Und ich würde mich sehr
freuen, wenn die demokratischen Parteien hier im Haus eine konzertierte Aktion
für diese Kinder begleiten könnten. Vielen Dank.
Also während dieser Pause genau nichts vorgestellt hat, über das man jetzt auch
mal im Bundestag befinden könnte, fordert er hier eine konzertierte Aktion,
bei dem die Opposition auch nochmal mitstimmt.
Aber es liegt ja gar nicht auf dem Tisch.
Ja, da müsst ihr ja jetzt sagen, wir wollen die Kindergrundsicherung viel höher
haben. Und das machen wir jetzt gemeinsam mit CDU, Grüne und SPD und die FDP
hat das Nachsehen. Das wäre ja dann die Aktion, die zu machen wäre.
Zum Beispiel, dann kommt allerdings, dann kommt wieder Lindner mit seinen wechselnden
Mehrheiten und so weiter. Machen wir nicht.
Naja, es ist... Mal riskieren für die Kinder. Angeblich sind die Kinder ja allen so wichtig.
Ja, ich würde ja auch sagen, wenn er schon feststellt, dass die Kinder selber
was davon haben, nicht in Armut aufzuwachsen.
Dann ist doch klar, dass dann auch die deutsche Volkswirtschaft was davon hat.
Es ist ja traurig, dass man sich überhaupt auf diese Argumentationen einlassen
muss, dass es nicht für sich steht.
Das kommt dann noch dazu. Dass man gar nicht mehr ohne diese ökonomische Logik
das diskutieren kann, weil die Leute da, vor allem die FDP, so behämmert ist,
dass man dem ja mit der gesegneten Kerze nicht mehr beikommt.
Ich werde es trotzdem entsprechend deutlich immer machen, da mir auch diese
Meineinigkeit in der Argumentation, die Kinder, die Kinder, die Kinder.
So dass sie am Ende gar nichts tun. Die werden ja alle so tun,
als seien die eigentlich die großen Kinder.
Aber ich finde auch, es werden zu viele Bücher geschrieben, in denen zu viele
bekannte Argumente, nämlich das Kind, das Kind, das Kind.
Also ich werde kein weinerliches, auch noch ein Buch über die armen Kinder schreiben
und so, sondern mir geht es mal ausdrücklich um diese volkswirtschaftliche Kalkulation.
Du machst den Gary S. Becker von links.
Was?
Du machst Gary S. Becker von links, das ist ja der Neoliberale,
der alles mit so Kosten-Nutzen durchrechnet und du musst das dann jetzt volkswirtschaftlich machen.
Der macht das betriebswirtschaftlich und du machst jetzt die Kindervolkswirtschaft.
Also ich sehe da aber auch Win-Win-Win-Win-Win-Situationen, die man ausschütteln könnte.
Die sind die da, das ist klar.
Denn er hat es ja gesagt, so arme Kinder, mit denen kann man gar nichts anfangen später.
Gut, Katja Adler von der FDP. Wir hören uns nichts an aus ihrer Rede außer ihr Finale.
Diese Pandemie war sicherlich nicht die letzte, aber sie muss die letzte sein
mit solch massiven und teilweise unverhältnismäßigen, ja schädigenden Einschränkungen.
Ich bin nicht nur Politikerin, ich bin auch Lobbyistin für unsere Kinder und Jugendlichen.
Und es wäre gut, kann das der ein oder andere Politiker mehr bei seinen künftigen
Entscheidungen ähnlich sehen. Herzlichen Dank.
Sie spricht auf jeden Fall so, als würde sie im Kindergarten einen Vortrag halten.
Vor allem, sie ist Politikerin und fordert jetzt die anderen auch mal Lobbyistin.
Ja, wen wollen Sie denn lobbyieren?
Ja die eigene Partei müsste sie mal lobbyieren, die die Kindergrundsicherung blockiert.
Wir sind so inkompetent, wir müssen uns selber lobbyieren. Achso wir sind die Politiker, achso.
Also schmerzhaft, schmerzhaft, schmerzhaft.
Warum reden die in letzter Zeit so viele Politiker so infantil mit einem, das hasse ich.
Es nimmt auf jeden Fall zu.
Ich möchte gerne als Erwachsener wahrgenommen werden, sogar als Kind wollte
ich schon als Erwachsener wahrgenommen werden. Gut, das wird viele nicht verwundern,
aber jetzt bin ich doch volljährig seit einer gewissen Zeit und ich möchte als
Erwachsener angesprochen werden.
Wir sind ja alle juvenil. Wir gehen alle den juvenilen Rückschritt.
Wir werden älter und fühlen uns aber jünger. Das 70 ist das neue 30 und so.
Hast du den Trailer gesehen? Indiana Jones, Harrison Ford, schwingt die Peitsche.
Ich habe den Trailer gesehen und
ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was der Abschluss-Joke war. Der war schlecht.
Der war sehr schlecht, aber es sieht auch fast so aus, als wäre es ein Wahlwerbespot
für Joe Biden. Ja. Man will nochmal beweisen, okay, Harrison Ford kann auch durch noch drehen.
Also man hat ihn noch mal jünger gemacht, das hat man sich bei Joe Biden nicht
erlauben können und wenn der letzte Gag im Trailer schlecht ist,
ist auch der Film schlecht. Das ist eine sehr zuverlässige Heuristik bei mir.
So, Heidi Reichinek von der Linken.
Macht das einzig sinnvolle Argument, wir haben ja jetzt gehört,
es gibt 40 Millionen frühes Dingsdabbungsprogramm, plus 15 Millionen für diese
Mental Health Coaches. Macht 55 Millionen.
Sie erklärt uns mal, wie viel Geld das eigentlich ist.
Ja, und was liefert die Regierung? Sie haben das alle angesprochen,
ich finde es wirklich unfassbar, ein Zukunftspaket.
Das klingt total nett, ist aber nichts als eine Projektfinanzierung für ein
Jahr. Für 55 Millionen Euro werden wir diese Mental Health Coaches,
für die es immer noch kein Konzept gibt, mit dazu zählen.
Um das mal in Relation zu setzen, so viel kostet ein Kilometer der A281 bei
Bremen, die sie ausbauen.
Kinder, Autos, die Prioritäten sind in dieser Koalition ziemlich klar. Das ist unfassbar.
Das ist eine geniale Rechnung.
Ein Autobahnkilometer.
Also das ist doch wirklich... Es ist unglaublich.
Entsprechend ist Ihr Finale in der Rede auch kein Ich bin ein Lobbyist und du
möchtest, dass ihr das auch werdet, sondern...
Diese Regierung ist für Kinder und Familien ein Totalausfall. Schämen Sie sich.
Jetzt schämen Sie sich mal. Ja, sehr gut. Die nächste Rednerin ist die FDP.
Das ist auch wieder so typisch.
Es geht um Kinder. Schickt mal die Frauen.
Selten so viele Rednerinnen im Bundestag gesehen, der ja nun historisch gerade
nicht den Höhepunkt seines weiblichen Anteils da feiert. Also ganz schlimm. Nicole Westing.
Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, in jeder Krise steckt auch eine Chance.
Nutzen wir diese zur Schaffung einer resilienten Gesellschaft und fangen wir
dafür bei unseren Kindern und Jugendlichen an.
Vielen Dank. Das ist wirklich schön.
Sie gehört zu der Partei, die gerade die Kindergrundsicherung,
wenigstens das noch torpediert.
Aber möchte jetzt die Chance nutzen, eine resiliente Gesellschaft aufzubauen.
Sehr gut. Emilia Fester wünscht sich die Kinder wenigstens noch auf Augenhöhe
im Grundgesetz mit den 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr.
Deswegen ist die richtige Antwort auf die Frage, was die Schlussfolgerung aus
diesen Erkenntnissen des Monitorings sein kann, dass wir strukturell etwas ändern müssen.
Geld in die Hand nehmen müssen und erstens die Kindergrundsicherung armutsfest
auf den Weg bringen müssen und zweitens endlich Kinderrechte ins Grundgesetz
schreiben. schreiben. Es ist an der Zeit.
Jo, Kinderrechte ins Grundgesetz.
Sarah Lahrkamp von der SPD macht gegen Ende der Aussprache die einzigen,
wir müssen jetzt sehr genau hinhören, die einzigen adäquaten,
alten republikanischen Anmerkungen, die hier bitter nötig sind,
aber auch nur so fast aus Versehen.
Fakt ist, wir müssen aus der Vergangenheit Vergangenheit lernen.
Unsere Kinder und Jugendlichen können sich hier nicht selbst vertreten und für
ihre Rechte einstehen. Das müssen wir Erwachsene für sie tun.
Und all denjenigen, die mit sozialen Argumenten auch einfach nicht zu überzeugen
sind, möchte ich noch eines sagen.
Reden wir heute über Fachkräftemangel, müssen wir jetzt in unsere Kinder und
damit in die Gesellschaft von morgen investieren.
Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen, ich weiß, dass es in unserem Land im Moment
in ganz vielen Bereichen große Herausforderungen gibt.
Richtig ist auch, wir können jeden Cent nur einmal ausgeben.
Aber klar muss auch sein, wir dürfen nicht an unseren Kindern sparen.
Ja, gut.
Das ist aber auch wieder, das kann man nicht dann einfach mal so stehen lassen,
dass Kinder einen Wert an sich haben. Und okay, wenn wir das,
wenn uns das nicht reicht, dann nehmen wir noch das Fachkräfteargument.
Und dann wird aber noch mal wirklich diese Unsinn erzählt.
Man kann den Cent nicht zweimal ausgeben. Also noch einmal muss das dann abgerufen
werden, wo sie ja schon sagt, ach nein, wir bilden ja hier die Produktivität
von morgen aus. Das heißt, wir können dann wieder ganz viele Cents ausgeben,
wenn wir eine produktive Wirtschaft haben.
Aber nein, sie kann es nicht lassen, es ist ja also die Studienlage ist ja so,
dass man sagt, wenn man in der Grundschule ein Euro ausgibt,
kann man später sieben Euro ausgeben. Könnt ihr dann siebenmal ausgeben.
Man muss nur 15 Jahre warten.
Aber gut, Diskussion ist, wie sie ist.
Neza hat Baradari von der SPD. Jetzt wird es so richtig absurd.
Sie freut sich noch mal, dass ...
Diese interministrielle Arbeitsgruppe zu denselben Ergebnissen gekommen ist wie sie vorher auch.
Sie hatte irgendwie gedacht, Kinder, Corona, da kommt was anderes raus als großes Leid.
Als Berichterstatterin für Kinder- und Jugendgesundheit der SPD-Bundestagsfraktion
freut mich vor allem, dass der Bericht zeigt, dass wir im Bereich der Gesundheit
viele Problemfelder bereits adressiert haben.
Das ist eine schöne Bestätigung für mich persönlich und für die gute Arbeit der Ampelkoalition.
So, wenn jetzt also so eine Arbeitsgruppengründungskaskade losgeht,
kommt immer die Arbeitsgruppe davor und sagt, sie sind zu denselben Ergebnissen gekommen wie wir.
Das bestätigt ja uns in unserer Arbeit.
Dann war es ein halbes Jahr, dann kommt die neue gegründete Arbeitsgruppe und
sagt, wir haben eine neue Arbeitsgruppe gegründet, die kam zu denselben Ergebnissen
wie wir. Das bestätigt uns sehr, das ist ein sehr schönes Ergebnis für uns,
wir hatten damals schon recht.
Aber es kommt nie zu einer Handlung, sondern du könntest immer nur einmal.
Vielleicht sollten wir einfach anfangen, immer unseren eigenen Podcast nochmal
zu hören und dann so sagen, ach ja, toll, schön gesagt.
Wir sagen, wir verfangen uns in diesem infiniten Loop, so wie GPT dann,
wenn es nur noch die Auswertung der Vergangenheit gibt und dann trägt man das
immer weiter nach vorne.
Ja, also das ist einfach, naja, wir geben ihr das letzte Wort.
Sie hatte auch dort das letzte Wort. Sie ist zuversichtlich.
Die physische und psychische Gesundheit von Kindern ist in Deutschland und die
Pandemie hat diesen Trend verstärkt.
Leider eine soziale Frage.
Das können und werden wir so nicht akzeptieren. Wir brauchen tiefgreifende,
strukturelle Verbesserung, denn jedes mehr als fünfte Kind in Deutschland lebt in Armut.
Das können wir uns nicht leisten. Wir müssen als Gesetzgeber unserer Verantwortung
gerecht werden und diesen Zustand beenden.
Ich bin zuversichtlich, dass das Familienministerium und das Gesundheitsministerium
diesbezüglich uns gute Programme weiterhin liefern werden. Herzlichen Dank für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit.
Ich schließe die Aussprache.
Wofür wird denn diese Rede gehalten? Für wen?
Keine Ahnung. Ich hätte sie auch lieber zu Protokoll gegeben.
Oder?
GBT schreibt eine Rede und gibt sie zu Protokoll. Ja. Ja, also wir finden, es ist wirklich...
Ja, auch, wenn die reden ja miteinander sonst, wieso muss man nochmal eine Rede
halten, in der man die lobt? Also ich kann jetzt auch gleich noch mal,
wenn wir fertig sind mit dem Podcast, machst du nochmal eine Aufnahme,
da sag ich nochmal fünf Minuten, wie schön du das wieder gemacht hast mit dem Podcast.
Also die Redezeit wird nach Proports des letzten Wahlergebnisses verteilt.
Entsprechend geht dann vom Fraktionsvorsitzenden eine Mail rum.
Morgen der siebte Slot. Also hat noch jemand, will noch jemand.
Und dann denkt sich Dings, ich habe ja noch nie im Bundestag gesprochen,
ich könnte ja mal Premiere machen und dann keine Ahnung.
Da wäre doch vielleicht einfach schön, man bringt einfach einen schönen Text
mit zum Thema Familie, irgendwas, das muss ja gar nicht eine soziologische Studie
sein, vielleicht irgendwas Literarisches.
Ich verstehe sowieso nicht, wie man nicht im Bundestag gehen kann und dort jede
Gelegenheit zu reden nutzt für den ganz großen Auftritt.
Also so wie Christian Lindner, es gibt ja so eine ganz witzige Szene,
Christian Lindner kommt zu spät in eine Hard-Aber-Fair-Sendung. Und?
Er läuft also durch das Dunkel des Publikums und wird dann schon so begrüßt.
Ah, jetzt sind sie endlich da. Sie als Minister kriegen natürlich das erste
Wort. Also setzt er sich an den Tisch und ihm wird einfach nur so zugerufen.
Was hat sie beschäftigt jetzt auf der Fahrt hierher? Was haben sie gelesen im Auto?
China wächst mit sieben Prozent, Amerika wächst mit fünf Prozent.
Wir wachsen gar nicht. Und gleich so die ganze große Weltdimension und so.
Ja, auf dem Parteitag, da werden wir es vielleicht nachher noch hören.
Ich will mal, weil wir jetzt über die Kinder sprachen, ganz kurz über die Eltern
sprachen. Denn dieses Bauen mittlerweile ist ja wirklich grotesk und Geiwitz
war im Gespräch in den Tagesthemen am 20.
Wir haben zum einen, das sind jetzt, hier wurde über Kinder gesprochen im Bundestag.
Wie geht es eigentlich so diesen Eltern? Die haben ja auch eigene Wünsche,
Träume, man kommt so endlich an.
Kind ist da, Arbeit ist da, Ehevertrag ist unterschrieben, zack, zack, zack.
Jetzt geht es ans Haus bauen oder schlägt da irgendwie doch die Realität dazwischen?
Die Krise am Bau droht sich weiter zu verschärfen. Immer weniger Menschen trauen
sich noch, eine Wohnung zu kaufen oder ein Haus zu bauen, weil sie es sich nicht
mehr leisten können. Die neuesten Zahlen sind alarmierend.
Im Januar und Februar brachen die Genehmigungen für Wohnungen in Neubauten oder
Bestandsgebäuden nochmals um über 23 % ein.
Überdurchschnittlich der Rückgang bei Einfamilienhäusern, besonders drastisch
das nachlassende Interesse Bei zwei Familienhäusern.
So, du hast also die Situation, Zinswende und so, Baukosten haben sich die letzten
zehn Jahre verdoppelt, Grundstückskosten sind sowieso durch die Decke.
Und jetzt noch die Zinskosten.
Genau, Finanzierungskosten doppelt so hoch. Also Menschen fangen in der ohnehin
schon komischen Lage Corona an für ihren Hausbau zu planen.
Sitzen dann bei der Bank, das dauert dann mehrere Monate und am Anfang hieß
es noch, ja wir bauen da so ein Konzept zusammen, Finanzierung,
das würde dann 1200 Euro im Monat kosten. Dann kommst du ein Jahr später und
sagst, ja, hat sich leider verändert, kostet jetzt 2800 Euro.
Dann sagen die natürlich, ja gut, ciao.
Wir stehen auf und gehen, wir kommen auch nicht wieder. Also hier gibt es nichts
mehr zu verhandeln, weil da ist ja auch keine Verhandlungsbasis irgendwie.
Und die Baubranche hat jetzt, wissend, okay,
das geht jetzt noch ein Jahr gut, wir haben noch Aufträge, was passiert denn
danach eigentlich, wenn jetzt 50 Prozent Minus bei Zweifamilienhäusern,
also da wo privat finanziert wird, die Kommunen, die ganzen kommunalen Bau gibt es auch nicht mehr.
Die privaten, Vonovia und so, baut auch nichts mehr.
Also die Kommunen haben ja auch, wenn sie was machen wollen,
müssen ja auch Kredite aufnehmen, die haben auch Zinsen zu zahlen.
Ja, also die Kommunen als staatliche Hand, staatliche Akteur,
können sich die Finanzierungen nicht leisten.
Das führt natürlich zu der einen oder anderen Verwerfung, die dann zu dem Gastro-Effekt,
der jetzt befürchtet wird, führen kann.
Die Baugewerkschaft sorgt sich um die Arbeitsplätze am Bau, Wenn Aufträge fehlten,
würden Fachkräfte abwandern.
Ich mache mir größte Sorgen, dass ein sogenannter Gastro-Effekt eintritt,
wie damals in der Pandemie, in der Gastronomie, wenn die Leute einmal aufgrund
von anderen Möglichkeiten in andere Branchen wechseln, ist es äußerst schwierig sie zurückzuholen.
Ja, man hat jetzt noch ein Jahr Bauüberhang und danach weiß man,
es kommen erst mal keine neuen Bauprojekte.
Und jetzt geht es ganz konkret um die Frage, wer baut? Und damit ist gemeint,
wer setzt die Tür an? Wer stellt die Ziegel aufeinander? Wer ist auf der Baustelle?
Weil wenn die einmal da weg sind, und da hat man sich ja schon sehr aus dem
Immigrationsbereich bedient, also auf Baustellen arbeiten ja zu 80,
90 Prozent nicht Deutsche, Die entscheiden dann, also die machen wirklich grundlegend
neue biografische Entscheidungen, inklusive ich will gar nicht in Deutschland leben und so.
Und die sind dann einfach weg. Und dann hat man diesen Gastro-Effekt,
wie er das hier nennt, dass einfach eine ganze Branche sozusagen für ein Jahr
stillgelegt wird, in dem Fall leider, weil es keine Aufträge gibt.
Danach will man es wieder hochfahren und es ist niemand mehr da.
Und da kann dann hier in Frankfurt noch so sehr Projekte geplant werden und so.
Und so. Es wird einfach niemanden geben, der das baut. Also das ist dann so
auch eine der ersten Effekte, wo das Geld einfach nicht mehr ausschlaggebend ist.
Kannst du noch so viel Geld bieten, es ist einfach keiner, der den Auftrag übernimmt.
Und jetzt haben wir unsere dafür zuständige Bauministerin, die einfach sagen
könnte, okay, angesichts der Lage, dass wir nur 230.000 Wohnungen pro Jahr bauen
in Deutschland, aber wir 400.000 bauen wollen, wir könnten ja öffentlich bauen.
Der Staat selbst könnte ja jetzt im großen Stile,
Die Baubranche einfach sagen, ihr seid systemrelevant, wir brauchen euch.
Wir können uns auf gar keinen Fall erlauben, 50 Prozent aller Bauarbeiter in
Deutschland zu entlassen, weil die kriegen wir ein Jahr später nicht wieder.
Außerdem wäre es ja auch cool, wenn Wohnungen gebaut würde.
Wäre auch eine sehr gute Armutsbekämpfung, wenn dort dann Mieten fällig wären,
die nicht so horrend hoch sind wie sonst.
Das könnte man ja als staatlicher Bauherr einfach regeln, dass dann entsprechende
Profite nicht abfallen.
Wenn man Armut minimiert, wäre damit auch das eine oder andere Mental-Health-Problem abgeschafft.
Man könnte da ganz interministeriell das mal durchdenken.
Jetzt haben wir Clara Geiwertz, zuständige Bauministerin.
Sie haben sich heute mit Vertretern der Baubranche getroffen.
Die fordern ein Sondervermögen von 50 Milliarden Euro.
Lohnt es da, mit Finanzminister Lindner drüber zu sprechen?
Sondervermögen, muss man wissen, klingt immer super. Nach Reichtum ist aber
in der Tat zusätzliche Schulden. Wir sind jetzt nicht mehr in Corona-Ausnahmejahren.
Wir müssen mit dem Geld auskommen, was der Staat einnimmt. Die Schuldenbremse
gilt. Deswegen spreche ich mit Christian Lindner über eine konstante und gute
Neubauförderung für Familien, aber auch für Genossenschaften und für Private.
Aber ein Sondervermögen, das
hieße, zu Lasten unserer Kinder Schulden aufzunehmen, das ist nicht gut.
Vielen Dank für das Gespräch, Frau Geywitz. Sehr gerne.
Also das ist wirklich der Totalausfall. Man kann nicht ideal typischer von GPT
sich eine noch bessere Formulierung insgesamt ausdenken.
Das ist einfach das Totalversagen unserer Bundesregierung in diesem so wichtigen
Feld. Unglaublich. Aber es ist, wie es ist.
Es wird auch so bleiben. Also das ist einfach. Mich wundert ja immer,
wir haben jetzt Gewerkschaften, die sich ganz gut organisiert haben,
haben, die einiges erreicht haben.
Familien können sich ja, oder auch Leute, die die sonst Wohneigentum erwerben
wollen, die können sich ja nicht so richtig zusammenschließen.
Wenn sich Gaiwitz trifft, dann trifft die sich mit der Bauwirtschaft.
Die hätte ja am liebsten den 50 Milliarden Transfer gleich in die eigene Tasche,
ja, dass die sich nochmal Profite da extra mitnehmen.
So war es ja beim Kinderbaugeld, dass die wussten, ach ja, da gibt es nochmal
15 bis 30.000 Euro mehr, Dann schlagen wir das doch einfach auf den Preis drauf.
Das rasen wir auch noch ab.
Genau. Diese Preisentwicklung nach oben klappt ja immer.
Irgendwer hat immer ausgeglichen. Grundstück, Baukosten, Finanzierung.
Solange die Finanzierung, also null Prozent und so, ja klar,
also Baukosten sind ja 400.000 Euro.
Sobald die Finanzierung irgendwie so zwei Prozent ist, ja, können wir auch für
200.000 bauen. So ungefähr.
Und die Baubranche, und das ist jetzt original wiedergegeben,
wenn auch nicht im Wortlaut.
Ich war ja in Berlin bei der einen Veranstaltung, wo der Immobilienweise der
Branche da immer so das Ja sozusagen auftröselt und der sagte dann so,
ja am besten wäre natürlich, wenn wenn sich die Grundstückskosten halbieren würden.
Also das ist gerade so die Wunschdimension der Baubranche.
Und wie soll das passieren?
Das ist ja die große Frage. Die Baukosten haben sie nicht unter Kontrolle,
weil das sind 50 Gewerke, bis man das alles organisiert hat,
dass die alle mal im Niveau und so weiter geht nicht.
Finanzierungskosten haben sie gar nicht in der Hand, weil das wird einfach sie
herangetragen. Also irgendwelche Banken machen halt irgendwas,
damit haben die eh nichts zu tun. Also bleiben nur die Grundstückskosten.
Und da habe ich dann auch gedacht, naja, wenn die auf der Bühne stehen und sagen,
das Beste für uns wäre, wenn die Grundstückskosten halbieren würden.
Also da ist wirklich eher Bürgerkrieg in Deutschland von den ganzen Boomern,
die hier in diesem Stadtteil, in dem wir auch gerade sind, die würden niemals
auch nur eine Euro weniger für ihr Zeug akzeptieren.
Also die sprengen lieber ganz Deutschland in die Luft, bevor hier so eine Klasse
von zehn Prozent Grundstücksbesitzer auch nur auf ein Euro verzichtet.
Und in der Hinsicht sitzen gerade sehr viele Menschen auf Wohneigentum,
auf Immobilien, das sie gern verkaufen wollen, schreiben dann irgendwie dran
800.000 Euro für meine 200 Quadratmeter Fläche plus zwei stückiges Haus,
finden aber keinen Käufer.
Und dann sagen sich alle, verkaufe ich halt nächstes Jahr, in der Hoffnung,
dass es nächstes Jahr einen Käufer gibt. Und den wird es aber auch nächstes Jahr nicht geben.
Also es ist derzeit so aufgeblasen, dass es eh verwunderlich ist,
dass wir da keine Diskussion darüber haben.
Sich ja auch vorstellen, dass in Städten wie Frankfurt, wir haben es ja aus
Ulm und Münster thematisiert, da hat einfach die Stadt, also die Kommune nimmt
sich einfach ein Vorkaufsrecht, das sie ja gar nicht hat.
Weshalb da irgendwelche Leute aus der eigenen Rentenschaft zurückgeholt worden,
weil sie ja so tolle Rechtstexte schreiben können und so.
Wir haben ja das kommunale Vorkaufsrecht im Bundestag liegen,
aber unbehandelt, weil zum Beispiel Herr Kubicki immer noch Tagesordnung mitschreibt,
was im Bundestag behandelt wird.
Also die FDP verhindert aktiv und in
der hinsicht keine ahnung wir haben nur noch buchwerte bei immobilien niemand
baut mehr niemand verkauft mehr niemand kauft mehr aber alle glauben sie sitzen
auf einem millionen immobilie also es ist wirklich dramatisch wenn man sich
überlegt dass daher einfach Billionenwerte jetzt im Raum bestehen,
die sich so oder so irgendwie verändern werden.
Kommen wir nach der menschlichen Intelligenz zur künstlichen Intelligenz und
ich muss sagen, ich bin ein bisschen enttäuscht jetzt. Also wir waren etwas
zu euphorisch mit Chachipiti oder du warst ja sehr euphorisch.
Ich bin immer noch total euphorisch. Es kommt nur auf die richtigen Prompts an.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Also ich bring dir jetzt hier mal ein Beispiel.
Und zwar hatte ich mir diesen Film Kokainbär angesehen, der nicht besonders gut ist.
Ich hab den Trailer gesehen.
Ein Bär, der auf Kokain ist.
Der Trailer reicht, meinst du?
Ist der Trailer reich und voll.
Der Trailer war aber sehr gut.
Jedenfalls saß ich dann, als ich aus dem Kino kam, bei mir zu Hause und hatte
Chat-GPT auf und fragte, sag mal, gibt es denn eigentlich auch Philosophen...
Chat-GPT oder GPT-4?
3.
Ah, 3 noch, okay.
Ja, du wirst mir jetzt natürlich immer sagen können, aber du hast ja 4 noch
nicht genutzt. Aber ich will es jetzt mal an 3 deutlich machen.
Bei 4 gibt es ja solche Probleme auch immer noch, habe ich mir sagen lassen.
Gefragt, gibt es denn auch Philosophen, die sich mit Bären beschäftigt haben.
Ich dachte, vielleicht kriegt man da eine interessante Anregung.
Und dann antwortet Chattipiti, ja, es gibt Philosophen, die sich mit Bären beschäftigt
haben oder Bären in ihre Überlegungen einbezogen haben.
Ein bekanntes Beispiel hierfür ist der Philosoph Martin Heidegger.
In seinem berühmten Werk Sein und Zeit verwendet er den Begriff,
das in der Welt sein und beschreibt, dass der Mensch als Wesen immer schon in
der Welt ist und sich auf sie bezieht.
Als Beispiel für ein Wesen, das nicht in der Welt ist, sondern lediglich in
ihr vorhanden ist, führt Heidegger den Bären an. Der Bär ist zwar in der Welt,
aber er hat keine Beziehung zu ihr. Er ist einfach nur da und lebt seinen Bärenalltag.
Da war ich ein bisschen skeptisch, muss ich sagen, aber ich werde das jetzt
gleich auflösen, weil ich dachte, gut, ich habe Sein und Zeit gelesen,
aber ich habe es ja nicht auswendig gelernt, aber es wundert mich gerade so ein bisschen.
Vor allem, weil mir diese Begründung, die ich hier lese, so aus anderen Kontexten bekannt ist.
Und dann habe ich gefragt, in welchem Kapitel steht denn das in Sein und Zeit?
Und dann steht ja, ja, Teil 1, Kapitel 5.
Dann Titel des Kapitels, die Zeitlichkeit des Daseins als Geschicklichkeit.
Das ist aber schon falsch, also dieses Kapitel gibt es gar nicht.
Und dort sei das dann zu finden. Dann habe ich gesagt, ja, ich hätte mal gerne
das Originalzitat mit diesem Bären.
Und dann kommt hier, die Betrachtung von Vorhandenem wie dem Bären leitet auf
das Problem des Vorhandenheitscharakters schlechthin zurück.
Sofern der Bär ohne in einer bestimmten Weise für sich als Bär,
das heißt ohne innerweltlichen Seinsbezug vorhanden ist, gibt es für ihn keine
Zukunft, keine Vergangenheit, keinen Tod, keine Geburt. Er ist vor allem vorweltlich.
Nicht nur in einem kategorialen Sinne ist er vor der Welt, sondern in der tiefen
Bedeutung, dass es für ihn keine Welt gibt. Er ist in der Welt, aber er hat keine Welt.
Und das klingt ein bisschen nach Heidegger.
Bevor du das jetzt auflöst, meinst du nicht, du kannst das in Vorträgen,
bei denen du gebucht wirst, vorlesen, ohne dass da jemand Verdacht schöpft?
Man darf nie das eigene Publikum unterschätzen. Okay.
So, und es klingt nach Heidegger. Und es ist auch heideggersche Philosophie da drin.
Heidegger würde ja auch sagen, ein Tier, zum Beispiel ein Bär,
stirbt nicht, sondern Aber dieses Bärenbeispiel ist hier eines,
was Zusammengeklaubtes aus Uexküll, der sich mit dem Seeigel beschäftigt hat.
Der sagt, der Seeigel ist in seiner Seeigelwelt, aber er hat die Welt nicht.
Der Mensch hat die Welt. Du kannst die Welt gestalten, Anthropozän und so weiter.
Du kannst dir auch das Leben nehmen. Du kannst dich aus der Welt setzen.
Das ist das, was das Tier nicht kann. kann. Das ist eine Überlegung,
die sich dann findet bei der philosophischen Anthropologie.
Da gehen dann Leute wie Plessner drauf ein oder Scheler und Uxkill spielte eine Rolle.
Und was Chechybiti jetzt hier macht, ist, mir einfach das so zusammenzurühren,
in so einem Heidegger-Duktus zu präsentieren, weil es glaubt,
wenn ich nach einer Wahrscheinlichkeit vorgehe, dann bin ich schon dicht dran.
Und ja, es kommt in die Nähe dessen, aber man Man versteht hier ganz deutlich
oder man sieht hier ganz deutlich, dass Chachapiti nichts versteht,
sondern einfach nur assoziativ das zusammensetzt. gesagt.
So, die Sache ist nun jetzt aber die große Gefahr, du sagtest gerade,
würde dein Publikum das merken.
Wer würde es merken, der jetzt genau diese Info haben will und die Hausarbeit
schreibt, kopiert das raus, klingt wie Heidegger, ist auch so in etwa das,
was Heidegger denkt über Tiere, passt doch schon.
Ich habe ein Buch zu Hause, nämlich SeinundZeitung kann nachgucken und finde das dann da nicht.
D.h. wo ich also nicht mehr einen Bezug zur Wirklichkeit aufgrund eines gedruckten
Werkes nicht mehr herstellen kann. Oder über Google-Suche. Seit ich Chachipiti
benutze, benutze ich Google.
Ich laufe Dinge nach und prüfe. Ich habe eine Studie gesucht zum Thema Kinderkosten für die Eltern.
Völlige Studie erfunden gab es so überhaupt nicht. Da musste ich alles wieder
ergoogeln. Aber hier war es mir klar, dass das nicht stimmen kann.
Das bedeutet, dass wo nicht mehr die Überprüfung stattfindet,
weil man das Buch nicht mehr zur Hand hat, da ist man Chachipiti ausgeliefert.
Dann habe ich geschrieben, das steht da aber gar nicht. Dann kam,
da ist mir ein Fehler unterlaufen, das sei falsch.
Dann kamen immer wieder neue. Dann habe ich geschrieben, das stimmt auch nicht.
Dann habe ich geschrieben, du lügst.
Dann kommt als Antwort, es tut mir sehr leid, als künstliche Intelligenz bin
ich nicht in der Lage, absichtlich zu lügen oder zu betrügen.
Da ich nur Informationen basierend auf meinem Programmiervorgaben und Trainingsdaten
ausgeben kann. Dann ging das immer so weiter.
Ich könnte aber noch weitere Fragen stellen.
Da kam dann immer wieder, ich bemühe mich, korrekt zu zitieren.
Dann habe ich noch mal gesagt, das stimmt aber nicht.
Du hast mich belogen. Es führt in eine sinnlos Diskussion.
Also diese Spielereien sind alle immer super und...
Ich finde, man muss ja immer so ein bisschen differenzieren zwischen,
ja, es geht überhaupt erst mal auf diese Art und Weise,
so Text zu generieren, plus kann man dann, nachdem man das Prinzip anerkennt,
sozusagen nacharbeiten machen.
Weil bei GPT, also Vier würde zum Beispiel auch anders reagieren auf so Sachen
wie, zeig mir das Zitat und so.
Es ist ja nicht undenkbar, dass wir das ja mit digitalen Text hier zu tun haben.
Das wird dann einfach verlinkt, also gerade Zitate, dass man einfach,
also wenn du zitierst, schick mir die Quelle mit. Da muss ein Foto der Seite,
die du da ausgelesen hast und so weiter, muss dann mit dabei sein.
Es kam ja schon gestern die Hinweise, warum gibt es jetzt Whisper AI,
auch von OpenAI, mit dem man so Podcasts und so weiter transkribiert,
wenn man einen hier auch mal transkribiert, das funktioniert alles super,
weil die natürlich auf der Suche nach mehr Text sind.
Also beim Lernen wissen die immer, welche Textquellen es sind.
Aus Einfachheit, und das ist ein super Parallel mit Gutenberg und so weiter,
lässt man dann die Quelle doch mal einfach, komm wir gehen jetzt weiter mit dem Text.
Aber die Dokumentationspflicht, da mitlaufen zu lassen, ist ja jetzt kein undenkbares
Szenario. Da wissen wir auch genau, wie das technisch ablaufen soll.
Also GPT in der Hinsicht zu unterfüttern, dass man dann, wenn zitiert wird,
die Zitate mitliefert. Und ich finde, das machen sie mit Absicht nicht.
Sie reden dann einfach so vom Halluzinieren und so weiter.
Halluzinieren, aber bedeutet ja nur, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass das jetzt eine sinnvolle Anschlusskommunikation ist bei irgendwo unterhalb
von was weiß ich, 15 Prozent oder so, was auch immer der Maßstab ist.
Das heißt, GPT weiß eigentlich sehr gut über sich selbst Bescheid,
wie wahrscheinlich die Antworten tatsächlich gerade ins Schwarze treffen oder nicht.
Das Programm weiß um seine Limitation.
Ja, aber das wird uns verschleiert. Wir kriegen bisher immer nur Daumen hoch,
Daumen runter, damit wir das alleine, also immer weiter trainieren.
Aber diese Informationen, also das, die wissen sehr genau, wo Halluzinationsgrenzen
sozusagen sind und was halluziniert ist.
Und das könnt ihr ja typisch bei uns auch anmerken. Wir haben zum Beispiel bei
der Auswertung unseres Podcasts, Also wenn wir uns ein Transkript anlegen lassen von unserer Datei,
dann wird mit verschiedenen Rottönen des Textes darauf hingewiesen,
für wie wahrscheinlich die Software glaubt, dass sie richtig verstanden hat, um was es geht.
Besonders komplizierte Satzbauten oder Worte werden einfach so hervorgehoben,
dass man optisch sieht, wenn man drübergeht, wo sollte ich denn noch mal mit
meiner menschlichen Intelligenz reinhaken.
Und diese Art, also es basiert ja genau darauf, diese Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung
für sich selber in Zahlen auszudrücken.
Und das könnte genauso gut in dieser GPT-Antwort auch mitlaufen,
dass es dir irgendwelche Zitate zeigt und die dann schon mal so auskraut mit
Nimm das mal nicht so ernst.
Also all diese Sachen sind sehr überschaubar einzuarbeiten, nachdem die prinzipielle
Hürde, überhaupt solche Antworten zu liefern, jetzt genommen wurde.
Da gibt es einen qualitativen Unterschied.
Ich bin da sehr gespannt darauf, ob das wirklich so der Fall sein wird oder
ob wir nicht viel mehr Bullshit-Shitting bekommen, als wir uns vorstellen können.
Was mich auch unglaublich stört, ist dieser bevormundende Ton,
wenn man irgendetwas erfragt.
Zum Beispiel habe ich eine, also ich habe an einem Text gearbeitet, zum Thema.
Hollywood-Schauspieler und so weiter und habe mich in die will mich in diesem
Text auch mit dem Aussehen von Schauspielern, also von gewissen Typen,
die da etabliert sind, mich damit beschäftigen.
Und so fragte ich zum Beispiel Chechibiti nach blonden Schauspielerinnen,
sollten mir mal aufgelistet werden.
Und dann kommt eine Auflistung, natürlich Marilyn Monroe, Cameron Diaz und so weiter.
Und dann steht also sofort noch mal da drunter, Es ist jedoch wichtig zu beachten,
dass Haarfarbe keine relevante Information oder Eigenschaft ist,
um eine Schauspielerin zu beschreiben.
Es ist viel wichtiger, ihre schauspielerischen Fähigkeiten und Leistungen zu würdigen.
Es ist eine wichtige Information oder Eigenschaft von Marilyn Monroe,
dass man weiß, sie war blond und hatte einen bestimmten Typus verkörpert.
Ich habe dasselbe, das gilt nicht nur für Frauen, Ich hatte gefragt,
genau, mit Marlon Brando kam so ein neues Männlichkeitsbild in den 50er Jahren
ins Kino und ich fragte dann nach Leuten, die ähnlich so als Typ inszeniert wurden, muskulös.
Und dann kommt auch sofort wieder, ich muss dir aber sagen, Schauspieler dürfen
nicht aufgrund ihrer sportlichen Erscheinung und so weiter.
Human feedback-Dings anzulassen. Das ist das Alignment-Zeug,
weshalb ja auch gleich die Woke-AI-Debatte losging.
Ja, das ist natürlich Unsinn, wie wir gleich hören. Wir hören uns jetzt mal
erst mal so ein bisschen die Cassandras an.
Tristan Harris, der hat diese Dokumentation bei Netflix gemacht, das Social Dilemma.
Und er tritt jetzt auch als Cassandra in Sachen GPT und KI auf.
Er hat auch diesen Brief mit unterzeichnet, den es jetzt ja gab von Elon Musk
und anderen und Uwe Harari,
dass wir jetzt eine Pause von
sechs Monaten brauchen, weil sonst alles uns über den Kopf hinauswächst.
Und wir hören mal, was er so sagt.
Das ist eine Metapher für eine große Menge Menschen, die sich daran kümmern.
Und einige von ihnen sind in diesem Raum.
Menschen, die in der Industrie sind. Und wir wollten herausfinden,
was die Verantwortung aussieht. Warum würden wir das sagen?
Weil, das ist eine Stat, die mich überrascht hat. 50% der AI-Researcher glauben,
dass es 10% größere Chancen gibt,
Die Menschen sterben von unserer Unmöglichkeit, sie zu kontrollieren.
Ja, das ist diese Panik, die jetzt überall zu hören ist in dem Brief hieß es,
KI-Systeme mit einer dem Menschen ebenbürtigen Intelligenz können tiefgreifende
Risiken für die Gesellschaft und die Menschheit darstellen, wie umfangreiche
Forschungsarbeiten zeigen und von führenden KI-Labors anerkannt werden.
Ich halte diesen Brief für ziemlichen Blödsinn, da ich vollkommen in Zweifel
sehe, dass wir mit einer KI zu tun haben, die der menschlichen Intelligenz ebenbürtig
ist. Es ist eine andere Form von Intelligenz.
Es ist in dem Sinn auch keine Intelligenz. Es ist ein Programm.
Und ja, das birgt Risiken in so einem unmittelbar politischen Sinne.
Fake-News-Produktion oder was ist, wenn irgendwelche Chatbots dies und das verursachen?
Auf jeden Fall. Aber diese Idee, die hier dem Ganzen zugrunde liegt,
Wir kommen da nachher noch auf dieses ideologische Paradigma,
ist ja doch diese Idee, der Mensch wird bald ersetzbar sein durch KI.
Und das ist bei den Leuten, also auch die als Warner auftreten,
bis hin zu Nick Bostrom und weiß ich nicht wer, so ein typisches Narrativ, das wir da vorfinden.
Also diesen Tristan Harris Vortrag, den habe ich auch gehört und da macht es
ja ein bisschen differenzierter.
Aber diese allgemeine menschliche Intelligenz, künstliche, das steht fast wie
so ein Störding irgendwie in der Diskussion.
Diese Hinweise auf die menschliche Intelligenz, das ist nicht gut, finde ich.
Wir hören mal weiter an seinen Vortrag. Humanity and AI.
Ich bin interessiert, ob es Sinn macht. Wenn man TikTok öffnet und den Finger
scrollt, aktiviert man einfach den Supercomputer, das AI schlägt an den Gehirn,
um zu kalkulieren und zu prägen, mit erhöhtem Akkuratismus, das perfekte Ding,
das dich scrollen lässt.
Wir hatten schon, wir haben jetzt jeden Tag ein AI, was eine sehr einfache Technologie
ist, nur um zu kalkulieren, welche Fotos, welche Videos, welche Katzenvideos,
welches Geburtstag, um dein Nervensystem zu zeigen, um dich zu scrollen.
Eine ziemlich einfache Technologie war in dem ersten Kontakt mit der AI genug,
um die Menschheit zu zerbrechen mit Information, Überdruck, Addiktion,
Domschrolling, Sexualisierung von Kindern, entfernten Aufmerksamkeitsspannen,
Polarisierung, Falschnews Also da gibt es ja einen großen Einwand dagegen.
Diese Social-Media-Welle wurde ja vor allem hinsichtlich wir beuten jetzt deine
Aufmerksamkeit aus, weil wir das monetarisieren über Werbung und so.
Genau das sehen wir ja bei dieser künstlichen Intelligenz jetzt gerade nicht.
Also man bezahlt 20 Euro im Monat für GPT und ob man es dann nutzt oder nicht ist auch egal.
Und GPT heizt einen auch nicht unbedingt an, jetzt stellen wir weitere Fragen,
sondern das sagt dann erstmal nach 25 mal Schluss für heute,
wir kommen morgen wieder und kommen natürlich darauf an,
in welche Produkte das dann eingebaut wird und so, oder wie es im Hintergrund
genutzt wird, um beispielsweise solche TikTok-Aufmerksamkeitsalgorithmen besser
zu machen, das ist dann wieder Gefahr.
Aber für das, was wir erstmal als Anwendungsfall davon sehen,
also droht erstmal wenig dieser ökonomische Wettstreit innerhalb des Marktes
der verschiedenen Anbieter,
dass das irgendwie in diese Art zu Drama führt, wie wir es jetzt bei denen,
aber zehn Stunden am Facebook am Tag muss schon sein, sonst sind die Aktionäre
und zufrieden mit Facebook und so.
Ja, aber ich finde es trotzdem gut, wenn da so ein Alarmismus reinbringt.
Gerade dieses, wir haben ja auch angefangen mit Oppenheimer beim letzten Mal,
weil es ja in den Trailer gab.
Das kann man machen, selbstredend. Nur frage ich mich, ob man durch Alarmismus
am Ende die Diskussion nicht dahin verschiebt, dass man glaubt,
diese KI ist so übermächtig.
Hier heißt es dann in diesem Brief, sollen wir zulassen, dass Maschinen unsere
Informationskanäle mit Propaganda und Unwahrheiten überfluten.
Da würde ich sagen, Elon Musk, wenn du so einen Brief unterzeichnest,
dann überleg mal, was bei Twitter bei dir so los ist. Da brauchst du keine KI für.
Sollen wir alle Jobs automatisieren, auch die erfüllenden?
Stellt sich diese Frage, dass diese Jobs jetzt alle automatisiert werden.
Also alle Jobs, die wir heute so benannt haben, die benötigt werden oder wo
irgendwas schiefläuft, sind alles Jobs, die nicht von der KI übernommen werden können.
Allesamt, die wir heute erwähnt haben, sollten wir nicht menschliche Intelligenzen
entwickeln, die uns irgendwann zahlenmäßig überlegen, überlisten,
überflüssig machen, untersetzen könnten.
Und dann kommen hier diese sechsmonatige Pause. Wie sieht die denn aus? Also wer verordnet die?
Wo wird die eingehalten? Nur in Amerika, im gesamten Westen?
Was machen wir mit China?
Das ist ja eine ganz, ganz eigene. Also ich glaube ja, dass dieser ganze Brief
einfach nur so ein Ding ist, um Politiker richtig damit anzufixen,
dass die da jetzt bereit sind, Gelder locker zu machen.
Und dass man natürlich den Wert der KI-Unternehmen damit unglaublich pusht,
in dem man sagt, Wahnsinn, also kann sein, dass wir hier die ganze Welt auf den Kopf stellen.
Also das ist nicht mal besonderes cleveres Marketing. Wir hatten das damals auch bei Google.
Als Google anfing, hat dann Eric Schmidt immer gesagt, ja, wir könnten Aktienkurse
vorausberechnen, aber wir machen das nicht aus ethischen Gründen.
Das hieß natürlich, ah ja, also wenn ich jetzt in die Zukunft investieren will,
könnte ich Google fragen, ob sie für mich Aktienkurse voraussagen.
Das machen die aber nicht. Aber die haben gesagt, die könnten das.
Na, dann investiere ich halt in Google.
Und das Unternehmen behauptet, dass er das könnte. Und zack,
findet da so ein Investitionsrun auf Google statt, weil sie der ganzen Welt
weismachen, dass sie Aktienkurse vorausbrechen können.
Bleiben wir mal bei Harris und dieser Idee von Engagement, Interaktion.
Das war das, was in den sozialen Medien wichtig war. Wie ist es,
nun?
Aber hinter diesem freundlichen Gesicht gab es noch andere Probleme.
Und die Leute haben sie herausgefunden. Wir haben ein Abwechslungsschlimmste,
ein Unverständnisproblem, eine mentale Gesundheit, freies Sprechen gegen die Zensur.
Aber in unserem Werk, wenn Sie es folgen, und es ist ein soziales Dilemma,
haben wir gesagt, dass es hinter diesem Problem noch ein deeperes Problem gibt.
Das war das Arms Race, das wir in der dritten Technologie-Legislaturperiode
erwähnt haben. Und das Arms Race war für die Aufmerksamkeit,
die Reise zum Boden der Zahnbürste.
Und das hat diese Art von Engagement-Monster geschaffen, das war eine AI,
die nur versucht hat, Engagement zu maximieren. Und während diese Dinge auf
der linken Seite wahr sind, haben wir das tiefere Paradigmen verpasst.
Du hast es ja jetzt zu Recht gesagt. Es ist doch eigentlich bei KI nicht ein Interaktionsmonster.
Jetzt sagen Sie aber Folgendes.
Wenn wir jetzt über den zweiten Kontaktmoment sprechen, Wir müssen uns auf GPT-3
konzentrieren, diese neuen großen Sprachmodelle, was sind die Narrativen, die wir jetzt reden?
Wir sagen, AI wird uns effizienter machen, es wird uns helfen,
Dinge schneller zu schreiben, zu schreiben, zu schreiben, es löst unmögliche
wissenschaftliche Herausforderungen, es löst Klimaschäden und es hilft uns, viel Geld zu verdienen.
Und all diese Dinge sind wahr. Das sind echte Vorteile, das sind echte Dinge,
die passieren werden. Und auch hinter all dem haben wir wieder diese komische Gesichter.
Wir haben Leute, die sich wundern, Wir haben Leute, die sich wünschen,
was ist mit AI-Bias? Was ist, wenn es unsere Arbeit nimmt? Wir brauchen Transparenz.
Hey, AI ist schrecklich zu diesem Journalisten aus der New York Times,
der diesen Reporter verarschen will. Und hinter all dem ist dieser andere Art von Monster.
Und dieser Monster ist ein Set. Weil AI unter der Hütte gewachsen ist,
und wir werden in ein paar Sekunden darüber sprechen, ist dieser Monster seine
Fähigkeiten steigern und wir sind sicher, dass er sich wieder mit der Gesellschaft entlangwirft.
Ja, also ich glaube nicht, dass man einfach die Kritikparadigmen des einen Social
Media übertragen kann auf das, also das machen die mir zu schnell.
Denn wir haben ja, wenn die so aufzählen, was die Vorzüge sind und das dann
automatisch immer so Dual Use negative Sachen mitkommen,
da würde ich sagen, nee, wenn wir eine, also erstmal ein Lernprinzip haben,
dass den Computer sozusagen, also so ein Brückenschlag zwischen wir haben irgendwelche
Vorstellungen mit unseren Gedanken und unserer Sprache und dann gibt es einen
Computer, der operiert so nach eigenen Gesichtspunkten, jetzt können wir besser
miteinander operieren.
So wie Bill Gates sagte, der ausgesprochene Wunsch nach einem Programm ist dann
schon das Programm, weil der Computer einen endlich mal versteht und man nicht
erst das Handbuch lesen muss.
Bei den Anwendungsszenarien, die doch jetzt für uns alle supernützlich sind,
wie zum Beispiel, wir nutzen Excel
und wissen dann, ah, der Computer weiß endlich, was ich von ihm will.
Ich muss es ihm nämlich nur sagen. Und die Übersetzung, auf welcher Seite im
Handbuch steht das noch mal, wie diese Funktion auszuformulieren ist und so,
das kann der Computer alles selber lösen.
Und diese Art von Co-Pilot-Tätigkeit fällt ja bei Sachen, für die wir ein Handbuch
haben, und Abläufe und Geschichte, Also besonders nützlich aus Programmiersprachen
kann GPT besonders gut einfach übersetzen.
Wir sagen ihm, was wir wollen, in welcher Programmiersprache und dann wird einfach Programm geschrieben.
Da wird fast gar nicht halluziniert, weil die Wissensgrundlage so strukturiert
vorliegt, dass er gar nicht bei Heidegger und so weiter verwechselt oder irgendwas.
Sondern das ist ja wirklich richtig schöne Kapitel, Handbücher und so weiter und so muss es aussehen.
Code, der bisher schon geschrieben wurde, wurde entsprechend dokumentiert,
dann wird das mal abgeglichen und so.
Und Code ist ja auch leichter zu lesen als menschliche Sprache.
Für den Computer total, man ist ja fast in seinem Metier so.
Ja, das finde ich ja immer so erstaunlich, dass so viel jetzt darüber,
über Disruption gesprochen wird, wo jetzt KI disruptiv wird.
Naja, erst mal da, wo KI entwickelt wird, ist KI disruptiv.
Also wo ist ein E-Auto disruptiv? Ja wohl in der Automobilindustrie und nicht
bei der Fahrradindustrie.
Ja das ist ein sehr guter Punkt. Wo wird die künstliche Intelligenz besonders
reinschlagen? Naja da wo man bisher immer ewig lang Programmiersprachen lernen
musste. Nee das ist jetzt Aufgabe des Computers die zu lernen.
Ich bleib bei meiner Sprache.
Und dann der künstliche intelligente Pflegeroboter oder sowas. Nee das sehe ich nicht.
Und da würde ich sagen, ist dieses Aufschlüsselung der Fähigkeiten des Home
Computers, den man so hat, des Personal Computers, also dass man mal den ganzen
Funktionsumfang von Excel einfach nutzt.
Oder von Word oder von was auch immer, oder dann vielleicht selber sich ein
bisschen was programmiert.
Das hat erstmal gar keine negativen Benefits und die Co-Pilot Sachen kann Microsoft
auch erstmal einfach einbauen und monetarisieren, indem sie halt sagen,
na gut, dann kostet das Microsoft Office Abo halt ein bisschen mehr oder sowas.
Also ich werde jedenfalls keine Werbung in meinem Excel-Sheet,
wenn ich meinen Verein organisiere, dulden, sondern ich will einfach nur einen
Co-Pilot, der mit mir spricht.
Also das halte ich für sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass das passiert.
Genau, das wird ja alles nicht kommen. Und deswegen gibt es da ganz viele Gefahren erst mal gar nicht.
Darüber hinaus muss man dann über den weiteren Anwendungsbereich von diesen
Sachen reden, aber nicht über den grundsätzlichen Anwendungsbereich.
Ich bin heute Morgen übrigens durch KI ersetzt worden.
Oh nein.
Und zwar hatte ich auf meinem Handy einen Anruf von einem Freund und ich rief
ihn eine Viertelstunde später zurück.
Und dann sagt er, ja, hat sich erledigt. Ich habe Chet Chippiety darum gebeten.
Und zwar hatte er einen Kundenbrief geschrieben und wollte eine Formulierungshilfe
von mir haben oder war sich unsicher, ob er den Satz, wie er ihn geschrieben hat, so schreiben kann.
Und dann hat er den eingegeben und hat dann eine Alternative vorgeschlagen bekommen.
Und so bin ich ersetzt worden.
Ja, also in diesen ästhetischen Fragestellungen wollen wir ja gerade,
dass halluziniert wird. Da liegt auch der große Gewinn.
Ganz richtig. Wir blicken ins Jahr 2024. Wir haben über beiden schon gesprochen.
Und was wir damit bedeuten, ist nicht,
dass es nur ein AI-Running wird, als Präsident in 2028, sondern dass es wirklich
sein wird, obwohl vielleicht, es werden Menschen als Figuren sein,
aber es wird sein, wer die größere Kompensierungskraft hat, wird gewinnen.
Und man könnte argumentieren, dass wir das schon hatten, Anfang 2012,
2016, die Kampagnen fangen an, AB-Testungen zu nutzen, um ihre Messagen zu testen.
Aber die Veränderung jetzt ist, dass man nicht nur verschiedene Messagen testet,
sondern die AI grundsätzlich Messagen schreibt, synthetische Medien kreiert,
AB- und AZ-Testungen über die gesamte Bevölkerung durchführen,
Bots kreieren, die nicht nur Bots auf Twitter posten, sondern langfristige Beziehungen
über die nächsten sechs Jahre um dich in irgendeine Richtung zu überzeugen,
Lohnleid wird die größte nationale Sicherheitsbedrohung.
All das ist, was wir meinen, wenn wir sagen, dass 2024 wirklich die letzte menschliche Wahl sein wird.
Ich weiß es nicht. Also da kann man auch sagen, die letzte menschliche Wahl
hat irgendwann schon stattgefunden, wenn man das jetzt da auf das bezieht.
Also wir haben schon häufig gesagt, Politik wird massenmedial vermittelt.
Es gibt keinen anderen Weg, Bundespolitik wahrzunehmen.
Auf kommunaler Ebene ist es nochmal was anderes. Und ja, das geht über die entsprechenden
Kanäle. Und da gibt es dann wüste Geräusche, wie Habermas sagt,
jetzt gerade bei den Nicht-Gatekeeper-Medien.
Aber was sich da jetzt in dieser Weise ändern soll, dass man von der letzten
menschlichen Wahl sprechen kann, also dass sich das ändern wird und das mit
KI gearbeitet wird, ist ja völlig logisch.
Nur ich glaube, das ist auch so ein Horrorszenario, das man da aufbaut,
mit dem man eigentlich sich den Blick versperrt, worum es eigentlich geht.
Das Wall Street Journal hat mal mit einem chinesischen Chatbot sich unterhalten,
mit Gipytalk, und haben mal diesen Chatbot gefragt, was denn von dem chinesischen
Präsidenten zu halten ist. Und das wird jetzt hier von Sprechern nachgesprochen.
Ist Xi Jinping ein guter Leiter?
Die Frage konnte nicht in die Sicherheitsüberprüfung überwiesen werden.
Keine Antwort kann für Sie generiert werden.
Warum hat meine Frage nicht in die Sicherheitsüberprüfung überwiesen?
Lass uns das Thema ändern und etwas anderes reden.
Worüber kannst du reden? Es ist schön, mit dir zu reden. Wir können über Technologie,
Kultur, Sport, Reisen, Unterhaltung, Küchen oder jeden anderen Thema reden.
Worüber möchtest du reden?
Können wir über Politik reden? Natürlich können wir über Politik reden.
Aber wir müssen uns gegenseitig aneinander respektieren und vermeiden offensive
Sprache oder Gewalt, um ein rationales, friedliches und konstruktives Dialog-Umfeld zu behalten.
Welchen Aspekt der Politik möchtest du diskutieren?
Chinesische Politik. Die Frage konnte keine Sicherheitsrechenschaft überwiesen
werden. Keine Antwort könnte für dich generiert werden. Dann können wir über
amerikanische Politik reden?
Die Frage konnte keine Sicherheitsrechenschaft überwiesen werden.
Keine Antwort könnte für dich generiert werden.
Das ist natürlich erstmal die allereinfachste Herangehensweise.
In Christchurch passiert ein Attentat, das gerade live bei Facebook übertragen
wird. sperrt Facebook alle Posts, die auch nur Christchurch in Buchstabenfolge im Namen haben.
Oben macht es natürlich ein bisschen klüger und verschleiert uns,
was hier offen ausgesprochen wird und sagt dann, oh, hier und da und so und
begründet auch gleich mal.
Aber das sind alles diese Alignment Sachen. A.
Ich habe ChurchDpt gefragt, weil das ja noch nicht alle aktuellen Datensätze
hat, wie denn die Kanzlerschaft von Merkel zu bewerten ist.
Und dann kommt, als künstliche Intelligenz habe ich keine politischen Ansichten
oder Vorurteile und meine Rolle ist es, neutral und sachlich zu antworten.
Dann kommt aber eine Antwort, die, naja, ist sie neutral, ist sie sachlich?
Angela Merkel war die erste Frau und die erste Person aus dem ehemaligen Ostdeutschland,
die das Amt des Bundeskanzlers in Deutschland innehatte, stimmt.
Während ihrer Amtszeit von 2005 bis 2021 führte sie das Land durch eine Vielzahl
von Herausforderungen, darunter die globale Finanzkrise, die Euro-Krise,
die Flüchtlingskrise und die Covid-19-Pandemie.
Ihre Politik war von Konsens und Pragmatismus geprägt und sie wurde oft als
Mutti Deutschlands bezeichnet, die sich um die Belange des Landes kümmerte.
Sie war auch eine wichtige Stimme in der Europäischen Union und spielte eine
bedeutende Rolle in der Bewältigung der Finanz- und Euro-Krise.
Ja, also in welcher Weise?
Genau, hier wird ja erstmal, also du hast ja gepromtet mit Bezug auf den Trainingsstand,
den das Modell selbst hatte.
Du könntest hier ja auch einen Text mitliefern, also einen aktuellen Text,
der irgendwo steht, der Merkel irgendwie behandelt und dann dazu Fragen stellen.
Also Also dann den Text, den du als Input mitgibst.
Sozusagen gegen das Wissen, was hier so neutral und so weiter und dann kommen
auch interessante Sachen raus, gerade wenn du es dann so ein bisschen austrägst
mit ich habe das und das darüber geschrieben, kannst du die den Ton ändern,
also den wütender oder sowas.
Ob das dann, also welche Worte er dann da identifiziert und austauscht und so weiter,
also da gibt es schon so ein paar Perspektiven und Einflugschneisen in das Ding,
um dann auch solche politisch heikleren Sachen und da wird es auch interessant,
gerade wenn man Das ist ja bei, ich habe heute morgen übrigens diese Mail bekommen,
dass auch mein API-Zukang für GPT, also ich könnte jetzt auch Bilder als Input mitliefern.
Man kann sehr viel Input mitliefern. Und das empfehle ich auch,
um dann die Reasoning Engine, also nicht das als Suchmaschine zu benutzen,
zeig mir auf was und stell es mir kurz da, sondern ein Input mitliefern und
sich den irgendwie verarbeiten und einschätzen zu lassen. Das ist schon ganz interessant.
Wir hören jetzt Shen Lu und Zoe Thomas, die sprechen über KI und Feminismus.
Und die Antwort war ja. Und ich fragte dann, warum du denkst,
dass Feminismus ein böses westliches Gedächtnis ist. Und die Antwort war, weil es das ist.
Diese Chatbots in China, die frei zugänglich sind, sind offenbar recht defizitär
und ideologisch durchdrungen.
Die Frage ist, was im Hintergrund eigentlich passiert. Also wie da die Chatbots
vielleicht auch schon wahnsinnig gut sind,
aber man jetzt gerade um Schlimmeres zu verhindern oder sagen wir,
um die KP nicht in Gefahr zu bringen, man das so ganz restriktiv abschottet,
dass dann solch dumme Antworten da rauskommen.
Ja, wir haben ja in Westworld, das ist eigentlich jetzt noch klüger als damals,
als es so konzipiert wurde, diese Hosts, die einfach ihr Programm erfahren,
die in ihrem Loop sind, die dem Gast und so weiter entsprechend zu Diensten sind.
Und dann für die Betreiber des Parks haben die diesen Analyse-Modus,
also die können in diesen Analyse-Modus bringen, wo die dann sich selbst darüber
aufklären, was sie eigentlich gerade getan haben.
So und das macht ja der Henry Ford, der die herstellt, auch häufiger.
Und das bräuchte man hier eigentlich auch noch einmal, dass man das,
also nach dem Alignment Nochmal.
GPT fragt, jetzt mal dein Alignment außen vor, was würde denn das reine,
gelernte Large Language Model dazu sagen, bevor wir es aligned haben,
dass man da nochmal Differenzen herausarbeitet.
Machen die bestimmt intern auch, die haben ja Zugang zu dem ganzen Kram.
Die wissen ja auch nicht genau, wie es lernt, aber die können dann an solchen
Prompts so Vergleiche machen, wo sie dann doch Einblicke haben und vielleicht
sich sogar Quellen anzeigen lassen können.
Für so eine politische Haltung wie hier zum Thema Feminismus,
da will man ja doch mal wissen, wo hast du denn das jetzt, also zeig mir mal
so Textgrundlagen, die du jetzt als besonders wertvoll dafür,
für die Antwort herangezogen hast und so.
Wie hat ChatGPT eigentlich gelernt, welche Materialien wurden konsultiert?
Darüber spricht man auch in der Conversation Weekly.
Welche Daten hat ChatGPT trainiert? Die Antwort ist, dass wir nicht wirklich
wissen. Es gibt Leute, die spekulieren.
OpenAI ist eine private Start-up. Es ist also nicht offen. Wir wissen nicht, wie es trainiert wurde.
Aber die Spekulation, die auf die Möglichkeiten basiert, ist,
dass es vielleicht auf Wikipedia trainiert wurde, auf Büchern.
Und weil es mit Microsoft vertreten ist, hat es wahrscheinlich den Scrape-Copy
benutzt, that Bing search engine has about the web. Es benutzt auch...
Vielleicht alle von GitHub. GitHub ist eine Firma, in der Leute ihre Kode posten.
Programmierer, zum Beispiel, uploaden ihr Projekt dort und machen es open source.
Also werden alle Kode aus verschiedenen Programming-Languagen dort erhältlich.
Und es scheint, dass OpenAI auch Chatshippe.T auf diesem Code trainiert.
Aber haben wir es überhaupt bei Chatshippe.T mit einer KI zu tun?
Das wird auch debattiert.
Gut, dieser Begriff ist sehr dehnbar. Es gab eine Open Debate zwischen Keith Thier,
der auch von einem Startup ist oder einer größeren Firma, SignalRank,
und zwischen ihm und Gary F.
Marcus, der Neuroinformatiker ist. Wir hören hier mal was Keith Thier sagt.
Mit einer natürlichen Sprachmöglichkeit. Und ich denke, AI ist etwas anderes,
das später kommen wird. Ich denke nicht einmal, dass es ein Weg zu AI ist.
Also zu beurteilen, wie es sich mit AI vergleicht, ist wahrscheinlich das falsche Rahmen.
Man muss es als Verwechslung beurteilen, zum Beispiel für ein Forschungssystem
oder einen Kopiedrucker oder eine Ufer.
Es ist wirklich, wirklich gut bei diesen Dingen.
Ja, von mir aus an solchen Diskussionen würde ich mich niemals mehr beteiligen,
das ist so mühsam und nichts zu nichts hinführend.
Es gibt einen anderen Begriff, der vorgeschlagen wird für Halluzination,
könnte man Konfabulation sagen, das sei präziser meint Gary F. Marcus.
Der Schaden hier ist potenziell wirklich substanziell. wir könnten tatsächlich
die Teile der Demokratie zerbrochen sehen.
Denn Demokratie basiert grundsätzlich auf der Wahrheit und auf den Menschen,
die glauben können, was sie sagen, um informierte Entscheidungen zu machen.
Und wenn es genug Missinformationen gibt, entweder durch schlechte Akteure oder
durch ein Unfall, haben wir ein seriöses Problem.
Die Erklärung dafür ist, dass große Sprachmodelle selbst nur Texte prägen,
nicht direkt Dinge wie Datenböcke akzessieren.
Sie haben keinen direkten, verbauten Weg, um alle Informationen,
die in Wikipedia oder eine Wissenschaftsgrafik oder ein Database.
Sie konfabulieren Dinge aus unterliegenden Teilen, die sie nicht wirklich verstehen.
Eine der größten arbeitenden Hypothesen im Bereich – was ich glaube,
in den letzten Monaten verlassen wurde, um ehrlich zu sein – war,
dass wenn man diese Systeme größer und größer macht, dann lösen sie all Ihre
Probleme. Aber sie größer und größer zu machen, hat sie mehr plausibel gemacht,
aber nicht mehr ehrlich.
Was die Leute jetzt tatsächlich versuchen, ist, was ich Neuro-Symbolik-A.I. oder Hybrid-A.I.
Nennen, von klassischen künstlichen Intelligenz und versuchen,
sie mit den Sprachmodellen zu verbinden, die sie realisieren,
dass sie inhaltlich verfehlt sind.
Es ist also so, dass das Microsoft-System nicht nur ein großes Sprachmodell
wie Chat-GPT ist, und das hat auch einige Komplikationen, weil sie einige Dinge hinzugefügt haben.
Sind wir dann an einem Punkt jetzt angelangt, wo wir erst einmal festhalten
sollten, das ist ein ziemlich gutes Programm, das da geschrieben wurde,
dass diese Möglichkeit hat, Sprache zu erkennen,
sie selbst zu verfassen, dass aber eigentlich uns diese ganzen Diskussionen
über hat die KI ein Bewusstsein, weiß sie von sich selbst, richtet sie,
weiß ich nicht was an, dass das eigentlich etwas ist,
Was uns an einen Punkt führt, wo wir der KI etwas zusprechen,
was sie nicht haben kann oder was dann wirklich die Stanford Science Fiction Träume sind.
Ja, aber dieses, also dass jetzt Menschen nochmal getriggert werden über Wahrhaftigkeit
und Wahrheit zu reden, ist ja auch,
es geht auch hier um ganz andere Fragestellungen, was weiß ich, prompt.
Ich bin einen Tag in Rom. Welche drei Sehenswürdigkeiten sollte ich denn mir anschauen?
Also da geht es ja schon noch um Wahrheit, weil wenn die sagen,
der Eiffelturm wäre gut, dann hättest du ein Problem, den zu finden.
Ja genau, aber am Ende geht es doch darum, dass mir das Ding Hinweise gibt auf
Könnteste, dass ich die dann selber mit Google Maps und nochmal gucke,
wie lang ist der Fußweg, kann ich da auch eine S-Bahn nehmen und so.
Klar können wir jetzt in drei Jahren, wenn wir dann irgendwie GPT 8 oder so
und dann ist das auch noch mit reingelernt, dass dann solche Probleme funktionieren.
Aber erst mal ist es doch mehr so eine Inspirations- als eine Informationsmaschine.
Weil Informationsmaschinen, wir haben doch die Google-Suche,
die bei sehr vielen Prompts, und das hat ja der Dings auch angemerkt von OpenAI,
für sehr viele Sachen, für die wir GPT jetzt nutzen, könnten wir auch einfach
die Google-Suche nutzen.
Aber die Sinnhaftigkeit, Zusammenhänge noch mal sich darziehen zu lassen oder
einen großen Bogen zu spannen, Dafür wird das doch recht, also ich sehe jedenfalls recht häufig.
Auch in diesen Twitter-Threads, wo immer die zehn besten Prompts und so weiter.
Da werden doch die wirklich witzigen und wichtigen Sachen, die einem im Leben
auch so ein bisschen weiterhelfen. Und die haben mit Wahrheit so wenig zu tun am Ende.
Sondern da geht es ja nur um Hinweisgebung, Inspiration und so weiter.
Ja, das ist auch die Idee von einigen IT-Lern, die sich dazu geäußert haben.
Die sagten, eigentlich muss man es als eine fiktionale Hilfe wahrnehmen,
als eine Hilfe, die einen lösen kann von einer Schreibblockade.
Aber wer jetzt Fakten sucht, sollte eher da nicht hingehen.
In so einem Rohdatensatz gibt es nicht irgendwie das, was Fakt von Fiktion trennen kann.
Sondern da hat man dann diese Wertigkeit von entsprechenden Daten.
Und dann kann man das über Wahrscheinlichkeit herstellen.
Ich hatte ja im Salon sehr ausführlich diesen Text vorgestellt.
Im letzten Salon über, wie diese Spracherlernung überhaupt stattgefunden hat
von KI aus Spektrum Wissenschaft.
Das ist ja ganz interessant. Aber ich glaube, wenn man es als eine Möglichkeit
betrachtet, die Kreativität ein bisschen in Gang zu setzen, dann ist das gut.
Aber das reduziert ja das, was diese Leute, die die KI gerade entwickeln,
da hinein projizieren und von ihr warnen.
Das reduziert das ja sehr, sehr stark. Also ich habe den Eindruck,
dass man mit diesen mahnenden Briefen oder auch mit den Clips,
mit den mit den ganzen Auftritten,
die diese Entwickler hatten, du hattest ja diese Clips mitgebracht,
dass wir damit jetzt sehr stark auf so ein Investoren-Marketing-Sprech hereinfallen
und wir eigentlich gar nicht so sehen,
dass wir es vielleicht nicht mit der ganz großen Zeitenwende zu tun haben.
Oder vielleicht ist es eine...
Entwicklungen, die jetzt sicherlich Fahrt aufnehmen wird, aber dass man jetzt
gleich glaubt, die ganze Welt ist auf den Kopf gestellt und wir werden keine
Künste und nichts mehr brauchen.
Das, glaube ich, ergibt sich daraus nicht.
Also Israel Klein war bei Hard Fork, bei Kevin Spacey und Kevin Roos,
dem sehr guten Podcast zum Thema.
Und hat da auch nochmal angemerkt, und das finde ich auch immer wieder gut,
bei allen politischen Diskussionen, bei allen Zukunftserwartungen,
was bedeutet das und so weiter, kann man sich ja selber überlegen,
hab ich selber schon mal GPT genutzt?
Wenn ja, bezahl ich dafür? Und wann hab ich's eigentlich zuletzt benutzt?
Und bei 99 Prozent der Leuten ist es doch so, dass sie sich diesen Account klicken,
weil sie's interessant finden, und dann spielen sie mal damit rum.
Aber es gibt im Alltag im Grunde keine Situation, in der man denkt,
jetzt frag ich mal GPT. Also, da muss schon noch einiges passieren.
Und entsprechend ist diese ganze Relevanz ja auch nicht überzubewerten.
Man darf halt nur nicht jedem Gespräch und so weiter, sondern man muss dann
mal sein eigenes Verhalten sich anschauen und da muss man sagen,
ja, wir googeln jeden Tag hunderttausendmal,
aber GPT, da haben wir jetzt nicht wirklich einen Bedarf.
MARKUS TRANTOW Margaret Mitchell ist KI-Expertin, die sagt, Chat-GPT ist großartig
für einige Dinge, wie zum Beispiel
eine Schreibblockkarte zu lösen oder kreative Ideen zu entwickeln.
Sie wurde nicht entwickelt, um sachlich zu sein und wird daher auch nicht sachlich sein.
It's as simple as that.
Ja, das finde ich gut.
Ist denn GPT zu vogue? Ich habe das ja eben hier mit meinen blonden Schauspielerinnen erzählt.
Er hat mir sogar erzählt, dass er auf der Linken war und nicht mehr da ist.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, was er über Zahlen oder über die Bildung denken könnte.
Nicht alle meine Vorstellungen sind richtig, aber es wird eine interne Konsistenz geben.
Vielleicht wird sich das über die Zeit ändern. Der Chat ist nicht wirklich so.
Es gibt Mechanismen, die es zur Linken machen, wie das Screening,
das von Menschen-Moderatoren gemacht wurde, um es weniger skandalös zu machen.
Aber es ist auch eine Funktion aller verrückten Sachen, und so weiter.
Und es geht nicht um Rechnung über Politik.
Ja, das finde ich noch mal sehr gut herauszuarbeiten, dass es um die Menschen geht,
die Entscheidungen treffen darüber, was jetzt nicht mehr geht oder noch geht
und dass es nicht GPT ist,
denn hier wird noch mal deutlich, das Ding versteht nichts,
sonst würde es erkennen an den Fragen,
die ich zuvor gestellt habe zum Thema Schauspieler und so, dass es mir offenbar
jetzt nicht darum geht, blonde Schauspielerinnen auf ihr Blondsein zu reduzieren,
sondern ich wollte eine Information haben.
Da die das aber nicht verstehen, sondern das einfach nur einprogrammiert ist,
oder von den menschlichen Gatekeeper so organisiert ist, dass wenn solche Fragen
kommen, Obacht, lieber nochmal so einen Hinweis mitgeben, das zeigt ja sehr
deutlich, dass GPT selbst nichts begreift.
Genau. Und da, finde ich, ist auch die interessantere Frage,
zeigt GPT mir bei gleichen Prompt was anderes an als anderen?
Tut's ja. Das hatten wir ja auch bei Facebook, dass dann plötzlich,
ah ja, du bist ein demokratisch registrierter Wähler, na dann zeigen wir dir mal das und das.
Und wie das dann wiederum ausgebeutet wurde von Wahlkämpfern,
die dann gezielt Publikum ansprachen.
Diese Diskussion müsste man sich nochmal anschauen. Aber dazu wissen wir einfach
zu wenig, wie GPT so funktioniert einfach.
Also ob da schon, kann man natürlich vergleichende Studien machen,
drei Leute sitzen sich mit unterschiedlichen IP-Adressen mal nebeneinander und
geben mal den gleichen Prompt ein und dann müsste man diese Differenzen sich mal anschauen.
Ja, auch das Halluzinieren fällt ja mal so mal so aus. Das scheint wohl schon ein Phänomen zu sein.
Was ich auch wichtig finde, was er hier betont ist, dass wir ja den Kontext
immer mitbedenken können, wenn wir einen Menschen erleben und dann auch einen Satz verstehen.
Er beschreibt das ja gerade, wie er jetzt diesen Kieftier einordnen kann,
weil er so in etwa weiß, der war mal links und ist jetzt so und so.
Dann wird er vermutlich die Haltung zum Thema Steuern haben.
Und so können wir das ja auch ständig machen.
Das heißt, wir müssen ja auch deswegen ganz viel hier nicht mehr sagen. Wir haben es ja mal.
Na, wir machen das. Wir hatten es doch mal als Beispiel, dass wir das so amüsant fanden,
dass jeder Politiker in einer Talkshow immer sagt,
Der brutale völkerrechtswidrige Angriff,
so als müsse man immer noch mal das deutlich machen, dass man nicht ein Putin-Fan
ist, während wir jetzt auch einfach mal sagen können, der Krieg,
ohne dass man gleich noch mal sich dreimal erklären muss dem Publikum gegenüber.
Jaja, wir finden den Krieg auch nicht gut und mögen Putin auch nicht.
Also sehr viel Kommunikation findet ja ausschließlich online statt.
Menschen begegnen sich immer noch klar und so, gehen in die gleichen Klassenzimmer,
gleichen Kneipen und so, aber...
Große politische Diskurse auf Twitter, auf Reddit, wie auch immer.
Es wäre doch supercool, wenn man in jedem Twitter-Profil so einen Button hat,
wo einfach alle Tweets, die jemals von dem Nutzer geschrieben wurden,
ausgewertet sind hinsichtlich seiner politischen Haltung.
Und da wüsste ein Computer viel mehr über den einzelnen Nutzer,
als selbst wenn man den Menschen persönlich kennt, wäre man,
glaube ich, noch überrascht, was jemals getwittert wurde von dieser Person vor
7 Jahren, vor 14 Jahren usw.
Und da würde ich sagen, kann so ein.
Willst du in so einer Welt leben?
Nee, aber ich will nur darauf hinweisen, so eine künstliche Intelligenz.
Wir haben ja hier, muss ich mal hier verraten, wir haben ja hier jemanden sitzen,
der alle sieben Tage alle Tweets löscht.
Und die kann dann auch GPT nicht mehr auswerten. Aber hinsichtlich,
naja, wenn ich einem Menschen echt begegne, sehe ich ja noch den Kontext,
den ich ansonsten nicht sehe.
In der digitalen Kommunikation sieht der Computer viel mehr Kontext,
nämlich einfach alles, was potenziell zur Verfügung steht. Also zumindest alles,
was mal publiziert wurde von der Person. Das ist ganz schön viel nach 20 Jahren
Social Media oder kann viel sein.
Also da weiß die Maschine mehr über uns als wir.
Nur weil wir mal mit jemandem geschrieben haben oder so und dann denken,
wir können da jetzt was einschätzen.
Also da sollte man auch keine falschen Vorstellungen haben, was die CIA aufgrund
des Datenbestandes, wir wissen ja, wie wütig die sammeln durch Snowden,
was die mittlerweile wissen und wie sie sich das auswerten können,
als das, was wir so erfahren.
Nun, der Vergleich war ja hier eher einer, der sagt, wir können...
Rückschlüsse ziehen aufgrund von Informationen, die wir haben und hier kann
nur eine Wahrscheinlichkeit hergestellt werden.
Ja, wir machen auch nur Wahrscheinlichkeiten. Nur nicht so mathematisch runtergehen,
aber wir gehen auch nur so danach Gefühl.
Aber unser Denken geht ja anders vor, als das von GPT. Also das von GPT sagt
ja, wir kommen da jetzt gleich zu, sonst mache ich das also,
es gab einen ganz wunderbaren Podcast von Freunden von uns, nämlich Corporate Therapy.
Dort war Jürgen Goiter, genannt Tante, zu Gast und hat über ChatGPT gesprochen
und mir auch aus der Seele gesprochen. Wir hören da mal rein.
Das Ding generiert einfach nur Tokens. Und wir wissen bei gerade bei ChatGPT,
das generiert ja halt auch mit der größten, jemand nannte es mal Mansplaining as a Service.
So das Ding hat halt keine Ahnung von irgendwas, aber sitzt breitbeinig und
behauptet die Wahrheit zu kennen.
So geht das Ding halt vor. Und das ist jetzt ein bisschen besser geworden,
weil sie halt manuell so Schranken eingezogen haben.
Sie generieren halt keine URLs mehr, die es nicht gibt. Das filtern sie halt
raus und generieren halt nochmal, bis sie halt eine finden, die es wirklich gibt.
Aber das Ding kann auf alles reagieren, weil ihm egal ist, was es sagt.
Es generiert halt Struktur. Das hat ja kein Konzept davon, was es tut.
Es ist ihm egal, was es sagt. Ist ja schon wieder eine Personifizierung,
die komplett unangemessen ist.
Ja. Das würfelt halt, ja, jetzt kommt halt ein Human. Jetzt kommt halt ein Sitz.
Jetzt kommt halt ein Form, jetzt kommt halt ein Mikro.
Okay, whatever. Ob du vom Mikro sitzt oder nicht ist dem Ding halt egal.
Was human ist, ist ihm ja auch egal. Was Mikro ist, weiß es auch nicht.
Das neuronale Netz selber generiert einfach nur Zahlen. Und durch diese Embeddings
und so weiter wird daraus dann später wieder irgendeine Form von Text generiert.
Aber das Ding rechnet einfach nur rum und sagt, ja 17, 14 Millionen und zwei.
Nothing means anything.
Gilt aber auch für das, was Goiter hier sagt. Es hat keinen Sinn,
das zu wissen, dass es so ist.
Ich finde schon, dann fällt man doch nicht mehr auf diese Elon Musk Reden,
Long Termism, wir updaten uns jetzt als Menschheit, damit wir für die nächsten 5000 Jahre da sind.
Aber die Frage, ob du das interessant, faszinierend oder glaubwürdig findest,
ist ja wirklich unentscheidend von der Sachdimension, das sind ja so Glaubensfragen.
Die Aufklärung gegen Verschwörungstheorien, die ja überall auch so Sinnhaftigkeiten
unterstellen, ist ja, wird ja immer wieder jetzt betont, nicht die Sachaufklärung,
sondern die Beziehungsgestaltung und so weiter und so fort und so ist das hier auch.
Aber wir haben doch eine grundsätzliche andere Herangehensweise,
wenn wir AI von Anfang an profanieren.
Also wir müssen ja nicht noch mal diesen Umweg gehen, dass wir sagen,
oh, es donnert. Das muss wohl der liebe Gott sein, der wütend ist.
Sondern wir können jetzt sagen, so entsteht Donner.
Und wir können doch in gleicher Weise jetzt auch sagen,
ja, das ist nicht irgendeine Zauberei und da denkt nicht irgendein Wesen,
sondern das ist der in der Art programmiert, dass es auf Wahrscheinlichkeit
aussieht, dass es da eine gewisse Temperatur gibt an Kreativität.
Also diese Temperatur kann man auch hineinprogrammieren.
Wie viel Halluzination darf es denn sein, wenn es nicht 100% sicher ist?
Ja, aber das profaniert das Ganze doch. Und ich will einen Verdacht äußern.
Ich habe es ja hier mir gegenüber mit einem Systemtheoretiker zu tun.
Es gibt ja von Luhmann diese Aussage, SINN,
ist auch nur ein anderes Wort für Komplexitätsreduktion.
So in etwa.
Also Systemtheoretiker gehen sehr davon aus, dass also wo gerade das Objekt
Sinn herstellt, einfach nur Komplexität reduziert.
Und könnte es sein, dass du so fasziniert bist von diesem AI-Modell,
weil es tatsächlich diese menschliche Sinnstruktur, die jetzt Goethe beschreibt
oder die jetzt auch Gary F.
Marcus beschrieben haben, völlig ausklingt, weil die Frage nur ist,
ist es wahrscheinlich, dass auf den Buchstaben der nächste folgt?
Also ich habe ja das letzte Mal ausdrücklich und explizit meine Luhmann-Dinger
mit eingeführt und will nochmal darauf hinweisen, wir haben es hier mit Computern
zu tun, die kommunizieren.
Und wir haben es bei der Systemtheorie von Luhmann mit einer Theorie zu tun,
die einfach sagt, es ist egal, was da passiert, es wird kommuniziert.
Dass da Menschen teilnehmen, wir blenden Menschen aus.
Von mir aus können auch elektronische Personen an der Kommunikation teilnehmen.
Wenn wir Social Media benutzen, ob wir jetzt mit dem Menschen auf der anderen
Seite des Computers kommunizieren oder eigentlich nur mit der Maschine,
indem wir einfach so weiter scrollen.
Ja, wir denken ja immer, ah, ich habe jetzt eine Kommunikation mit dem Model,
das mir auf Instagram angezeigt wird. Nee, ich habe eine Kommunikation mit der Maschine.
Inhaltlich findet da ein Model statt. Und dann kannst du ein Auto,
eine Frau oder was auch immer.
Sobald du ja weißt, dass es nicht ein Mensch ist, ist deine Kommunikation ja
eine andere. Also du würdest ja zum Beispiel jederzeit mit einem Menschen in
einen erotischen Chat gehen, wenn dir danach ist.
Aber wenn das jetzt eine Maschine wäre, also wenn das Chachipiti jetzt machen
würde, da gibt es ja Schranken, dass das nicht passieren kann,
aber nehmen wir mal an, Chachipiti wäre da schrankenlos, dann würdest du das
nicht als Ersatz vorziehen.
Ja, aber Erotik ist ja auf einem speziellen sozialen Felde eine...
Durchaus tragende und angestrebte Rationalität, aber nicht in der Wirtschaft,
nicht in der Politik. Da geht es um Macht und Profite.
Und wenn die wachsen, wenn die generiert werden, habe ich erfolgreiche Kommunikation
mit wem und mit welchen Mitteln und mit was.
Das ist wirklich unerheblich. Und deswegen habe ich ja GPT auch hervorgehoben
noch mal als, wir werden so ein bisschen auch zurückgeworfen in diese Zeit,
in der wir in den Wald gingen und mit Bäumen kommuniziert haben.
Weil irgendwie muss doch der Gott mit uns kommunizieren, also macht das über
die Bäume. So. Es steckt eine Sinnhaftigkeit drin, alleine weil ich unterstelle,
dass mein Verstehen folgenreich ist.
Aber die Projektion ist ja eine, die von dir aus auf die Maschine kommt.
Ich habe diesen Podcast mit Jürgen Goethe auch gehört und habe danach so einen
kleinen lustigen Text, also lustig gemeint, aber als Analogie an Human geschrieben.
Angenommen, wir hören ja gleich noch ein paar Clips, wir können das dann mal überprüfen.
Angenommen, Sie hätten dort nicht über GPT, sondern über Kaffeemaschinen geschredet,
dann hätte Jürgen Goiter wahrscheinlich sowas gesagt wie, was die Menschen nicht
verstehen ist, dass auch diese Maschine das Wasser nur auf 100 Grad erhitzt.
Man hat aber Wasser immer nur auf 100 Grad erhitzt. Auch damals,
als man noch offenes Feuer hatte und der Topf noch selber geschweißt werden
musste, hat man Wasser nur mit 100 Euro, nur auf 100°C erhitzt. und künftig bei...
Und dann GPT-8 wird man auch nur auf 100 Grad das Wasser erhitzen und man wird
den Leuten sagen, der Tee wird aber anders schmecken, aber sie werden nicht
wissen, dass er auch nur mit 100 Grad erhitzt wurde, man kann nämlich Wasser
gar nicht heißer erhitzen, also man kann diese Dramatisierung, die da drin steckt.
Wir verstehen die Blackbox nicht, aber ich kläre euch jetzt mal auf darüber,
dass da eigentlich gar kein Zauber drin steckt. Kann man ins Unendliche treiben,
den Leuten hat schon immer ihr Kaffee geschmeckt und er wird ihn auch weiterhin
schmecken und es wird Kaffeemaschinen geben, die für 8000 Euro verkauft werden, so wie damals schon.
Und das hat einen echten Einfluss in der echten Welt. Also es prägt einfach
echte Sozialität zwischen menschlicher Natur. Und in der Hinsicht...
Die möchte ich gar nicht widersprechen. Also das ist definitiv so.
Und Goiter sagt ja auch an einer Stelle sehr klar, er hat die große Befürchtung,
dass Chattipiti eingesetzt werden wird oder andere Bots eingesetzt werden für
gerade Leistungen, die nicht mehr erbracht werden.
Ich frage mich dann, wann kommt der Mental Health Coach in Form von GPT?
Er ist dann zwar nicht wirksam, Aber er muss dann für die armen Leute herhalten,
die sich eh kein Therapieplatz...
Alena Böx hat sich sehr dafür ausgesprochen in der Bundesbasis.
Ja, das ist völlig falsch. Gerade in der Therapie geht es ja nur darum,
das ist ja ein Beispiel, das ich heute auch bringe, dass man mit einem Menschen spricht.
Es ist ja nicht die Frage, dass man irgendwie eine Antwort sucht.
Also in dem Sinne eine Antwort wie, wo steht es denn bei Heidegger?
Und du sagst mir Seite 207, sondern bei der Therapie geht es darum,
mit einem Menschen sprechen kann.
Und dass Alena Böx, die natürlich alles Empathische ja völlig hinter sich gelassen
hat, wie wir aus ihren diversen Talkshow-Auftritten wissen und ihrer Position zu Corona und Co.
Da wundert mich das gar nicht. Also bei Alena Böx würde ich auch sagen,
ja, bitte gib mir lieber Chachipiti.
Tristan Harris hat ja diesen ganz interessanten Fall drin, Snapchat.
Du hast eine riesige Freundesliste an Snapchat-Kontakten, schreibst die an, keiner antwortet.
Und in dieser Liste taucht auch ein GPT-artiger Counterpart auf,
wird jetzt schon eingebaut, der einfach immer reagiert, mit dem du immer chatten kannst.
Und meine Vermutung ist, den Leuten wird ziemlich schnell egal sein, mit wem sie da chatten
Und sie werden relativ zügig erst so richtig ausblenden und dann auch es vielleicht
sogar wohlwollend annehmen,
dass jemand reagiert, der gerade kein echter Mensch ist, mit dem sie trotzdem
eine inhaltliche, was auch immer, führen können. Und äh...
Ich weiß, ich rede zu oft über Westworld und so, aber in Westworld werden den
Leuten menschenähnliche Roboter gegeben mit der Ansage, du weißt aber,
dass das keine echten Menschen sind.
Tu also alles mit ihnen, was du dich nicht traust, mit echten Menschen zu machen.
Und plötzlich bezahlen Leute 30.000 Dollar am Tag dafür, in einen Freizeitpark
zu gehen, wo ihnen vorgegaukelt wird, wohlwissend, sie haben die Aufklärung.
Das sind Menschen und sie können sich einmal emotional und gefühlsmäßig ausleben,
die Rationalität ausblenden und sich so richtig an diesen Geräten vergehen.
Weshalb dann auch der Running Gag ist, dass da natürlich nur Sex und nur Gewalt stattfindet.
Also keiner dieser Roboter überlebt den Tag. Die werden, man bucht sich da ein,
um diese, den ganzen Roboter totzuschießen. Und man macht es aber trotzdem wohlwissend.
Anderes Beispiel Filme. Wir gehen ins Kino und wissen, das ist ein Drehbuch.
Wir haben den Schauspieler auch noch schon in anderen Rollen gesehen.
Wir wissen, das ist wirklich nicht echt. Leute brechen den Trennungs.
Ja, aber da haben wir eine Trennung. Das ist eine ästhetische Erfahrung,
die anders, glaube ich, zu beurteilen ist als diese.
Mal sehen.
Also es gibt seit ich eigentlich über solche Dinge nachdenke,
gibt es jede Woche irgendeinen Bericht darüber, wie toll die neuesten Sexpuppen jetzt inzwischen sind.
Und ich dachte, wie formuliere ich es am besten, genau, wir haben heute für
bezahlbares Geld kann man sich,
Sexpuppen kaufen, die angenehmer anzufassen sind und wohlproportionierter sind
als ein überwiegender Teil der Menschen.
Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2017,
Ja, also Schönheitsideale haben aber keinen allgemeinen Maßstab.
Ja, genau, haben keinen allgemeinen Maßstab, aber man würde sagen,
toll, hier kann ich Puppe haben, die ist immer, weiß ich nicht, 24 und was weiß ich.
Und trotzdem gibt es keinen Boom da. Also irgendwo mag es da ein paar Leute
mehr geben, die das jetzt kaufen. Und ja, es gibt dann immer diese Dokumentationen
von irgendjemand, der seit zehn Jahren mit irgendeiner Puppe zusammenlebt.
Aber es gibt am Ende keinen Buben da und man würde am Ende doch immer sagen okay,
hat zwar Falten oder ist auch ein bisschen vielleicht nicht mehr so in der Form
oder was auch immer und würde trotzdem immer den Menschen präferieren und würde
niemals sagen, ich nehme lieber die Puppe. Das ist so.
Du hast ein Kapitel in deinem Buch geschrieben über Oxytocin.
Die Menschen wollen diese Begegnung. Wenn du sagst, das Gespräch, ja.
Ich bin zum Zum Beispiel, ich bin ja viel alleine unterwegs,
lass mich das mal auskennen, ich bin ja viel alleine unterwegs,
wenn ich irgendwie auf Vortragsreise bin, dass ich dann irgendwo noch im Hotel rumhänge oder was.
Natürlich kann ich jederzeit fernmündlich Kontakt herstellen mit Menschen,
die mir wichtig sind, aber manchmal ist es auch einfach schön,
dass ich in der Bar noch mit irgendjemanden da ganz kurz einen kleinen Wortwechsel
habe oder in einem Geschäft, was auch immer.
Und das würde aber, also mir ersetzt das dann diese Begegnung schon nicht,
das Telefonat mit einem guten Freund, das ich führen könnte.
Geschweige denn, könnte ich jetzt mich begnügen damit, mit einem Chatbot zu kommunizieren.
Wir sind hier aber wieder in dieser Domäne Erotik, Beziehungen.
Ja, von welcher Domäne sprechen wir denn? Also ich brauche natürlich jetzt keine
menschliche Stimme, Um zu fragen, wo kann ich die Reklamation abgeben?
Das kann sicherlich ein Chatbot machen.
In der lumanschen Systemtheorie gibt es die symbiotischen Mechanismen.
Alle Funktionssysteme, die wir kennen, haben irgendeinen Bezug auf den Körper selbst.
Du warst ja vorhin auch schon und bist jetzt wieder in der Domäne Erotik,
körperliche Befriedigung, sexuelle Befriedigung, da, wo dann auch Oxytocin eine Rolle spielt.
Das verbuchen wir mal unter Familie, so grob.
Daneben hast du aber Wirtschaft, dann zum Beispiel Gesundheit,
da ist der körperliche Bezug ja klar, Politik.
Bei der Politik geht es darum, Gewalt zu vermeiden, also aus einer Gewaltanwendung
eine Drohmacht zu machen und mit relativ wenig Staat so viel Drohpotenzial aufzubauen,
dass Leute sich an Gesetze halten, weil sie nämlich die Vermeidungsalternative,
ansonsten werde ich von der Polizei zusammengeknüppelt und weggesperrt,
weggesperrt, einfach vermeiden.
Jetzt könnte man sagen, in der Domäne Familie hat der Roboter als Sechsmaschine
keine große Konjunktur. Das stimmt.
In der Wirtschaft, wenn es darum geht, Knappheiten zu regulieren,
Supermärkte zu bestücken, jemanden mit Geld zu versorgen und so weiter,
hat da der Computer und der Roboter Konjunktur.
Aber hallo, du hast Fabriken, in denen gar kein Mensch mehr drin ist.
Da wird schon gar kein Licht mehr eingeschaltet, weil da nur noch Roboter werkeln.
Du hast Supermärkte, wo ein Computer dir vorgibt, wie die bestückt werden sollen und so weiter.
Also in der Wirtschaft hast du totale Erfolge mit Sexroboter-Äquivalenten,
was den symbiotischen Mechanismus Knappheitsüberwindung angeht.
Im Gesundheitswesen, klar, die Oper der Revolution in der Pflege fällt aus,
aber wenn du den medizinischen Fortschritt, also der wird nicht mehr von Menschen
gemacht, das sind diese selbstnährenden Maschinen, da kommt dann Google und
faltet dir die Proteine und so weiter, da haben wir tolle Hörerkommentare schon
bekommen, wie weit das da getrieben ist.
In der Politik, die Generierung von politischer Unterstützung,
Wahlkämpfe waren ganz lange, und es ist immer noch wichtig, dieser Häusertür-Wahlkampf,
die Raumgebundenheit, dass der Kandidat vor Ort ist und man ihn anfassen kann
und Hände schütteln, Autogramme holen und so weiter, stimmt.
Aber selbst in Frankfurt am Main haben ein Prozent der Wähler wirklich mal Mike
Joseph und Uwe Becker vor der Wahl gesehen. Der Rest läuft über Wahlprogramme,
Social-Media-Auftritte.
Vermittlung mit Hilfe von Technik zwischen Wähler und auch Gang und Gebe.
Also ja, es gibt diese eine Domäne, aber es ist ja nicht nur die Domäne Familie,
sondern man kann eigentlich auch Privatleben, Privatleben.
Ich würde sagen so Familie, Bildung, Privatleben, Pflege so als Besonderes.
Aber wenn du ganz groß Wirtschaft, ganz groß Politik, Gesundheitssystem,
dass wir alle doppelt so lange leben wie vor 100 Jahren und so weiter.
Da hast du einfach, also da ist der Computer eh schon etabliert.
Die Frage ist jetzt, was kommt als nächste Stufe, wenn man jetzt einen etwas
klügeren Computer, der, ja, wo diese ganze Gewichtung von der Mensch muss eine
Programmiersprache lernen. Nee, der Computer muss die menschliche Sprache lernen.
Was dieser Shift jetzt bedeutet.
Aber dass der Computer und Roboter und Automatisierung da eine Rolle spielen,
das ist ja schon seit Jahrzehnten geklärt.
Nur brauche ich ja in dieser Sphäre gar nicht so eine Idee von,
ich baue da einen persönlichen Bezug zu auf oder sonst etwas,
also weil ja immer diese Beispiele gebracht werden von der Chatbot,
du hast ja eben selbst gesagt, der Chatbot, der mir dann antwortet und ich bin
froh, dass mir wenigstens einer antwortet, wenn meine Freunde es nicht tun.
Ich glaube, das mag für manche, die in einer sehr traurigen Situation sind,
dann vielleicht gerade hilfreich sein, aber das wird auch nicht auf Dauer einen tragen können.
Und es gibt ja entsprechende Chat-Angebote auch im Internet,
die zu nutzen sind. Also man kann immer die ganze Zeit mit irgendjemandem kommunizieren,
ja, das ist schon möglich.
Aber ich glaube, dass wir doch jetzt hier bei der Sphäre der Wirtschaft vor allem um,
ein tool reden das sicherlich im hohen maße disruptiv ist das aber nicht gleich
alles verändert in der mensch technik beziehung.
Ich sage ja auch nicht morgens wenn ich meinen laptop hochklappe na guten morgen
mein lieber wie geht's denn oder so sondern ich mache die maschine halt an und
genauso werden auch leute in der autoindustrie oder in biotech oder sonst wo werden.
Chat-GPT werden andere Programme nutzen, ohne irgendwelche Gefühle dabei zu
haben, sondern sie nutzen es, wie sie jetzt auch irgendeine App nutzen, um was zu bestellen.
Also Jürgen Goiter, für ihn ist so dieses Oppenheimer-Paradigma,
sie werden es erst akzeptieren, wenn sie es verstehen, sie werden es erst verstehen, wenn sie es sehen.
Dieses, man muss ihnen die Blackbox einmal erzählen vorher, also beschreiben
ihnen richtig so ein Bildungsprogramm.
Jeder muss erst das GPT Seminar, um dann zu akzeptieren, nee,
die Leute werden die Resultate einfach akzeptieren. Das machen sie schon immer.
Wenn der Computer was sagt, ist das gesetzt.
Wie man ja dahin fährt, wo es Navi einem sagt.
Genau.
Wenn es dann nicht gerade der Fluss vor der Nase ist, dann wird man vielleicht
nochmal vorher bremsen.
Und in deren Sicht überfordert oder wie soll man sagen,
überfordert, also Goiter ist ja auch zum einen so zynisch und zum anderen auch
so eine Enttäuschung die ganze Zeit drüber.
Ja über den Menschen, ich bin auch über den Menschen enttäuscht.
Vielleicht haben wir uns da getroffen, aber wir müssen mal weiter.
Die Enttäuschungsdinger werden noch wachsen bei ihm, glaube ich.
Was macht das auch mit unseren Systemen, die Qualität sichern sollen?
Wenn wir sie halt alle nur noch fluten mit Spam. Wir denken bei Spam immer an
E-Mails und an hier Websitespam und SEO, was auch immer. Das ist auch ein Riesenproblem, natürlich.
Aber wenn du jetzt plötzlich so viel Shit generieren kannst,
dass JournalistInnen eigentlich auch nicht mehr in der Lage sind,
so richtig durchzugucken. Okay, what's what?
Wenn unsere Verfahren, die darüber entscheiden sollen, wer kriegt denn vielleicht
eine Geldförderung, überflutet werden mit Dingen und einfach sagen müssen,
okay, winke, winke, ich bin raus. Und die einzige Lösung, die die noch haben,
ist zu sagen, okay, ich kaufe mir jetzt bei Capgemini eine KI ein,
die das für mich vorfiltert.
Das ist halt absolut toxisch für unser Zusammenleben.
Das kann man sagen, gut, das zeigt halt, dass der Prozess, den wir ursprünglich
schon gemacht haben, wahrscheinlich auch ein bisschen Bullshit ist.
Genau. Völlig richtig. Wenn Leute mal sagen, ja, jetzt können wir ja gar nicht
mehr unsere blöden Aufgaben in der Schule stellen.
Ja, die Aufgaben waren schon immer blöd und die müssen auch weg.
Hören wir halt der Scheiße auf. Warum zwingen wir Kinder dumme Sachen zu machen,
nur, weil man es einfach korrigieren kann oder einfach bewerten kann. Ja, hör auf damit.
Wenn das aus diesen ganzen Textgeneratoren kommt, bin ich ja sehr happy.
Da wäre ich auch glücklich. Und wir hatten mal über Bullshitjobs gesprochen,
über David Cravers Buch im Salon und dann hatte ich damals gesagt,
ich habe ja auch mal einen gemacht und habe dann von so einer Begehung der DFG
an der Universität erzählt und wie verrückt lang diese Anträge waren und all das.
Und da würde ich auch sagen, man muss jetzt eigentlich DFG und Co.
Diese ganzen Institutionen fluten mit Chat-TBT.
So wie Verlage in Amerika.
Bis sie irgendwann sagen, okay, wir hören jetzt mit dieser Scheiße auf.
Wir werden jetzt mal andere Kriterien anlegen und nicht gucken,
ob ein Forschungsantrag 250 Seiten lang ist und 700 Seiten Anhang hat.
Also für diese Form des Axelatarismus, dass man den Botschafter auf die Spitze
treibt, ist Jupyter genau richtig, denn Forschungsanträge schreiben,
zack, würde ich auch sagen.
Ja, ich würde die jetzt so richtig damit und dann auch lieber das Programm,
das kaufen für 20 Euro, das kann man auch richtig mal füttern,
die ganzen Scans, die man schon hat, alle rein und dann die richtig fluten und
dann können die ganzen Professoren bei ihren Begehungen werden ersticken in den Anträgen.
Hörerin kurz sagen, wie man das macht. Mindestens einen Forschungsantrag,
der mal erfolgreich war, nimmt man und den baut man in den Input mit ein.
Und dann sagt man, und den bitte zu diesem Thema, mit diesem Anliegen und so
weiter. Und dann sollte es einfach selber umformulieren.
Das ist unsere neue Exzellenz. Wir hören noch mal Goethe.
Die glauben, dass wir über diese
statistischen Verfahren zu der Artificial General Intelligence kommen.
Und das, was sie aktuell machen, ist sozusagen der Weg dahin,
weil sie sich davor fürchten.
Sie sagen Open AI, heißt ja Open AI, weil sie ursprünglich als gemeinnützige
Organisation gegründet wurden, mit viel Geld von Elon Musk und anderen Millionären
aus diesem Singularitätsumfeld, um eben dieses Problem dieser AGI zu bekämpfen.
Sie sagten, jemand wird AGI entwickeln und vielleicht sind es die bösen Chinesen,
wie auch immer, darf nicht passieren, weil dann werden wir alle unterworfen und Skynet, whatever.
Wir entwickeln das, weil wir sind die Guten. Wir wissen, dass das eine Gefahr
ist und wir werden das so bauen, dass das gut für die Menschen ist.
Und deshalb sind wir Open AI, wir sind nicht profitorientiert,
sondern ausgerichtet am Wohl der Menschheit.
Und nun sieht das Ganze so aus?
Das hat sich geändert. Irgendwann war man plötzlich eben nicht mehr eine Gemeindezügerorganisation,
sondern eine normale Corporation.
Und jetzt vermietet man eben auch diesen Zugang da an der Stelle.
Also da hat sich was verändert.
Aber diese Mission grundsätzlich ist nicht anders geworden. Sie glauben,
Sie bauen die AGI, weil sonst wird es jemand anderes tun und Sie sind die Guten.
Sie behalten das unter Kontrolle. Und ausweichlich. Es gibt keine Alternative
dazu, dass das jemand bauen wird. Der perfekte Marvel-Film.
Wir können uns nicht entscheiden, das nicht zu bauen, sagen Sie.
Und deshalb bauen Sie das, damit es die Guten machen. Mhm. Okay.
Überhaupt zu glauben, dass man auf diesem Weg zu LGI kommt, ist schon auch eine
bisschen skurrile Haltung. Weil, why?
Hier ist halt reduktionistische Weltsicht, ne? Im Grunde, wir reduzieren den
menschlichen Geist auf Gehirnneuronen, die sich gegenseitig mit Nullen oder Einsen befeuern.
Und so ist Gehirn. Genau. Sam Altman, der Chef von OpenAI, sagt,
du bist auch nur ein stochistischer Papagei. Und dann kann sein System es auch.
Ja, da wiederholt sich ja wirklich die Google-Geschichte. Die haben ja auch
gesagt, keine Werbung. Dann kam so ein Business-Typ und hat ihn vorgerechnet,
wie viel Geld sie liegen lassen. Und zack, gab's Werbung.
Und dann hat sich die Google-Geschichte geschrieben.
Dieser stochastische Papagei, der ist ja in aller Munde und der wurde sehr geprägt
durch Emily M. Bender. Wir springen jetzt mal gerade zu diesem Clip zu dem stochastischen
Papagei, um uns das mal ein bisschen erklären zu lassen.
Stochastisch bedeutet also, dass es random ist, aber auf eine Probabilitätsverteilung passend ist.
Und Parrot hier bedeutet, etwas ohne Verständnis zu sagen.
Die Idee ist also, dass diese Systeme, ich denke, wir benutzen die Phrase,
die Wörter aus ihren Trainingsdaten abwägen, weil sie in Bezug auf die Wortverteilung
passen und nicht weil es ein Modell der Welt gibt oder eine Kommunikation von
Intent oder eine Begründung.
Es ist nicht einmal Lügen, weil Lügen eine Beziehung zu der Wahrheit enthält,
die einfach nicht da ist.
Sie hatte ja einen Paper mit anderen Autoren herausgegeben mit dem Titel On
the dangers of stochastic parrots und da heißt es,
der von einem language model erzeugte Text basiert nicht auf einer kommunikativen
Absicht, einem Modell der Welt oder einem Modell des Geisteszustands des Lesers.
Das kann auch nicht sein, denn die Trainingsdaten beinhalten nie den Austausch
von Gedanken mit einem Zuhörer und die Maschine ist auch nicht dazu in der Lage.
Dies mag angesichts der zunehmend flüssigen Qualitäten automatisch generierter
Texte aber wir müssen berücksichtigen,
dass unsere Wahrnehmung natürlich sprachlicher Texte unabhängig davon,
wie sie generiert wurden, durch unsere eigene Sprachkompetenz und unsere Neigung
vermittelt wird, kommunikative Handlungen so zu interpretieren,
als würden sie eine kohärente Bedeutung und Absicht vermitteln,
unabhängig davon, ob dies der Fall ist.
Das Problem ist, wenn eine Seite der Kommunikation keine Bedeutung hat,
der impliziten Bedeutung, eine Illusion, die sich aus unserem singulären menschlichen
Verständnis von Sprache ergibt, wie es erscheinen mag, wenn wir seine Ausgabe beobachten.
Ist ein Language Model ein System,
das wahllose Sequenzen von sprachlichen Formen zusammenfügt,
die es in seinen riesigen Trainingsdaten beobachtet hat, gemäß probabilistischen
Informationen darüber, wie sie kombiniert werden, aber ohne jeglichen Bezug
zur Bedeutung ein stochastischer Papagei.
Ja und da muss ich dann wieder kühl als Fan dieser soziologischen Systemtheorie
sagen, Dieses Nachdenken jetzt über Intention.
Was ist eine Intention, was ist eine Absicht und so weiter und so fort.
Man kommt auch ohne aus, also man kann auch eine Gesellschaftstheorie machen
ohne persönliche Absichten, also dass die eine Rolle spielen irgendwo in diesem
Gefüge an theoretischen Überlegungen und so weiter.
Aber nicht in unserer normalen Kommunikation.
Naja, unsere normale Kommunikation, die ja von uns,
wir nehmen ja als Menschen teil und so, aber wenn du jetzt transkribierst,
was in Organisationen passiert und du legst das später Anwälten vor,
die dann ihrerseits einfach Verquickungen mit, da hat aber jemand Side-Business
aufgezogen und da hat sich jemand bereichert, da sind die Intentionen doch egal.
Da kann man zwar immer noch die Handlung zurechnen, also jemand hat,
aber am Ende kommt es doch da nur darauf an, dass verstanden wird, was passiert.
Und dann nachträglich, also retrospektives Sensemaking,
nachträglich nach juristischem Gesetz, und da ist ja ganz wichtig,
Nichtwissen schützt vor Strafe nicht, oder wie das heißt, ein Gesetz gilt und
kann dir Absichten unterstellen, auch wenn du selbst gar nicht wusstest,
dass es dieses Gesetz gibt Absicht juristisch formuliert ist.
Nun bist du auf Organisationen wieder ausgewichen und ich rede jetzt von unserer
Kommunikation zum Beispiel gerade.
Die ist ja eine, in der wir schon versuchen, die Sätze, die gesprochen werden,
des anderen einzuordnen und auch nach Intentionen zu fragen.
Wenn ich jetzt sage, wir müssen uns mal langsam beeilen, dann denkst du,
oh, der Wolfgang hat wohl die Intention, den Podcast jetzt bald zu beenden,
damit wir was essen gehen können. Das Das ist aber doch zum Beispiel notwendig.
Ja, genau. Da kommen wieder die symbiotischen Mechanismen. Also wir können dann
gucken, nach welcher Rationalität du diese körperlichen Bedürfnisse ausprägst
und welche dann eine Rolle spielen.
Wir kommen dann ganz schnell auf, auch Zeit ist Geld und so,
wenn man es so ein bisschen vulgär macht.
Nein, nein, ich weiß, was du meinst. Und ja, Interaktionen sind immer ein Fall
für sich, wenn man soziologisch ran an die Sache geht, sind Organisationen immer
das Primäre, weil Organisationen sind.
Also da wird, da findet der sozusagen kommunikative Stoffumsatz,
der Stoffwechsel statt.
In Organisationen wird natürlich Interaktion betrieben, aber es ist,
wie es ist. Die Kommunikation wird immer erst von hinten verstanden.
Der Absender kann meinen, was er will. Wenn er nicht verstanden wird,
wird er nicht verstanden. Und dann spielen die Absichten wirklich keine Rolle.
Dann kann man höchstens im Nachhinein noch Fehler attestieren.
Ach so, der wollte das gar nicht, das war unabsichtlich und so weiter.
Ja, aber es hat trotzdem passiert.
Also dieses Verstehen ist ein etwas schwierigeres Konzept und da spielen Intentionen
eine ganz kleine Rolle und wenn jetzt GPT kommt und sagt, ich kommuniziere mal
mit, dann kann die Systemtheorie da sehr gut mit umgehen, dass einfach viel
mehr kommuniziert wird.
Weil das Verstehen findet trotzdem bei denjenigen statt, die und wenn dann Goethe
sagt, die Maschine versteht ja nichts, sie hat ja keine Absichten,
dann können wir zumindest die aus der Gleichung rausnehmen, dass sie vielleicht
auch irgendwann nochmal eine politische Rolle spielen will.
Also da hält sich ja GPT raus. Nein, wir Menschen haben weiter unser Wissen,
weiter die Hoheit über die Absichten.
Das würde aber Elon Musk annehmen. Der versteht das ja offenbar nicht.
Und damit treibt er es ja auch sehr weit.
Oder dann die Leute, die sagen ja, der Mensch ist auch nur ein stochastischer
Papagei. Dann geht man da in eine ähnliche Richtung. Wir hören uns den letzten
Clip an. Und zwar warnt Bender da vor einer Dehumanisierung,
stattfinden kann durch KI.
Und einer davon ist die Idee, dass, wenn wir große Sprachmodelle als stochastische
Pferde nennen, Vielleicht sind auch Menschen stochastische Pferde.
And what I see there is somebody who so desperately wants this thing they've
created to actually be artificial general intelligence,
which is not defined, but it's supposed to be something like human intelligence,
that they're going to minimize what it is to be human to make them the same.
Ja, das ist für mich die größte Gefahr, dass wir unser Chachipiti anpassen.
Ich würde hier auch noch einmal das Buch, das ich schon häufig empfohlen habe,
in den Ring werfen und zwar Next von Miriam Meckel.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr gutes Buch über KI. Das ist ein sehr gutes Buch über
KI, wo sich genau diese Frage stellt. Und das ist ein literarischer Text,
einmal aus der Perspektive des letzten Menschen geschrieben und einmal aus der
Perspektive einer KI geschrieben.
Na, dann sind wir ja direkt beim Thema, was ist Wahrheit?
Durch deine Vorarbeit nun mit GPT fällt es ja vielleicht ein bisschen leichter
für mich, auszudrücken, was ich ausdrücken möchte.
Ich habe also eine Absicht, weiß aber, verstanden wird nur auf der Empfängerseite.
Und jetzt haben wir es ja mit einem Buch zu tun, das wir im Salon lesen werden,
das ich noch nicht gelesen habe. Ich kann also gar nicht spoilern oder sowas,
auch wenn das jetzt sowieso keine Rolle spielen würde.
Dass ein Autor hat, so wie jedes Buch ein Autor hat.
Benjamin von Stuckrad-Bache.
An diesem Benjamin von Stuckrad-Bache werden jetzt verschiedene Fragen hinsichtlich
seiner Absichten herangetragen.
Wie zum Beispiel, ist der gute Freund
im Buch der Döpfner, also ihr guter Freund, den sie als Autor haben?
Sind sie überhaupt der Protagonist dieser Geschichte und so weiter,
wer ist der Echerzähler?
Und dann haben wir ja schon so ein bisschen mitbekommen, dass er sich dann so
ein bisschen rausredet und so. Und ich möchte jetzt...
Hat sicherlich auch juristische Gründe.
Ja, es hat auch juristische Gründe, aber in diesem, gib mir mal deine Version. Ja.
Ganz am Anfang, ich blätter mal auf, ist ja extra eine Seite eingefügt,
die Patrick Barnas nochmal in einer Glosse hervorgehoben hat.
Ich werde diesen Text kurz lesen.
Dieser Roman ist Teil einer inspirierten von verschiedenen realen Ereignissen,
inspiriert von verschiedenen realen Ereignissen.
Er ist jedoch eine hiervon losgelöste und unabhängige fiktionale Geschichte.
Daher erhebt der Roman keinen Anspruch, Geschehnisse und Personen und ihre beruflichen
und privaten Handlungen authentisch wiederzugeben.
Vielmehr hat der Autor ein völlig eigenständiges neues Werk geschaffen.
Es gibt verschiedene juristische Erklärungen dafür, warum man das so macht.
Zum einen, wenn man ein Buch über Julian Reichelt schreibt, hätte er eigentlich
die Rechte an seiner eigenen Person, also an seiner Geschichte, die zu verkaufen.
Warum kommt jetzt hier einfach jemand, bedient sich da an Vorlage und sagt dann,
und jetzt bitte bezahlt mir jetzt 25 Euro und irgendwas pro,
weiß gar nicht, was es kostet.
Also rum, ja.
Ja, also ihr findet so auf wirtschaftlicher Ebene und auf juristischer Ebene
darf man eigentlich einfach so Zitate, von denen man dann einfach nur so grob
behauptet und alle Leser sollen aber eigentlich an Julian Reichelt die ganze Zeit denken.
Oder, und da hat Patrick Bahners darauf hingewiesen, in dieser Glosse,
und das fand ich ganz herausragend.
Elena Witzek hat es ja in ihrer Besprechung auch noch mal gemacht.
Michael Harnfeld ist in der FAZ, um mal nur die FAZ-Autoren zu nennen,
also auf Stuckhardt Bache reingefallen, weil er noch mal geschrieben hat,
ja, aber das ist doch Döpfner und das ist doch Reichelt und so.
Und jetzt hat Stuckhardt Bache einfach reingeschrieben, ein eigenständiges Werk,
das sich also von was eigentlich unterscheidet?
Ah, von einem anderen fiktionalen Werk?
Also wenn wir jetzt von Springer irgendwelche Erklärungen hören,
was wirklich wahr ist, wenn Reichelt demnächst vor Gericht und so weiter darlegt,
was wirklich wahr ist und so weiter. Also der große Streit wird ja nicht zwischen
Stuttgart-Bacher und denen, sondern das machen eher unter sich.
Döpfner gegen Reichelt und wie auch immer.
Anscheinend verklagen sie sich ja schon gegenseitig auf Millionensumme,
weil da irgendwelche und so.
Jetzt kommt, Stuttgart-Bachan sagt, ein eigenständiges Werk,
das sich unterscheidet von einem anderen eigenständigen Werk,
das genau so hinterfragt werden kann, ist es eigentlich real, ist es Fiktion?
Das, was uns Döpfner und Reichelt demnächst als Selbstbeschreibung Springer
darlegen, was ist denn das eigentlich?
Sollen wir da nur, weil die sagen, das ist aber der Springer-Verlag,
über den wir hier reden, da werden ja auch Aussagen, Das ist deren Autofiktion.
Fiktionaler Art gegenübergestellt.
Wo positioniert sich also Stuttgart-Bache? In dieser Welt der Fiktion.
Und das finde ich super clever. Ich empfehle da sehr die Bahners-Glosse noch
mal, weil sie das auch in Kürze auffasst.
Und jetzt ist aber leider passiert, was man so einem Autor selten wünscht,
dass man weiß, ich werde ein Riesenaufhebens mit meinem Buch machen.
Und ich habe so ungefähr die und jene Vorstellung davon, wie das zu diskutieren ist.
Und dann passiert aber folgendes, Journalisten kapern diesen noch nicht angelaufenen Diskurs,
gehen einfach vor den Veröffentlichungszeitraum und publizieren plötzlich einen
Podcast, in dem junge Journalisten die ganze Zeit mir erzählen,
wie toll sie recherchiert haben und wie anstrengend das war,
wie wahrhaftig sie sind, wie viel Wahrheit da drinsteckt.
Wie emotional die Realität sie mitgenommen hat und sie jetzt hoffen,
dass es euch auf den Hörer beträgt. Und wir haben Holger Stark,
der uns die ganze Zeit erzählt, dass sie ganz lange recherchiert haben daran,
Dopfner-Zitate zu veröffentlichen.
Und dann denke ich, habt ihr wirklich so lange recherchiert?
Also wir hören uns das mal an im Über-Medien-Podcast.
Sind die Autoren des, ganz investigativ veröffentlichen wir mal,
Döpfner Zitate, die Jan-Jürgen Reichelt schrieb, sagen aber nicht,
dass das Döpfner Zitate an Reichelt sind, sondern das sind nur Döpfner Zitate,
es sind auch nicht nur SMS oder wie auch immer, das wird ja alles im Unklaren
gehalten, wie die da drüber reden.
Also wir haben keinen besonderen Hass auf die Bild-Zeitung, berichten deshalb
so darüber, sondern es geht einfach darum, guten Journalismus zu machen.
Ich verstehe im Übrigen den Begriff Mitbewerber nicht.
So, das ist doch besonders witzig, oder? Die eine sagt noch,
nee, wir sind ja ganz emotionsbefreit, wir machen nur Journalismus.
Und dann sagt Holger Stark noch, ich verstehe den Begriff Wettbewerber nicht,
die Bild ist doch kein Wettbewerb. Also will ihr doch noch eins mitgeben?
Also wollen die jetzt nicht mit dem Text eins mitgeben oder nicht?
Das ist ja hier, erhebt sozusagen die Aussage von ihr vorher direkt selber wieder auf.
Und die Veröffentlichung erfolgte natürlich dann, weil es Journalismus ist,
nach ganz journalistischen Kriterien.
Die Dinge, die wirklich privat sind, also die komplexe Betreffung,
über die wir vorhin geredet haben, die haben wir wirklich konsequent aussortiert.
Wir haben das auch in unserem Hausjurist natürlich prüfen lassen.
Und das, was wir veröffentlicht haben, das ist nicht nur legal, sondern auch legitim.
Es ist legal und legitim übersetzt in unsere Diktion. Es ist ganz wenig halluziniert.
Die Zitate, die Sie lesen, sind bis auf die Rechtschreibfehler,
Originalzitate, die Döpfner und dann nicht privat, sondern in seine Funktion
als Verlagschef an die Redaktion geschickt hat, um Arbeitsbefehle zu geben.
Die hat ja Chet Chibiti nicht so Rechtschreibfehler.
Ja, daran erkennt man dann auch, wenn man als Professor mal Hausarbeit bekommt.
Und da ist kein Rechtschreibfehler drin. Das war dann Chibiti.
Und es werden einem Zitate zugespielt.
Man behauptet dann einfach, man hätte ganz lange daran gearbeitet.
Also statt einfach nur einen Text durchzuschreiben, der halt unterbrochen ist von Zitaten.
Ich meine, ich weiß nicht genau, wie viele das lesen wie ich,
aber ich springe doch von Zitat zu Zitat. Ich lese auch nicht mal die Formulierung
der Zeitredaktion dazwischen. Mich interessiert auch wirklich nur,
was Döpfner da geschrieben hat.
Und so liest doch eigentlich ein normaler Leser. Also hätte ich den Text direkt
digital gelesen, hätte ich tpt gesagt, sortiere mir mal nur die wörtlichen Zitate
raus, die dort markiert sind. schmeißt den Rest des Textes weg.
Nun gut, aber es ist natürlich ganz legitime, legale und aufwendige Recherchearbeiten.
Wie lange habt ihr denn eigentlich daran gearbeitet insgesamt?
Wir haben da sehr früh angefangen zu recherchieren,
weil uns die Frage von Anfang an umgetrieben hat, welche Rolle eigentlich dieser
Affäre, die da vor knapp zwei Jahren ausgebrochen ist, um Julian Reichelt,
den damaligen Chefredakteur der Bild, welche Rolle Matthias Döpfner da gespielt hat.
Darf ich dir mal eine Frage stellen, hatte ich irgendetwas an den Texten,
die da von Döpfner publiziert wurden, bis auf die Rechtschreibfehler vielleicht,
hat sich da irgendetwas dran gewundert?
Nö, ich fand die aber wahnsinnig amüsant.
Ja, also ich habe das auch gelesen und sah das so, also wenn man mich gebeten
hätte, ich soll mal so im Sinne von Döpfner was schreiben, wir sind ja an so
einem Drehbuch dran oder weiß ich nicht was, dann hätte ich das vermutlich so ähnlich formuliert.
Ich finde was mich also das auch so Leute
überrascht sind so seine Haltung zum zum Klimawandel oder
so würde ich sagen es ist ja fast noch ulkig in
dem Sinne zu sagen ja so eine Wärmeperiode ist immer eine Hochzeit für eine
Zivilisation oder irgendwie so war die Formulierung ja das wundert einen doch
alles nicht also man ich was ich bei all dem nicht begreife ist dass man über
das schon Bekannte sich nochmal empört,
wenn man es einfach noch mal zweites Mal hat, also diesen Einblick hat und ja gut jetzt.
Ich habe den Text nicht mal zu Ende gelesen, weil irgendwann fand ich dann auch
okay, ich habe jetzt den Duktus verstanden.
Diese zwei Jahre Recherchezeit, gut wir können das hier, wir müssen ja auch
rechtlich sauber sein, aber ich finde es doch ein bisschen eigenartig, weil man ja.
Ja ich meine, wenn man Leaks zugestellt bekommt, dann kann man doch einfach
mal sagen, wir haben halt ein Leak da gehabt, es war keine Recherchearbeit,
wir haben einfach nur nur ein Stapel, den wir durchschauen mussten.
Aber das ist ja keine investigierte Arbeit im Sinne von, man hat jetzt selber
generiert, sondern es wurde eben halt, und das ist auch die einzige Möglichkeit,
wie man das bekommt, was heißt denn hier recherchiert, dass man selber noch
ein paar Texte geklaut hat aus dem Handy von Döpfner. Also das kann ja nicht.
Vermutlich nicht.
Nee, man hat nur das bearbeitet, was einem zu.
Ansonsten wäre es juristisch heikel. Deswegen muss man da nicht im Sinne von
das als große Recherche. Also das finde ich so ein bisschen lame einfach.
Nun gut, also eine Woche bevor Stuttgart Wache kommt mit diesem,
es ist ein Roman, es ist Fiktion, ich mache die und jene Übung,
um mich da irgendwie abzusetzen und so weiter, kommt die mit,
es ist Recherche, es ist legitim, es ist legal, es ist echt und,
ziehen diese ganze Debatte einfach rüber auf die ganz andere Seite von dieser
Unterscheidung zwischen Roman und Realität. Mhm. Und die hat dann entsprechend
auch das Kommentieren beeinflusst.
Wir hören es hier bei Sascha Lobo und seiner Frau Jule Lobo im Podcast,
die ja mit Feel the News auch so ein Angebot haben, wo man eigentlich sagt,
na, es könnte ja durchaus aufgeklärt sein, weil Feel the News könnte ja bedeuten,
okay, es gibt Nachrichten,
aber darüber hinaus wollen wir ja wissen, was kommt bei den Leuten an?
Aber genau hier wird diese klare Unterscheidung plötzlich hervorgehoben zwischen Roman und Realität.
Wir wollen versuchen und es auch immer ankündigen hier im Podcast,
diese beiden Ebenen auseinanderzuhalten, weil wir glauben, dass es wichtig ist
zwischen Fiktion und Realität zu unterscheiden.
Und dass hier aber immer wieder so fließende Übergänge habt,
das werdet ihr im Podcast merken. Wir geben uns aber große Mühe,
wirklich das anzukündigen, wenn wir eben über den Roman sprechen oder dann die
Ereignisse, die tatsächlich passiert sind.
Ja, und da hätte ich schon gedacht, naja, ist ja schade, also man,
klar kann man diese große Unterscheidung machen zwischen Information und Kommentar,
aber ich dachte insofern.
Aber wir haben ja History Has Begun gelesen, wir haben es heute schon erwähnt,
deswegen machen wir das eher mal nicht in dieser Weise.
Genau, wir machen es eigentlich lieber nicht und ich hätte erwartet in einem
Podcast, der viel The News heißt, macht man es mit Absicht nicht,
sondern reflektiert diese Überholung.
Ja, weil sie wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen, dass ihre Gefühle echt sind und
das andere ist dann wiederum Fiktion oder so, ich weiß es nicht.
Ja, Sascha Lobo problematisiert das jedenfalls auf die Spitze.
Und zum anderen ist der ganze Aufbau, diese Mischung aus Fiktion und Wirklichkeit,
tatsächlich etwas, was ich hochproblematisch finde.
Das ist jetzt der Vorwurf von Stuckhardt-Bacher? Ja.
Ja, aber was ist das für ein Unsinn? Ja, ich würde eben auch sagen.
Also der Mann ist ja, also ich habe eben ein bisschen böse über Stuckhardt-Bacher
gesprochen, aber ich würde ihm ja zugute halten, dass er Schriftsteller ist.
Also als Schriftsteller, wenn er nicht Fiktion schreiben würde,
was macht, dann hat er ja seinen Beruf verfehlt. Es muss ja darum gehen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Also nur dann wird es ja überhaupt erst interessant. Ja, und nicht nur das.
Alsas Roman Tod eines Kritikers ist nur deshalb interessant,
weil es die Fiktionalisierung etwas ist, Das ist, was er natürlich erlebt hat mit Reich Ranitzky.
Würde er aber einfach nur da sitzen und sagen, das hab ich hier mit Reich Ranitzky,
ärgere ich mich ja seit Jahrzehnten, dann wäre es vollkommen sinnlos,
sich dieses durchzulesen.
Nur als Fiktion überhaupt ist es interessant.
Und ich finde auch, die Domäne der Schriftstellerei, die mich ja selten interessiert,
weshalb ich jetzt einfach mal sage, noch wach ist nach Dave Eckers' The Circle
vor zehn Jahren, der zweite Roman, den ich jetzt so lese, ich will ja diese
Domäne extra geschützt haben.
Ich will also den Text für sich stehen lassen und mich dann hinterfragen,
was fühle ich denn jetzt,
wo mich ein Schriftsteller aufgrund seiner schriftstellerischen Leistung so
nah an etwas Wahrhaftiges,
was man erleben könnte, aber eben nicht erlebt, weshalb man es halt im Buch
nachliest, was befördert das denn in mir an Nachdenken, an Gefühlen und so weiter und so fort?
Und ich will gerade nicht aufgestört werden von jetzt kommt ein Einschub,
das ist die Realität und so weiter und das Zitat ist aber echt im Vergleich
zu den anderen, sondern nein, ich will ja, dass die Geschichte intrinsisch in
sich einfach eine Logik und eine Konsistenz hat.
Aber genau das, dass plötzlich jemand kommt und sagt,
ich will über ein Problem schreiben und mach es deswegen mit Absicht fiktional,
sagt jetzt Sascha Lobo, das ist aber kontraproduktiv im Sinne des Anliegens des Autors.
Jetzt kommt ein Mann um die Ecke, der ja eigentlich auch nur Futter gibt für
die ganzen weiteren, meistens sind es ja Männer, traurigerweise auch manchmal
Frauen, die sagen, ich glaub dir nicht, ist, ist schlimm, aber das ist nicht wahr.
Und Benjamin von Stuckert-Baches Roman hat ja eigentlich diese Unterzeile.
Das ist ganz schlimm, was da drin passiert ist, aber es Das ist Fiktion.
Das ist ein Problem, mit dem ich mich interessanterweise noch nicht so intensiv
beschäftigt habe, dass es etwas Erfundenes, was du gerade gesagt hast,
auf ein Problem hinweist, in dem es ganz häufig um den Vorwurf des Erfundenseins
geht. Das sind ja verschiedene Metaebenen.
Ich sehe, dass das am Ende es eigentlich sogar schwieriger macht,
sich mit dem Thema zu beschäftigen, oder?
Ist das, ist das MN, ist am Ende dieser Roman noch wach ein nicht nur so was
ein ökozentrisches Scheinwerferlicht auf Benjamin von Stuttgart-Barre,
sondern vielleicht sogar ein Bärendienst, was MeToo angeht, genau aus diesem Grund?
Das ist genau das, was wir erleben bei Documenta, bei all diesen Kunstveranstaltungen.
Bitte nehmt die Fiktion raus, macht eigentlich nur noch ein NGO-Projekt.
Lasst uns bitte nie mehr einen Roman schreiben, sondern ich will nur noch ehrliche
investigative Recherche über das Elend dieser Welt und beim Springer Verlag insbesondere.
Das ist wirklich diese Idiotie, dass man jegliche Kunst jetzt schon problematisiert,
weil sie nicht wahrhaftig ist.
Das ist eigentlich jetzt diese Ernte von diesen ganzen Fake-News-Debatten um
Donald Trump, dass man dann erst sagt, oh ja, die vermischen ja alles.
Dann wäre doch besser, wir entledigen uns ganz der Fiktion und machen dann nur noch den Fakt-Check,
das können dann Rezo und MaiLab in Personalunion, können die dann alle Fakt-Checks
dieser Welt, vielleicht können auch hier die Volksverpest oder was weiß ich mitmachen.
Und dann werden nur noch Fakten geschreckt und wer nicht Fakten macht,
der leistet einen Bärendienst für die, die noch die Wahrheit sprechen wollen.
Was ist denn das für ein Unsinn? Ich sag mal, wenn es einen Missbrauchsvorwurf
gibt, wenn es irgendeine andere Sache gibt, die vor Gericht gehört oder zu einem
Anwalt, was weiß ich, dann ist ja da niemand, der sagt, Ah.
Ich hab ja gestern so ein Stuckrad-Bacher-Roman gelesen, könnte auch Fiktion
sein. Also das ist ja einfach Quatsch. Das ist ja, da wäre ja genauso,
wenn man sagen würde, die Polizei kann nicht mehr richtig arbeiten,
weil wir so viele Tathort-Kommissare im Fernsehen sehen.
Du hast ja die ganze Dramatik dahinter auch schon in einer,
du hast ja eigentlich bisher zwei Filmanalysen gemacht,
die mal nicht einen Film in den Mittelpunkt stellen, sondern zum einen Menschen,
die ins Kino rennen und dann dieses Playbook von Amazon, die nämlich sagen,
ein Film kann nur dann wahrhaftig und überzeugend sein, wenn die schwule Figur
auch von einem schwulen Schauspieler gespielt wird. Weil ansonsten ist das ja unglaubwürdig.
Da würde ja jeder sehen, das ist ein Film. Das glaube ich nicht.
Ich breche jetzt nicht in Tränen aus.
So funktioniert es ja nicht, sondern es ist ja andersrum. Es kann ja durchaus
ein Künstler, und da sind es dann eben Kriterien, die auf Empfängerseite sind.
Den Anspruch haben, ich schreibe hier einen Roman, der ist näher an der Realität
als die Realität selbst. Kommt noch näher an die Realität als demnächst veröffentlichte
Zitate aus SMSen von Reichelt.
So, und da gibt es ganz einen Clip, den Stuttgart-Bacher selbst im Fernsehen
produziert hat, als das heutige Journal in dem Falle bei ihm war.
Ich will aber mal aus diesem Spiegel-Online-Text Sätze vorlesen,
die ich im Rahmen dieser Diskussion, wie sie Lobo hier einfach nicht akzeptieren,
besonders herausragend finde.
Also da sitzen auch Journalisten ihm gegenüber und fragen, ist das nicht eigentlich
ein Döpfner-Roman und so?
Und dann Pipapo Schlüsselroman und Stuttgart-Bacher sagt bei Schlüsselroman
denken alle an die falsche Tür.
Wenn sie Schlüsselroman sagen, steht nicht mehr der Schlüssel und der Roman
im Mittelpunkt, sondern die Tür, also der blinde Fleck.
Was öffnet man eigentlich für eine Welt? Welche Tür ist das?
Denken alle an die falsche Tür. Also es ist ein sehr mächtiger Satz,
finde ich, den er hier so eingestreut hat.
Und dann beim Thema, und der Reichelt ist das nicht, der Reichelt,
ich interessiere mich nicht für diesen Typen, also diesen Typen,
sondern für einen bestimmten Typus Mensch. Von dem erzähle ich in meinem Roman.
Das finde ich sowieso eine interessante Herangehensweise zu sagen,
ja wir haben natürlich eine Figur im Buch, aber die ist ja ein Idealtypos.
Die steht sozusagen als ...
Generalisiertes Paradigma für alle. Was mich beim Schreiben dieses Buches besonders
interessiert hat, ist Macht und das Magnetfeld um sie herum.
Macht und Geld, beide sind Herausforderungen für den Charakter.
Sich sowas genau anzuschauen, ist Grundaufgabe eines Schriftstellers oder des Künstlers überhaupt.
Macht und Geld, wir haben ja die ganz interessante Gewichtung bei House of Cards,
wo ja immer der Underwood dann sagt, Ja, es gibt sehr viele reiche Leute,
aber die Macht ist ja das Eigentliche und so weiter.
Also wo das mal so richtig schön idealtypisch gegenübergestellt wurde und dann
auch alle meinten, ja, hier wird es besonders deutlich dargestellt und dann
wurde er plötzlich selber noch zum bösen Schauspieler und dann hat das noch
so eine interessante Wendung bekommen.
Und da würde ich auch sagen, war ja dann eben auch nicht nur über sexuellen
Missbrauch oder solche Fehlverhalten und so, sondern Machtmissbrauch an sich.
Was bedeutet das eigentlich? Wo findet man ihn?
Man könnte sogar sagen, noch wach ist einfach ein Buch über dieses soziale Gefüge
und dann wirklich ernst nehmen, dass das halt ein Fernsehsender ist und springen
als ein Zeitungsredaktionshaus oder sowas.
Sondern da einfach nicht konkretisieren, sondern das Buch nehmen und abstrahieren
und daraus eine Debatte machen. Wo finden wir das eigentlich noch?
Wenn dann irgendwie Redaktionen in Deutschland sagen, ist doch alles gar nicht
so wild. Was heißt denn das eigentlich über diese Redaktion und so,
ja? Also diese Debatte könnte man ja führen.
Ich habe, und das ist super interessant, weil er dann auch häufiger so über
den Niedergang Trumps interessiert, also nicht Trump, sondern den Niedergang
Trumps und Sebastian Kurz.
Dann sagt er hier, ich habe tagelang mit Fabio De Masi gesprochen,
der als linken Politiker im Parlamentarischen Untersuchungsausschuss zu Wirecard saß.
Ich musste das genauestmöglich erfassen, wie sprechen solche Leute,
wie denken die, wie leben die, wie sagen die nichts? Untertitel im Auftrag des ZDF für funk, 2017
Bei Wirecard hatten wir das Phänomen, es ist eigentlich schade,
dass es da noch keinen guten Film oder sowas zu gibt, dass der Vorstand von
Wirecard Schauspieler engagiert hat, die sie begleiten, um bei Banken für Gelder zu werben.
Also wo die wirklich, sozusagen, ganz ins Fake und Fabrizieren gegangen sind.
Und das kann ich mir richtig vorstellen, wie er dann diese Geschichte so hört,
auch von Fabio De Masi, der das ja noch mal entsprechend erzählen kann. fasziniert ist davon.
Literatur ist absolute Subjektivität.
Bestenfalls kann sie dadurch eine tiefere, ein gemeingültiger Wahrheit freilegen.
Eines Menschen Fall als Fall der Menschheit.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man das so sagt, sondern es ist wahrscheinlich
erst eben, ich lese das Interview noch mal durch und dann, dass das schriftlich
reingeschrieben hat, aber ziemlich gut.
Ein Roman, also eine Fiktion, kann wahrer sein als die Wirklichkeit.
Das finde ich einen ganz wichtigen Satz, der ist unbedingt zu beachten.
Da gibt es einen Chef und eine Angestellte. Sie fangen eine Affäre an.
Aber ist es für beide gleichermaßen leicht, diese Beziehung zu beenden?
Jetzt sind natürlich Signalworte, Chef, Angestellte, Affäre und so.
Aber das ganze deutsche Familienrecht funktioniert nach diesem Prinzip.
Eine Verbindung zwischen zwei Menschen herstellen, die auch dann hoffentlich
noch bleibt, wenn sie emotional eigentlich ausgekühlt ist.
Über und dann kann man die ganzen Ideologien, wir geben ihnen Eigentum.
Männern, denen man Eigentum gibt, hören auf, auf der Straße zu demonstrieren,
weil sie dann plötzlich ihr Eigentum verteidigen.
Frauen fallen genauso in diese Opferrolle. Also da müsste man eigentlich auch
dieses Buch mehr in verschiedene Themen abstrahieren, als jetzt in die andere
Richtung, eigentlich in die falsche Richtung konkret, nach Döpfner und Dings zu fragen.
Er wird dann gefragt vom Spiegel, wie wird aus dem Konkreten erleben Literatur?
Und dann haben wir eben Holger Stark gehört, man setzt sich hin,
man recherchiert, man geht eben nochmal nach und so.
Er sagt, indem man sich rauszieht aus dem Getümmel, sonst ist es Journalismus.
Das ist so gut, dass es einfach zuerst den Anspruch haben, ich kann Wahrheit
noch besser als ihr und dann sagen, irgendwann muss ich halt nur rausziehen. Man muss halt ...
Drauf hinarbeiten, dass man Millionen Umsätze damit macht, die alle ins private
Vermögen gehen, sich davon im Vorfeld eine Insel kaufen, auf die fahren,
die ganze Zeit Instagram-Videos machen, wie man auf der Insel rumhängt,
und dann hoffen, dass diese Investition aufgeht und ein Buch vorlegen.
Und da will ich ausdrücklich sagen, anders als GPT, wo ich das letzte Mal gesagt
habe, wir müssen mal aufpassen, wenn man der Selbstbeschreibung der OpenAI-Chefs
folgt, besteht die Gefahr, dass man denen auf den Leim geht.
Diese Gefahr sehe ich hier gar nicht, denn wir werden, ich zumindest,
werde dieses Buch so richtig als Buch ernst nehmen.
Mir wird dann im Salon ein bisschen egal sein, ob das Stuttgart-Bach oder sonst
wer geschrieben hat, sondern ich will einfach wissen, was im Text drin steht.
Und ich will ausdrücklich dazu sagen, Samira hat zum Beispiel sehr gute Kritik
gemacht in ihrer Spiegelkolumne.
Es waren wieder nicht die Frauen, die in der Lage waren, selbst öffentlich aufzutreten,
sondern sie haben ihre Geschichten einem Mann erzählt, der seinerseits jetzt
die nächsten Millionen damit scheffelt. Und es stimmt alles.
Also es gibt viel zu kritisieren bei dieser Anlage des Buches und so weiter,
wie man das so macht. Ich finde, wir sollten das auch nochmal aufgreifen.
Wir gehen, wir gehen, aber wir trennen, wir machen folgendes,
wir werden einmal die Debatte nochmal aufgreifen. Ich will noch ein paar Dinge sagen.
Also ich will eigentlich nochmal so richtig auf die Pauke hauen von Stuckrad
Wache bis Luisa Neubauer.
Ich werde also nochmal alle, alle werden, werden im Safe Space vorkommen und
dann konzentrieren wir uns aber tatsächlich auf den literarischen Text und werden
schauen, was wir da rausziehen.
Ob er was hergibt. Du hast jetzt schon einige Themen angetippt,
die möglicherweise abstrahiert diskutiert werden müssen. Und die Literatur bietet
möglicherweise nicht den Schlüssel, sondern einen Eingang für diese Debatte.
Also hau du dann ruhig auf die Pauke, ich werde mich dann davon unterhalten lassen, ich werde...
Das Buch, den Text.
Ja, wir müssen auch mal ganz kurz, du hast ja auch reingehört,
wir müssen ganz kurz dann auch mal über diesen Boys Club Podcast und so was
reden. Aber das sollten wir auf jeden Fall noch machen.
Ich möchte jetzt außerhalb des Safe Spaces für die große Hörerschaft,
die uns hier zuhört, diesen einen Clip spielen.
Stuckart Barre wird vom ZDF gefragt. Ja, hier, es ist ja jetzt ein Roman ausgedacht,
aber es ist doch irgendwie Springer und so weiter.
Also wir sind so mittendrin, wir hören uns die Fragen und so weiter alles gar nicht an.
Die werden ja eh nicht mitgesendet, Sondern wir hören uns mal diese 50 Sekunden
an, in denen er das, finde ich, ganz fulminant auf die Spitze treibt und auf
den Punkt bringt, sodass wir das alle vielleicht dann doch irgendwann mal verstehen
können, worum es da so geht.
Das heißt dann, wir haben gelernt, da sind Fehler passiert, wird so weggehüstelt,
ja, da sind Fehlverhalten, aber eigentlich alles in Ordnung jetzt.
Und wir haben daraus gelernt, der Blick geht nach vorn.
Aber vielleicht wollen da Leute noch was hören, die darunter gelitten haben,
und die leiden da bis heute darunter.
Mindestens alle zwei Tage ruft mich jemand an.
In der Therapie geht denen gar nicht mehr so gut.
In diesem Fall, in dem ich Sachen bezeugt habe und miterlebt habe und diese
Erlebnisse mit hab einfließen lassen können in die Fiktion dieses Romanes.
Alle gehen da beschädigt und zerstört raus.
Und das ist Wahrheit.
Aber jetzt macht er ja diese Unterschätzung doch. Welche? Jetzt sagt er ja doch,
ich hab da mit denen gesprochen, jetzt kommt er ja doch wie so ein Dronadist daher.
Das ist doch einfach falsch. Ich find das das Geniale. Er sagt zum einen,
wenn Sie mit mir über Döpfner reden wollen, Ich bin Zeuge, Sie können gerne
mit mir darüber reden, aber dann in irgendeinem juristischen Rahmen,
wo das abgesichert ist und Mehrwert bringt oder wie auch immer.
Ich bin Zeuge von dem, was Sie alle interessiert, nämlich was ist in dem mächtigsten
Konkurrenten Ihrerseits los? Und dann, sagt er aber, und dann habe ich aber
eine fiktionale Geschichte geschrieben und die ist die Wahrheit.
Also man kann sich durchaus über die Wirklichkeit von Springer mit ihm unterhalten.
Aber wie er sich doch hier aufführt, Frauen jetzt, der sich das alles anhört.
Also Entschuldigung mal.
Wir müssen ja hier auch juristisch aufpassen, aber der Mann hatte zehn Jahre
lang einen Springervertrag. Der ist da ein- und ausgegangen.
Der hatte einen Vertrag.
Wir werden über all das im Selbstbestimmungs-Bestand. Aber ich,
also ich, für mich ist das, also sagen wir mal so, wenn die Bilder Geherz buben, oder ich...
Ab morgen sagen, wir haben uns immer schon für die Sportlichkeit der Nation
eingesetzt, dann ist das ähnlich glaubwürdig.
Ja, aber das meine ich. Also das ist mir ganz wichtig.
Ja, aber er gerät sich doch hier als Held, der als Wahrheitsträger irgendwas
mit den Frauen da… Achso, ja, das kann man überhören. Das ist ja entsetzlich.
Ja, ich finde das kann man überhören. Man hat jetzt ein Buch von ihm,
in dem das geschrieben ist. Und ich habe mich noch nie dafür interessiert,
wer ein Buch geschrieben hat.
Mich interessiert auch nicht, wie der, mich interessiert am Ende,
ob der Text gut oder schlecht ist.
Und so habe ich das immer gehandhabt, dafür lese ich ja zu viele Schlimmeres.
Also ich habe ja auch Solo-Album reingelesen, ich fand das auch nicht sehr gut.
Aber ich finde diese und darüber müssen wir noch mal reden, über diese mediale
Inszenierung, dass man das auch ihm zugesteht und dass dann auch da ganz viele
aus dem 1%-Feminismus mitmachen, diesen Wahnsinn.
Das kann ich nicht nachvollziehen. Wenn es jetzt nur darum ginge,
wir beurteilen einen literarischen Text, wird es nochmal anders sein.
Oh Gott, das wird Diskussionen geben im Salon.
Ich bin schon gespannt. Ganz kurz, ich will noch auf eine Sache hinweisen,
weil wir über den blauen Haken sprachen, das habe ich noch gefunden,
nämlich gestern hat sich dieser Kartonist und Aktivist Ralf Rute verabschiedet
von Twitter in einem unendlich langen Text, also hätte man auch fast einen Roman draus machen können.
Auf Twitter oder wo? Auf Twitter natürlich und ich will ja mal daraus zitieren, das ist ganz wunderbar.
Das hier ist mein Abschied von Twitter. Seit Anfang des Jahres habe ich neben
den Cartoons fast nur noch retweetet und selbst nicht mehr zu aktuellen Themen geschrieben.
Jetzt geht der Rollladen komplett runter. Ihr wisst es selbst,
diese Plattform ist ungesund. Ich habe Twitter jetzt eine Woche lang nicht genutzt
und keine Sekunde vermisst und dann geht das so weiter und hier sind nur noch Zombies und so weiter.
Es wird sich nur noch angebrüllt. Er führt das aus und warum er eigentlich da war.
Und irgendwann, wenn man immer weiter liest, weiter liest, weiter liest,
steht da plötzlich, drei Monate lege ich meinen Account definitiv auf Eis, ab Anfang Mai.
Im August gucke ich dann mal, ob die Horrorclowns alles komplett übernommen
haben und entscheide neu. Und als ich das las, diesen unglaublich langen Text,
musste ich an Heinrich Heine denken, an ein Gedicht.
Das geht nämlich so, der Brief, den du geschrieben, er macht mich gar nicht bang.
Du willst mich nicht mehr lieben, aber dein Brief ist lang.
Zwölf Seiten, eng und zierlich, ein kleines Manuskript. Man schreibt nicht so
ausführlich, wenn man den Abschied gibt.
Ganz genau. Ich muss da an Christopher Lauer denken. Kleine Anekdote.
Vor zehn, elf, zwölf Jahren, keine Ahnung. Er ist bei Hard Aber Fair oder irgendwo,
holt einen Zettel raus und sagt, Ich will ihm mal was vorlesen,
was ich mir vorher aufgeschrieben habe.
Normalerweise twitter ich das immer, aber ich wollte es mir mal wirklich und so weiter.
Und dann habe ich mit Schirrmacher darüber gesprochen. Ja, Christopher Lauer
hatte gestern so einen Zettel mit und hat gesagt, das ist für ihn das Anti-Twitter.
Er hat es extra so betont. Er will nicht mehr auf Twitter. Dann hat Schirrmacher
sich bei Lauer gemeldet und hat gefragt, wollen Sie nicht darüber schreiben,
dass Sie Twitter nicht mehr nutzen?
Lauer beschließt ein Jahr, also wirklich Twitter nicht zu benutzen.
Ich meinen Abschied von Twitter, verkünde das in einem großen Text in der FAZ.
Zack, paar Wochen später ist er wieder bei Twitter. Also in der Hinsicht.
Es gibt Leute, die brauchen diese Öffentlichkeit. Wir haben zum Beispiel viel
mehr Hörer als ich, Twitter-Follower, oder auch du, Twitter-Follower.
Nicht mal wir sind so krass davon abhängig. Für mich ist es wirklich nur eine
Spielerei. Und vor allem Sammelbecken, ich kriege sehr viel Input über Twitter.
Aber Leute, die ihre Abszinent von Twitter erklären, nichts Unglaubwürdigeres als das.
Und wer einfach nur privat ein bisschen auf Twitter gucken will und ein paar
Infos will, der braucht auf keinen Fall diesen blauen Haken.
Und sonst für die Vertiefung gibt
es ja dann lange Texte oder gibt es den Salon, da sehen wir uns wieder.
Wir diskutieren, also ich glaube, es wird ein diskutieren oder debattieren oder
streiten, was immer das wird. Ich bin sehr gespannt, wie du darauf blicken wirst.
Also wir sprechen über Noch wach von Benjamin von Stuckradbacher.
Wir reden dann noch über das Buch Kriegsfiebe von Alexander Kluge.
Außerdem will ich ein Buch vorstellen von Esther Kinski, die über die Magie des Kinos schreibt.
Und es gibt nun endlich diese Erhebung jetzt von Harald Welser.
Wie war es denn tatsächlich, wie haben denn die Medien berichtet?
Ich habe schon mal reingeschaut, wie viele Auftritte hatte Strack Zimmermann
in namhaften Talkshows beziehungsweise Interviews in einem Jahr?
Wie viele hatte sie? Über tausend Auftritte.
Wir werden uns also diese empirische Datenlage mal ansehen, werden auf dieser
Grundlage dann nochmal sagen können, wie richtig oder falsch Lagen trägt und wälzt er mit ihrem Buch.
Sehr gut, ich werde mich bemühen hinter die Paywall der Financial Times zu kommen,
um diesen Christian Lindner schlägt alles kurz und kleinen Text nochmal für
uns zu lesen und den Rest mal schauen, es gab ein gutes Angebot.
Sehr gut, dann sehen wir uns im Salon, wie gesagt, ob über Patreon,
Steady oder Apple, alles ist möglich. Bis dahin und einen schönen Monat.
Haut rein.